Previously on mobileMacs.
Du musst mit mir zurückkommen!
Zurück in die Zukunft!
Nein, nein Doc, bin grad erst angekommen, okay? Jennifer ist hier, wir wollten mit dem neuen Wagen Sportstour machen. Na gut, nehmen wir sie mit. Sie betrifft das genauso.
Nicht zu schnell, Doc, wovon sprechen sie?
Was passiert mit uns in der Zukunft? Werden wir der Idiot nur noch sowas in der Richtung? Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, Marty, ihr beide, du und Jennifer, ihr seid okay, ihr sind eure Papierpizzis. Wir müssen unsere HP-PCs retten. Unbedingt. Wir sind in Gefahr.
Ja.
Herzlich willkommen bei den Martetrinkern. Die sich alle nur mal kurz durchreißen. Was ist mit dir, Dennis?
Sehen die Dinger hier?
Ich kann die auch noch ein bisschen lauter machen.
Sicher? Die Batterien wieder alle.
Bei Dennis?
Also hier ist das so. Bei dem sowieso.
Nochmal aufladen, ne?
Wessen Nachrichten hier?
Ja, irgendwie. Warte mal, da gab es gerade eine Erreur. Den muss ich mal nochmal in nouveau starten hier.
Also der hier ist tot.
Ich bin drei.
Die V-Mode.
Du meinst da macht?
Ey, vorpippsch noch mal. Jetzt gibt es ja die guten Innaloop XXX, oder was?
Nur vom besten.
Und der hier connectiert sich gleich.
Bei uns in der Firma ist ja alles voll mit Innaloop und diesen Chargern, ne? Also richtig. Bei mir auch. In jedem Büro mindestens zwei voll mit Batterien. Unser Susat, der hat irgendwie eine fette Schublade voll mit diesen Plastikboxen. Jeder, der da ankommt, kriegt erstmal buff hier deine Magic-Maus-Batterien. Aber wir haben keine Triple A, das ist ein bisschen nervig.
Ihr habt Magic Mäuse?
Ja, viele.
Wir sind jetzt komplett auf Trackpads umgestiegen.
Gibt's auch schon einige Adopter, ja.
Aber die sind ja nicht mit Batterien, oder doch?
Da liegt doch eins.
Bluetooth.
Welche Taste ist hier die Stilltaste?
Das ist die 2.
Ich bin hier die 4.
Ich dachte du bist Max.
Ich bin Nummer 4. Das funktioniert alles nicht. Das geht immer wieder aus, wenn man drauf rückt.
Das ist übrigens noch die Pre-Show. Lasst euch vom Intro nicht verunsichern.
Ja, keine Ahnung. Na ja, wie das immer so ist. Bluetooth ist auch als Technologie, finde ich. Es ist wirklich on its way out. Das muss man häufig genug probieren. Hallo? Immer wieder probieren.
Es geht immer wieder aus.
Ich weiß nicht genau, worum das liegt.
Frag Tim.
Die ist auch noch tot.
Mach ich doch!
Ich muss mein GSM noch zwitschen.
Na ja, ich bin ja nicht Tim Cook. Bin ich Tim Cook oder was?
Na, du hast immerhin einen ähnlichen Namen.
Da ist was dran, ne? Da ist auch wieder einer auf...
Jetzt nicht mehr. Aber irgendwie hier funktioniert ja nichts.
Hier funktioniert zu laut, hab ich gehört.
Was? Ich bin ja nie zu laut.
Vorlaut meinte er vielleicht.
Nein.
Ja, hier Ausgabe 71 von mobileMacs und bis eben hatte ich noch das Gefühl, wir haben ja eigentlich gar keine richtigen Themen dieses Mal, bis mir dann einfiel, dass dieses ganze Steve Jobs Drama hier noch nicht ausreichend in aller Breite durchgewälzt worden ist.
Das ist nicht dir eingefallen, das ist uns eingefallen.
Ja, das stimmt. Also mir ist eingefallen, nachdem ihr mich darauf hingewiesen habt.
Ach.
Wie das immer so ist.
Ja, nachdem wir dich darauf hingewiesen haben, hattest du die Idee, dass wir das eventuell...
Genau, da du das Thema jetzt eingebracht hast, kannst du es ja auch gleich mal entwickeln.
Was soll man da entwickeln?
Steve ist weg.
Der ist ja nicht weg.
Doch?
Der ist nicht weg. Nein, nein, nein. Ich glaube, dass das Ganze ist... Das ist einfach wieder so ein ganz, ganz fetziger Masterplan, den sie da abgewickelt haben, von dem ich annehme, dass er seit seiner ersten, mehr oder weniger seit seiner ersten Anomalie, Körperanomalie irgendwie Teil der Gesamtplanung gewesen sein müsste.
Vielleicht taucht er ja bei Nokia auf.
Na ich gehe davon aus, also das ist ihm jetzt sicherlich nicht erst vor einem Monat eingefallen, dass er jetzt bald nicht mehr CEO sein will.
Kann.
Sondern das läuft schon länger. Ich meine, in gewisser Hinsicht war es schon ein bisschen absurd. Als diese Meldung kam, mich hat sie irgendwie nachts erwischt, als sie raus kam. Weiß ich gar nicht mehr. Kann so wichtig nicht gewesen sein.
War jedenfalls nicht der 11. September oder so.
Ja, ich meine, er ist ja nicht tot. Ganz im Gegenteil. Vielleicht trägt das sogar dazu bei, vielleicht ist das ja eine lebensverlängere Maßnahme in gewisser Hinsicht.
Ja, aber man muss ihm mal wünschen, ne?
Ja, wünschen wir ihm das auf jeden Fall. Alles Gutes.
Aber es gab ja nach der letzten BWDC, nachdem er die letzte Keynote gehalten hat, hat irgendjemand von der New York Times, glaube ich, irgendwie Fotos gemacht, wo er seine Frau noch mal, also so wirklich so zu den ganzen Fotosälen, wo er mit seiner Frau ganz andächtig und anrührig sich umarmt und so und irgendwie machte das da, ich vermute mal, dass er da schon wusste, dass das seine letzte Keynote war.
Ja, war das jetzt bei der iPad 2 Vorstellung?
Bei der DVD-C.
iCloud.
Also ich glaube weder, dass es seine letzte Keynote war, noch glaube ich, dass er es erst seitdem wusste.
Du meinst, er macht das dann wie Stephen Hawking im Zweifel noch?
Aber in einem besser designten Rollstuhl. Genau, er geht jetzt so lange zurück, bis Jonathan Easton...
Machst du mich ein bisschen leiser noch?
Auf jeden Fall wird das Text-to-Speech besser funktionieren, als bei Stephen Hawking, da bin ich mir relativ sicher, ja.
Hier beschweren sich Leute, dass Dennis zu leise wäre, aber Dennis sagt gar nichts, weil der Grund warum er so leise ist.
Den Dennis, den Lieder meinen, den haben wir auch gar nicht.
Der Vader.
Der hat nämlich nur einen N, ihr Scheißer.
Du bist zu leise, wieso ist denn Dennis zu leise?
Ja, Dennis ist wirklich ziemlich leise.
So haben wir was, Dennis.
Du steck mal deinen Kopfhörer rein.
Ich sehe überhaupt nicht ein irgendwas zu sagen. Wie klar ist der drin?
Hörst du überhaupt was auf den Kopfhörer?
Ja, doch, doch, doch.
Ich glaub schon, ja, doch, doch.
Ja, ich krieg dich hier auch eigentlich ganz gut rein.
Du bist aber auch... Also jetzt sind irgendwie alle...
Wer war das?
Also ich klinge super.
Ja, du klingst tatsächlich...
Tim klingt auch gut.
Ja stimmt, aber der Huckel ist auch so ein bisschen hohe.
Ich hab bestimmt auf den V-Modes gespielt und jetzt ist wieder dein Mischpuls zerschreddert.
Ist doch alles ein Scheiß hier.
Ja, was hast du denn gedrückt?
Alles.
Das ist die Anikitaste.
Das hatte ich doch verboten.
Du hast verboten, dass wir auf alles drücken.
Warte mal, jetzt muss ich hier eine harte Maßnahme machen. Mann, Mann, Mann. Warte, warte, warte. So, und jetzt...
Schon wieder?
Viel besser.
Oh, jetzt kannst du aber auch meinen Biss... Jetzt sind sie zu laut. Und ich?
Bin ich jetzt auch besser?
Jetzt ist es viel weg.
Auch in der 71. Folge dieses Podcastes...
Bin ich jetzt noch da?
Ja, du bist noch da.
Aber ich höre mich nicht so gut.
Aber du hast ein bisschen zu leise jetzt.
Ja, glaube ich auch.
Redet einfach mal weiter.
Das ganze Leben ist ein Quiz und wir sind nur die Kandidaten.
Wir raten, dachte ich, kommt jetzt.
Du hast aber jetzt nicht auf irgendwas gedrückt denn, oder?
Nee, wir haben nichts gedrückt.
Was soll ich drücken? Du warst doch eben gerade laut oder was?
Ja, du hast doch den Regler wieder runtergezogen. Hab ich doch genau gesehen, den roten. Der rote war es da unten.
Das macht mich fertig. Ja, aber der rote ist aber für alle mein Freund.
Echt?
Ach so.
Was ist denn hier los?
Man, jedes Mal das Gleiche. Ist immer noch ein bisschen dumpf.
Ja, ich bin auch immer noch dumpf.
Max, sag doch mal, was sie da hat.
Ich sag doch mal was und ich bin überhaupt nicht dumpf.
Mach mal einfach mal weiter, ich kümmere mich hier.
Das liegt einfach in meiner Podcast-Halbküche.
Wie war es jetzt mit Steve? Der ist jetzt weg, Tim ist jetzt da.
Hier fliegen gleich die Löcher aus dem Käse und jetzt geht sie los in Opoldo.
Was soll man denn erzählen? Hat wahrscheinlich ihr ja mitbekommen, oder?
Ich weiß nicht. Also eigentlich finde ich ja schon, dass irgendwie die Privat-Krankengeschichten von irgendwelchen Leuten in so einer Sendung ja nichts zu suchen haben. Aber ich glaube, wenn der abtritt, dann muss ihm schon ganz schön Scheiße gehen. Und da sind wir noch nicht. Wo sind wir noch nicht?
Dass ihm ganz schön Scheiße geht.
Dass er abtritt. Er ist nicht abgetreten. Meine Wahrnehmung der Situation ist, er hat lediglich seine Aufgabenbeschreibung geändert. Vorher gab es einen CEO, der aber als CEO gar nicht da war. Wir haben ja die letzten acht Monate, und man könnte fast sagen auch die letzten zwei Jahre, eigentlich schon in derselben Situation gelebt, dass er gar nicht alle diese Tätigkeiten ausführen konnte. Und ich glaube, dass dieser CEO-Stempel eigentlich nur quasi das offizielle Label war. Und sie haben jetzt nur das Labeling geändert. Woran mache ich das fest? Das mache ich daran fest, dass Tim Cook, der jetzt der CEO ist, war ja vorher der COO. Und wer ist jetzt der COO? Es gibt keinen COO mehr. Also sie haben diese Stelle überhaupt nicht neu besetzt, sondern Tim Cook heißt jetzt CEO, der ist jetzt CEO gelabelt, ein anderes Tag bekommen. Und er tut aber eigentlich genau das, was er vorher auch getan hat, plus, dass er noch so ein paar Executive-Entscheidungen eben jetzt auch noch trifft, die vielleicht vorher noch für Steve vorbehalten waren.
Warte, warte, warte, da hab ich meine Zweifel. Wenn das wirklich so ist, warum kriegt er dann plötzlich gleich erstmal eine Million Aktien irgendwie zugeschoben? Weil irgendwas muss sich da ja schon geändert haben.
Weil es nicht um ihn geht oder um Steve, sondern es geht um die Shareholder und deren Confidence in the company. Und dadurch, dass sie eben Aktionenoptionen, erstmal ist das vollkommen normales in einem amerikanischen Unternehmen, dass wenn du CEO bist, dass du irgendwelche Aktienpakete zugesagt bekommst. Das ist überhaupt nichts außergewöhnliches. Was sie ihm allerdings zugesagt haben, sind zwei Aktienpakete und das erste kriegt er in fünf Jahren und das nächste in zehn Jahren. Und das übersetzt sich in ja, er wird lange bleiben und wir haben vollstes Vertrauen in ihn. Also wir würden ihn auch zehn Jahre haben wollen, weil er ist so toll, dass er hier nicht in irgendeiner Probezeit läuft, sondern das ist alles mal alles genau so, wie wir das haben wollen.
Also für die Aktienunternehmer heißt das, naja, selbst wenn jetzt der Steve irgendwie aufhört, aus welchen Gründen auch immer, dann ist da jemand, der sich kümmert. Das heißt das.
Genau, da ist ja auch jemand, der sich kümmert, weil letzten Endes ist es auch so, dass einige der Eigenschaften, die Apple so in den letzten Jahren entwickelt hat, die meiner Meinung nach ganz entscheidend sind für den Erfolg, tatsächlich Tim Cook zuzuschreiben sind. Vor allem eben diese ganze Revolution im Supply-Chain-Management. Als die neue Truppe übernommen hat vor 12, 13 Jahren, da hat Apple eine Vielzahl von Produkten gehabt, ewig lange Lagerzeiten.
Aber der Cook kam doch auch erst auch im… Also der kam nicht von Nextstep mit, also von Nextstep?
Nein, nein, der kam von… Der war bei Compact für ein halbes Jahr. Vorher war er bei IBM. Und da auch so in diesem Bereich tätig. Dann haben wir den Compact irgendwie abgeworben. Und dann kam halt Steve und hat gesagt… Willst du wirklich bei Compact alt werden oder willst du was bewegen in deinem Leben?
Oder willst du… Wie war das? Willst du was bewegen oder willst du Zuckerwasser verkaufen?
Und dann hat er eben auch irgendwie…
Stimmt.
In meiner gewisser Hinsicht ist diese Konstellation zwischen Tim Cook und Steve Jobs wahrscheinlich auch deshalb so gut gewesen, weil… Also nicht nur, weil Tim Cook ganz erheblich jetzt eine offene Flanke von Apple, sozusagen, eine der größten Schwächen dieses Unternehmens ausgebügelt hat, sondern vor allem, weil er eben ein ganz anderer Typ ist als Steve Jobs. Und von daher kamen die so wunderbar miteinander klar. Weil natürlich Steve Jobs keinen Steve Jobs neben sich haben will, weil das auch gar nicht ginge. Solche Typen kannst du nur mit Leuten ergänzen, die anders drauf sind. Kannst du nicht noch so einen Typen gebären. Deswegen wird es da auch niemanden geben, der jetzt diese Rolle einnimmt, sondern die Rollenverteilung ist jetzt bei Apple eine andere. Und sie haben jetzt in den letzten Jahren darauf hingearbeitet, auch in dieser Rollenverteilung effektiv zu arbeiten. Und wahrscheinlich existierte diese Rolle, also war diese Rollenverteilung auch schon in Betrieb. Die haben die jetzt nicht gestartet. Die haben die jetzt offiziell gemacht.
Es ist schon klar, dass sie da schon darauf hingearbeitet haben und dass natürlich das wahrscheinlich schon abgekatertes Spiel, also dass sie sich darauf vorbereitet haben, dass am Anfang des Jahres, dass sie sagen naja, hier ist die Firma zu, wenn du demnächst irgendwie weil krank oder so weiter nicht mehr richtig kannst, können wir ja nicht dann plötzlich sagen so Steve ist jetzt weg und dann bricht der Kurs ein und so weiter, sondern du gehst jetzt mal langsam so in dein Medical-Leave oder wie das Ding da heißt, keine Ahnung, und dann ziehen wir das so ganz langsam durch.
Das hat bestimmt der Steve selber schon gedacht. Der ist auch nicht groß.
Kann auch sein, ja.
Da müssen die nicht hingehen und sagen.
Ich verstehe das ja auch.
Ja, ich denke, die haben das einfach, das ist, ich denke, dass diese Führungsstabübergabe, das ist bei denen genauso ein Produkt gewesen, wie das neue MacBook Air oder vielleicht, sagen wir mal, eher wie das iPad.
Weil man ja so ein fettes Unternehmen ist, natürlich bereiten die da irgendwie sich vor.
Ja, aber auch The Apple Way. Durchdacht bis hin zum Timing des Pressreleases, ist alles dabei.
Alle Kinos hat der vorher auch schon nicht mehr gemacht. Also nicht mehr allein hat der auch schon mal Leute eingebunden. Team Brook hat ja auch schon mal eine gegeben. Da dachten sie, wer ist denn der Typi?
Ja, und der macht das halt anders, aber macht das halt auch charming. Auch charming. Ich finde den eigentlich auch sehr angenehm, den Typen. Nicht nur, weil er Tim heißt. Ja, trotzdem. Weil Tims untereinander ist ja auch so eine Sache. Das ist auch mal ganz gut, wenn die großen Unternehmen von Steves geführt werden. Dieses Festivisierung. Ja. Ja, mal gucken, wen sich Herr Bäumer so ausgeguckt hat. Der denkt wahrscheinlich, dass er bis Ewigkeiten dann auch weitermacht.
Ja, und wahrscheinlich ist so dieser Eisberg so, dieser Eisberg namens Microsoft auch...
Schmilzt.
Ja, schmilzt, aber er ist so riesig, dass das einfach noch sehr, sehr lange dauert.
Der schmilzt auf jeden Fall. Naja, also insofern, ich bin jetzt nicht besonders beunruhigt. Das Einzige, was mich jetzt wirklich beunruhigen würde, ist, wenn er halt wirklich stirbt. Oder wenn er wirklich so krank wird, dass er eben auch in keiner Form irgendeine Tätigkeit übernehmen kann. Weil ich vermute mal, dieser offene Brief, den er gebracht hat, der wäre ja auch cool.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, richtig Sorgen würde ich mir erst machen, wenn er stirbt. Ich glaube, dann braucht man sich keine Sorgen mehr zu machen, wenn er tot ist.
Doch, dann mach ich mir Sorgen.
Achso, dann machst du ja Sorgen.
Also du gehst nun um Apple. Hast du dann gar kein Mitgefühl?
Doch, klar, natürlich. Ich meine, das wäre blöd. Ich meine, für unser aller Leben wäre das doof. Weil, ich meine, wenn man sich anschaut, was der jetzt für einen Track-Rekord hat, ich würde mir wünschen, dass wir noch weitere zehn oder zwanzig Jahre unter seiner Einflussnahme mit in der ersten Reihe sitzen dürfen, um uns das irgendwie anzuschauen, was dabei rauskommt. Ja. Weiß der Geier zu, was der sich noch...
Vielleicht ist er jetzt aber auch abgetreten, weil er schon so lange nicht mehr so richtig bei Apple mitmachen konnte, dass er schon sieht, wie die Firma langsam den Bach runtergeht, wenn man sich Final Cut anguckt und Xcode und Line und das gerade so für den Scheiß abgeht. Und da ist das, was ich denke, er verlässt mal das Ding in den Schiff.
Genau, man soll ja gehen, wenn es am schönsten ist.
Genau.
Hat sich eine schrickte Diät verordnet, um das alles glaubwürdig erscheinen zu lassen. Und rückt sich jetzt in die Karibik ab und hat eine schöne Familie.
Und geht jeden anderen piken und...
Ich meine, wir hatten das ja auch schon ein paar Mal. Weil so diese... Was mich eigentlich am meisten stört an diesem ganzen Computermarkt ist, dass die anderen alle einfach keine Eier in der Hose haben und irgendwie nicht in der Lage sind, auch mal irgendwie geil aufzutrumpfen.
Ja, das ist traurig. Das ist extrem traurig.
Dieses HP-Elend, ich meine, das ging ja jetzt, an dem wir letztes Mal schon drüber gesprochen haben, ging das ja noch weiter. Wie kann man nur auf so eine Idee kommen, irgendwie zu sagen, ja, unsere PC-Sparte ist ja irgendwie alles nichts wert und die verkaufen wir oder auch nicht. Aber eigentlich wollen wir sie nicht weiterführen, aber sie haben noch keinen Plan, wie sie die verkaufen wollen. Das heißt, die werden sie jetzt wahrscheinlich auch nicht verkaufen oder wenn sie sie verkaufen, dann wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr für viel Geld.
Das ist...
Ich bin immer fassungsloser darüber, was der da treibt.
Da kann man echt nur den Kopf schütteln. Das wird echt krass. Und dann ist auch diese WebOS-Geschichte dann, ja, das Touchpad läuft jetzt aus, dann verkaufen sie es für 99 Dollar. Und dann so, oh, das geht ja gut weg. So, und dann haben sie irgendwie so einen Desaster gehabt mit ihren Zulieferern, wo sie dann irgendwie Verträge hätten und so weiter, und jetzt waren sie quasi gezwungen, denen diese Bauteile abzunehmen.
Und dann haben wir noch ein paar draufschrauben lassen.
Ja, dann bauen wir halt jetzt noch mehr, das heißt, sie produzieren jetzt noch extra Geräte nach, die sie mit Verlust verkaufen dürfen. Ich meine, das hätten sie sich auch echt...
Wie kopflos muss man sein um sowas? Also, ich hab diesen Artikel gelesen, der ich weiß nicht mehr, wo der aufgetaucht ist. Wenn ich HP innerhalb eines Jahres zugrunde richten wollte, was müsste man machen? Ich meine, die haben einfach aufgezählt, was der gemacht hat im Laufe dieses Jahres. Und dieses Vor und Zurück und...
Hast du den Link noch? Vielleicht hat er den Link.
Wo hat der Apotheker vorher gearbeitet? Bei der großen Konkurrenz? War es da eine Konkurrenz? Aber er macht jetzt HP zur SAP-Konkurrenz, oder?
Nee, die haben schon ein riesen Business Unit. Irgendwie Services weiß der Teufel was. Da sieht er halt die Zukunft.
Das Ding ist aber auch, dass viele Leute der Meinung sind, das kann ich nicht beurteilen, dass es auch ihr PC-Geschäft ist, dass eben diese Services-Division quasi, also was eine Auftragsquelle ist. Weil die großen Firmen kaufen halt tonnenweise PCs und haben so ihre ganze Infrastruktur, dann kaufen sie sich eben auch noch den Kram dazu. Und ja, diese Artikel beim World Seed Journal, Happy's One Year Plan.
Das ist Apotheker, oder?
Ich weiß nicht, ob das der Apotheker ist.
Ich denk schon.
Sieht auch alle gleich aus.
Schauen wir mal hier.
Oh, Louis ist der Typ, der den Artikel geschrieben hat. Das ist Leo Apotheker.
Vor allen Dingen war er... Du bist jetzt gleich im falschen Fenster.
Ich bin immer im falschen Fenster.
Das war ja auch noch irgendwie diese Nummer, dass da dieser Marc hört, der irgendwie auf ganz merkwürdige Weise auch zurückgetreten worden ist, oder? Also steht ja so...
Ja, das war diese alberne Affäre da, angebliche Affäre mit irgendeiner Braut.
Die ohne Sex auskam.
Also es machte wirklich so den Eindruck, als ob da einfach so eine Kabale geschmiedet wurde, um diesen Typen rauszudringen. Das war wahrscheinlich das Schlechteste, was sie tun konnten. Zumal ja danach auch noch Oracle, also einer der Hauptgeber, sich danach noch einverleibt hat.
Versteht auch noch dieses Zitat von hier, wie heißt der Oracle Chef gleich? Larry Ellison. Das war die dümmste Entscheidung, die sie jemals getroffen haben.
Der ist aber auch ein Großmaul. Kein Wunder, dass er so der Freude ist von Steve Jobs.
Wollte gerade sagen.
Da gab es auch dieses geile Zitat von Sierra Cousa, da hat er doch irgendwie getwittert, und die Leute sollten raten, von wem das ist. Und irgendwie haben dann alle getippt, Larry Ellison, als war irgendwie so, Steve ruft irgendwie seinen Kumpel an, fragt ihm Rat und Kumpel sagt, oh fuck off Steve, it's in the middle of the night. Make up your mind and make a decision, I don't care.
Das hab ich auch irgendwo gelesen, wie Steve zu der Entscheidung kam, ob er zurückgeht zu Apple. Ja.
Ja, was haben wir da zu sagen? Also jetzt haben wir auf jeden Fall eine neue Aufstellung und es gab ja dann auch eine kleine Entscheidung, nämlich dass dieser Eddy Cue in diese Führungsriege der sogenannten Senior Vice Presidents aufgestiegen ist. Das ist ja quasi so das Executive Team, in dem Rahmen offensichtlich Entscheidungen gefällt werden, die jetzt nicht einer alleine fällt. Und interessanterweise war halt diese ganze Internet Division an der Stelle noch gar nicht vertreten. Das ist ja eh eine interessante Kombination, was bei Apple ein Senior Vice President ist und was ein Vice President ist.
Und dieses Bild, da meinst du, wer wem reportet, wo es die da mit war, drum rum, so was.
Also diese Vice Presidents sind sozusagen immer so die Chefs einer Abteilung. Und die Senior Vice Presidents sind Chefs einer Abteilung, die aber auch so als systemkritisch angesehen wird, dass sie eben zu dem Kernführungszirkel gehört, die dann, ja, was weiß ich, was sie da alles mit dem Einzelnen entscheiden. Und da ist eben jetzt diese ganze iCloud-Sache auch mit aufgestiegen. Durch den Typen, der natürlich dann auch gleich mit Aktien gesalbt wurde, etc. Das gehört ja auch dazu. Ich glaub, über Geld müssen die sich eh nicht so richtig viel zahlen.
Aber der hat nur 100.000 bekommen, den meinste.
Ich weiß nicht mehr genau, wie die Zahl war. LQ, das ist derjenige, der den Apple Store, den iTunes Store, etc. Also alles, was mit Internet zu tun hat und erfolgreich war bei Apple.
Also nicht Mobile Me?
Nein, das Mobile Me Team war ein anderes Team. Als Steve sie dann gefeuert hat, hat dann der LQ das übernommen. Und dann haben sie es mal richtig gemacht. Und das Ergebnis davon ist jetzt quasi iCloud. Ich sehe ohnehin iCloud als das Projekt an, wo sie... Das ist quasi ihr Internet-OS. Das ist neben iOS und neben macOS 10 ist iCloud das dritte OS, was förmlich über allem schwebt. Schönes Bild, ne? Cloud.
Auf Amazon und Microsoft Server, wie man lesen durfte? Angeblich.
Durfte man das lesen? Ich meine, sie haben definitiv auch ihre eigene Infrastruktur, aber sie nutzen teilweise auch noch andere Infrastrukturen mit.
Also ich hab auch das irgendwie so stichpunktartig gehört, dass auf Amazon und Windows sind. Aber gelesen hab ich dazu, also ich hab's nicht durchgelesen, ich hab's selber nicht überprüft und das ist, ich weiß nicht, ob's wirklich wichtig ist eigentlich, ehrlich gesagt.
Also man kann ja jetzt auch sagen, dass es ja ganz schön peinlich ist für Apple. Aber man kann natürlich auch sagen, dass...
Was ist peinlich für Apple?
Dass sie schon die Services der Konkurrenz nutzen müssen, dass sie es selber nicht hinkriegen. Man könnte aber auch sagen, dass Amazon und Microsoft schon so unbedeutend sind, dass sie jetzt schon für Apple die Cloud machen müssen.
Man kann aber auch einfach sagen, dass es im Augenblick... Das ist im Augenblick einfach noch...
Da würde sich Amazon eher drüber freuen, wenn sie für Apple die ganze Cloud machen würden. Aber sie machen sicherlich nicht die ganze Cloud, sondern sie werden einfach Teile, die sie derzeit nicht abdecken oder wo sie es aus anderen Erwägungen nicht als wirtschaftlich ansehen oder nicht erforderlich ansehen, das selber zu machen. Machen sie dann halt über andere Sachen. Ich meine, da zahlen sie dann halt Geld für die Bereitstellung von Infrastruktur. Das müssen sie, wenn sie die Infrastruktur selber bereitstellen, auch in die Hand nehmen. Und wenn das für sie einfacher ist, da jetzt erstmal an ihr eigentliches erstes Ziel hinzuskalieren, dann machen sie das halt so.
Ist das denn schon irgendwie bestätigt mit diesem, oder ist das noch weiter ein Gerücht? Weil ist eigentlich untypisch, dass Apple irgendwas...
Was bestätigt?
Nein, mit diesem Amazon- und Microsoft-Zeug.
Ich hab da gar nichts drüber gelesen, von daher kann ich da gar nichts zu sagen.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie sie das rausgefunden haben. Wahrscheinlich haben sie irgendwelche Server gefunden und haben denen mal einen Traceroute hinterher geschickt.
Der hat ja auch die Sekretärin irgendwo gequatscht.
Also ich meine...
Was war denn das für eine Quelle? Ich hab da nichts von gelesen.
Diverse.
Immer diese Quellen nennen, ohne Quellen zu nennen. Das ist überhaupt nicht journalistisch.
Ach so.
Wir haben links und rechts um die Ohren geschlagen von unseren Hörern.
Genau, weil ansonsten sind wir immer so extrem... Aus dem Hintergrund hat Dennis das. Hau auf Dennis ein. Hau auf Dennis ein. Dennis hat das.
Wieso? Ihr habt doch schon davon geredet.
Komm Max, jetzt red dich mal nicht raus.
Also ich hab damit auf keinen Fall angefangen.
Ach, das war hier sogar ein Zitat von Steve mit diesem Anruf. Ich paste das einfach mal so in den Chat.
Oh Gott, was sind denn das hier alles für?
Alle achten...
So bei Chipstands auch. Meinsin, gibt's hier irgendwas, was man halbwegs eye-touch, bei Heise stand nix. Guck mal mal hier bei Spiegel Online. So, jetzt da haben wir doch mal eine seriöse Datengefülle.
Register.
Apple kommt noch da hinten dran oder was?
Hat hier der Chat-Klien von...
Ach stimmt, die haben ja nicht...
Activation.
Ok, ist ein reines Gerücht, aber woher es kommt, weiß keiner.
Naja.
Aber jeder kleine Mini-Admin bei Amazon würde es ja wohl mitkriegen, wenn Apple da deren Services benutzt. Also es geht...
Und die haben da eine geringere Disziplin, meinst du?
Nicht so wie Apple, na klar.
Ich nehm das mal hier in die Links auf, ich weiß nicht, ob das stimmt. Das Register hat so sehr unterschiedliche Qualität, was so die Berichterstattung betrifft. Ja, sind wir denn jetzt schon... Gibt es da noch irgendwas zu sagen zu dem Thema Steve Jobs und so weiter?
Ich glaub ja nach wie vor, dass... Achso, Steve Jobs. Wegen iCloud. Weil du gerade das als OS bezahlt hast.
Hatten wir das schon so richtig beendet?
Das iOS oder das Steve's-Thema? Wir wünschen...
Ich bin also sagen wir mal so, ich bin mit der heutigen Situation nicht unzufrieden.
Ja, schauen wir mal, wie es nach dem nächsten Keynote aussieht.
Also ich fand es eher erstaunlich, dass der Markt so entspannt reagiert hat. Weil ich diesen Markt bisher immer als...
Ja, da gab es ja auch viele... Ich hab selber von mir auch immer gesagt, wenn Steve hustet, geht der Kurs nach unten. Und an dem Tag hat Steve nicht nur gehusstet, sondern war ja noch ein bisschen heftiger. Und der Kurs ging runter, aber am nächsten Tag war er höher als vorher.
Ja, der hat sich doch sofort...
Der ist auch schon an dem Tag nicht mehr gesunken als der Dow Jones Index an dem Tag.
Eben.
Also ich glaube...
Also da gab es eigentlich überhaupt keine nennenswerte Delle.
Jetzt mal so ein bisschen böse formuliert, Dell oder Microsoft wären glücklich, wenn ihr Kurs an einem Tag mal so wenig sinken würde.
Dell ist jetzt nach HP dann sozusagen der nächste, ne?
Aber die machen jetzt ja, die machen noch weiter mit...
Die machen noch weiter mit......Bereitschaften.
Die haben doch jetzt gerade sich mit China irgendwie einen fetten Deal noch an Land gezogen oder so. Irgendwas bauen die für Chinesen. Dell.
Du meinst, die lassen den China bauen für die Chinesen? Die Chinesen wollen doch immer Computer bauen. Was ist überhaupt mit Dell? Die wollten doch irgendwie komplett auf Windows Phone 7 umstellen. Dann hat das überhaupt schon geklappt.
Wer weiß, wer weiß. Warte mal, ich such mal.
Es gibt Telefone von Dell? Ach, die hatten dieses Streak oder dieses 5-Zoll-Tablet.
Das haben sie schon wieder eingestellt.
Jaja, wegen extremem Erfolg. Sie haben einfach zu viele davon verkauft. Nee, aber es gibt von Dell. Es gibt von Dell Endereute-Telefone, glaube ich.
Irgendwas mit Baidu und Dell war das. Dell to produce Smartphones with Baidu Software for China Wireless.
Ach, mit diesem Baidu.
Das ist nicht diese deutsche Firma?
Nee, Baidu, das ist diese Suchmaschine, dieser riesen Konkurrenz zu Google, die irgendwie gestern so ein eigenes Tadaha-Handybetriebssystem vorgestellt haben auf Android-Basis.
Android-Fork-Basis, so wie Amazon auch.
Hat Amazon schon was angekündigt?
Es gab einen Behind-the-Scenes-Artikel, wo vorgestellt wurde, was dieses Amazon-Tablet dann so kann und was es denn so besteht. Der Schreiberling meinte, er wäre sich da sehr sicher und hätte es selber in der Hand gehabt.
Wenn wir jetzt bei Apple gewesen wären, würden wir das Produkt sofort in den Schredder geworfen und nie wieder ein Sterbungswarnchen darüber verloren.
Ja, aber es ist jetzt sehr interessant, was jetzt passiert. Ich meine, es vergeht ja kein Kommentar-Thread, wo man einmal Apple und Android in einem Zusammenhang genannt hat, wo dann nicht gleich wieder diese Market-Share-Diskussionen aufkommen. Und wie erfolgreicher Android wäre und so. Das Ding ist nur, es gibt mittlerweile eine ganze Menge Android-artige Telefone, die zwar auf Android der Source-Code basieren, aber nicht auf Android das von Google lizenzierte Android, was ich auch so nennen darf.
Der Plattform.
Mit den Google Apps und mit der Google-Suchmaschine etc.
Ich hätte ein schönes Beispiel dafür.
Es nehmen jetzt alle diese Technologie, sagen Dankeschön, wir entwickeln das mal selber weiter. Das macht jetzt Amazon, das macht meines Wissens auch Baidu und es gab wohl auch schon andere kleinere Hersteller in China, die das auch ähnlich gemacht haben, sodass eben überhaupt nicht absehbar ist, dass wenn man jetzt sagt, Android-Telefone haben so und so viel Marktanteil, was sich davon tatsächlich um Google Android handelt und was sozusagen nur basiert auf irgendeinem Software-Stand von Androids.
Das wäre wirklich mal eine interessante Frage, was bei diesen Android-Aktivierungen, die immer so rumgereicht werden, was damit reinzählt. Ob das...
Na bestimmt nicht. Also dann bestimmt nicht die Amazon-Geräte und bestimmt auch nicht die Baidu-Geräte.
Kommt immer drauf an, wer die Zahlen postet, ob er groß oder klein haben will. Und wenn es die anderen sind, dann machen sie das immer riesengroß.
Na ja, man muss erstmal die Zahlen rankommen überhaupt. Und selbst Google muss rankommen. Also ich weiß nicht, also diese ganzen China-Geräte, klar, die von denen, da gibt es ja massenhaft, da gab es ja schon mit Android 1, 6 irgendwelche Tablets und da war auch kein Market drauf und sowas, weil die einfach nicht die entsprechenden Lizenzen gekriegt haben und die Kompatibilitätsansprüche und weil die auch viel zu scheiße waren, selbst für Google, um da irgendwie zu sagen, ja, da geben wir unseren Stempel drauf. Und das ist...
Ja, aber die Frage, die sie mir stellen, ist, wie, ich meine, unabhängig von den Zahlen, Tatsache ist, es gibt da über die eigentliche Fragmentierung des Google-Android-Markts hinaus, die es ohnehin schon gab, mit diesen ganzen verschiedenen Plattformen, dadurch, dass die Geräte so unterschiedlich sind, dass es keine Updates gab, dass sie alle unterschiedliche Versionen fahren, etc., und Unterschiede, dass jeder noch sein eigenes GUI mit drauf tut. Dazu gibt es ja nochmal einen kompletten weiteren Track oder mehrere Tracks, wo etwas Android-artiges jetzt genommen wird und es vollkommen unklar ist, ob irgendwelche Weiterentwicklungen an Android, die Google vornimmt, da überhaupt noch einfließen. Oder ob die sich nicht komplett wegforken oder zumindest so weitgehend wegforken, dass das eben auch für die Developer relevant ist. Für welche Plattform programmierst du jetzt noch, wenn du sagst Android? Das ist wirklich das große Fragezeichen. Und ich hab so den Eindruck, dass dieses ganze Android-Spielchen von Google nicht aufgeht für Google.
Das Gefühl hab ich auch. Deswegen haben sie doch Motorola gekauft, werden ihre eigenen Phones rausbringen, den anderen den Hahn abdrehen und dann selber Kohle verdienen.
Ja, dann wird HTC sich bedanken und schön auf Windows vorumgehen. Ja, ich meine... Also ist der größte und zweitgrößte Hersteller dann sind sie ja dann irgendwie alleine mit Motorola, die eine Firma ist, die kein Geld verdient und deren Marktanteil jetzt schon unter Ferner liefen ist.
Ja, die bei Google werden das schon hin drehen. Ich denke schon, da gibt es noch irgendwie einen dicken Apple-Gegenspieler.
Ja, aber welche Strategie siehst du denn? Also ich meine, wenn sie jetzt eigene Telefone rausbringen.
G-Phone mit dem eigenen Android, ordentlich gepflegt, vielleicht dann auch mal in schnell und dann kontrollieren sie noch besser den Markt. Also mit ihrem Gerät, was drauf ist und was da geht und was nicht geht. Können dann auch bessere Deals mit den Phone-Providern machen. Das ging ja vorher alles nicht. Nur die Software zu schreiben, hatten sie ja nicht so richtig das Melden.
Wie meinste, sie können bessere Deals mit Phone-Providern machen?
Na so Apple-Style halt. Darum geht es ihnen auch wahrscheinlich.
Ja, aber die brauchen...
Also ich glaube, die wollen jetzt einfach Apple simulieren, nur dass sie halt irgendwie vier Jahre zu spät kommen.
Wenn sie Apple simulieren, heißt das aber auch, dass sie ihr komplettes Revenue-Modell ändern. Derzeit ist es...
Nee, nicht das komplette. Den Rest werden sie ja nicht abstoßen.
So ist es ja nicht.
Von ihrem Werbezeug.
Meinen ihr Android Revenue-Modell?
Ja.
Na so.
Dass sie das ja total ändern.
Aber da verdiene ich wirklich viel oder doch?
Naja, das ist auch genau das, was ich sage.
Sie verdienen gar nichts.
Sie verdienen daran halt nichts. Wie kann sich ein Unternehmen sowas leisten?
Was verdient denn Apple an Phones? Wodurch verdient ihr Geld?
Ja, durch das Verkaufen der Telefone.
Ja, siehst du. Und das hat Google jetzt auch vor.
Ja, das heißt, sie ändern ihr Modell komplett, weil derzeit verkaufen sie doch überhaupt keine Telefone. Ich meine, sie haben da zwar diese paar Nexus-Phones rausgebracht. Nur der Punkt ist, während Google mit ihrem Android in dem Markt nach Zahlen zwar Erfolge hat, also was die Verbreitung betrifft von installierten US'n auf verkauften oder geschippten Telefonen betrifft, haben sie davon noch nicht unmittelbar auch einen Revenue Stream. Der ist eher theoretisch und basiert darauf, dass sie davon ausgehen, dass da ja viel Google-Software mit ausgeliefert wird, alle ihre Suchmaschine benutzen und dass sie am Ende ihre Kohle über die Werbung wieder reinholen. Und das ist halt schon sehr fragwürdig, wie gut das überhaupt funktioniert in the long run. Weil es gibt Schätzungen, wo sie dann vielleicht ein oder zwei Dollar pro User pro Jahr machen.
Deswegen auch nicht so schlimm, wenn die Ecke wegfällt. Wenn sie dann zum Beispiel bei HTC wegsprechen.
Ja, aber dann müssen sie jetzt auf Apples Turf auch noch zu Apples Bedingungen kämpfen. Das heißt, sie müssen ein Telefon bauen, was es mit dem iPhone aufnehmen kann.
Na, es muss nicht direkt mit dem iPhone aufnehmen können.
Da bin ich mir nicht so sicher, dass sie das so ohne weiteres können. Weil da müssen sie erst mal in der Lage sein, es so billig zu bauen.
Na guck mal, jetzt kaufen die Leute doch auch schon Android und jetzt ist es alles noch ein riesen Mischmasch. Man ist sich nicht sicher, ob man Updates kriegt oder nicht. Und jede Bude macht da noch teilweise, die spielen ja in den Gurchs darum richtig, dass jeder seine eigene Optik macht. Und das kann Google jetzt alles mal ein bisschen streamlinen und halt den Apple-Weg versuchen. Die müssen ja nicht genauso gut oder sogar besser sein, aber da ist noch genug Platz für jemand anderen. Also schon genug, wie viel Apple-Hasser es gibt. Die würden sich immer was anderes kaufen, selbst wenn es ein Stück schlechter ist. Vor allem, außerdem sehen die das gar nicht.
Ich glaube, dass Apple-Hasser, ja im Moment, überhaupt nicht entscheidend sind.
Es gibt noch Microsoft. Ich sehe da keinen Weg dahinter. Wenn ich an Google stelle, hätte Apple nachahmen wollen, dann hätte ich erst mal angefangen und mir das entsprechende Now-How gekauft und hätte angefangen, diese entsprechenden Telefone zu entwickeln. Davor scheint das aber zu lange zu dauern. Also haben sich jetzt Motorola einsbeingebunden, die ja nun Schweine Geld gekostet haben und wahrscheinlich auch, hast du es schon erwähnt, diese Sendung, Verlust machen im Augenblick. Und die Telefone bauen, die jetzt nicht total schlecht waren, aber jetzt wirklich richtig geile Sachen waren. Also das letzte wirklich erfolgreiche Motorola-Telefon war dieses, wie hieß es, dieses Klappteil? Dieses, was aber jetzt nicht sich dadurch ausgezeichnet hast, dass besonders...
Ich dachte, das Droid wäre das letzte Kohle.
Das Droid ist eigentlich, also Droid ist meines Erachtens nach eine Marke von Verizon, also nicht von dem Telefonanbieter.
Ja, aber gut. Aber eins davon hat halt Motorola gemacht.
Genau, da gab es dieses erste Droid, das war das erste Gerät überhaupt, und ich glaub, der einzige Grund, warum das überhaupt so... Also das war extrem beliebt, ohne Frage, aber ich glaub, weil es das erste Telefon war, was Android 2.0 hatte. Und das war der einzige Grund. Weil in dem Moment, in dem das...
Da sieht man mal, dass die Software sehr stark entscheidend ist.
Na, in dem Moment, in dem dann Android 2.0 für andere Geräte auch kam, haben nämlich alle gesagt, dass Motorola Droid das aber eigentlich ziemlich langsam, weil das hat einen relativ langsamen Prozessor, der dann von allen anderen überholt worden ist. Und ich fand's jetzt auch... Ich war sicherlich kein schlechtes Gerät, aber sie haben sich, glaube ich, jetzt nicht so die Top Edge Hardware-Marke da eingekauft, die wirklich ganz, ganz weit vorn ist, wie bei Apple, sondern es ist eher so... Ja, es sind ganz gute Telefone, die die bauen.
Auch Telefone immer mal wieder von der Konkurrenz überholt werden, das ist doch ganz normal. Wenn das nächste iPhone 5 nicht mit einem Dual-Prozessor rauskommt, dann werden auch die anderen Telefone oder ein paar zumindest mit einem Dual-Prozessor rauskommen. Dann werden alle sagen, naja, das iPhone 5 ist jetzt aber auch nicht das Schnellste. Das war auch schon mal so, wo die ersten Kisten mit einem Gigahertz rauskamen und Apple dann noch ein bisschen hinterher war. Das ist doch immer so, die überholen sich doch immer wieder so ein bisschen gegenseitig, wenn man es von der Hardware betrachtet.
Ja, aber worüber redet ihr jetzt gerade? Ich kann überhaupt nicht mehr folgen, was eigentlich euer Kern-Aussage ist.
Ob Google, glaube ich, eine Chance hat mit dem Aufkauf von Motorola so eine Position wie Apple einzunehmen.
Ja gut, aber worüber konkret?
Wir waren gerade abgedriftet, wir geben es zu.
Ja.
Aber ich fand es lustig, wir können gerne noch ein bisschen abdriften.
Ich meine, das mag ja, also angenommen, also ich kann mir das nicht so richtig vorstellen, dass sie jetzt wirklich sagen, ach naja, unser bisheriges Modell, was sozusagen auf der Ist-Situation des gesamten Google-Konzerns basiert, dass wir einfach Werbung verkaufen, das ist ein Werbeunternehmen. Jetzt machen wir mal geile Handsets. Wir kaufen uns eine Firma, die genauso groß ist wie wir und ab heute sind wir dann so gut wie Apple. Ich meine, da glaubt auch keiner dran.
Natürlich nicht, aber dann sag mir, warum die Motorola kaufen. Das muss sein Grund haben. Die geben ja nicht um wie viel? 8 Milliarden, 9 Milliarden Dollar aus. Ach, das war es, glaube ich.
Ich habe keine Erklärung dafür. Ich kann dir das nicht erklären.
Und du meinst, meine Erklärung, die wäre nicht so cool.
Was genau ist deine Erklärung? Nochmal? Also, dass sie ihr Geschäftsmodell drehen. Ja, dass sie ihr Geschäftsmodell bauen wollen.
Sie wollen halt jetzt Software mit Hardware verbinden. Das, was halt sonst keiner kann. Das können nur die und Apple. Und Microsoft auch noch nicht mal, weil sie auch kein Hardware-Business haben.
Da brauchst du ja jetzt Nokia.
Dann, also so haben sie ja ein bisschen verschleiert, aber wenn die sich so richtig doll zusammentun, dann ist auch die ja. Und dann wird es demnächst auch nur die drei geben, weil alle anderen werden sozusagen über den Softwareweg ausgetrocknet, weil dann kann HTC nämlich auch nichts mehr machen, außer sich irgendwo, ja, weiß nicht, bei Microsoft irgendwie klingeln. Und dann kriegen die aber auch nicht doll viel.
Also HTC kann, glaube ich, vorher noch mal forken.
Um es mal ganz ehrlich zu sagen, ohne Software kommst du heutzutage nicht mehr. Weil es ist jetzt sozusagen beim Telefon das angekommen, was bei den Rechnern jetzt auch schon seit langer Zeit so ist. Ohne Software geht da nichts.
Okay, ich sag's mal so, ja? Wenn Google jetzt selber anfängt, sozusagen voll auf das Apple-Modell zu setzen und Software und Hardware und wir setzen jetzt voll auf das Gerät und nicht auf ein damit verbundenes Werbemodell, dann sag ich nur, they just can't walk in. Also, welche Kompetenz siehst du bei Google, die dieses Modell stützt? Wo soll das auf einmal herkommen? Die werden sich jetzt so aufreiten.
Die Kompetenz ist bei denen, liegt auf der Bank und hat irgendwie...
Nee, mit Geld kannst du das nicht vorwärts. Wenn es so wäre, dann hätte Microsoft da schon große Erfolge gelandet. Alle haben's verpennt.
Bei Microsoft ist doch bekannt, dass die immer alles verpennen und dann irgendwie zu spät kommen.
Jetzt haben wir doch mal eine Firma in diesem Smartphone-Markt, die irgendwie ein geiles Produkt hat, über die alle reden. Über das alle reden.
Über die Samsung-Geräte wird sehr viel gesprochen, seitdem sie vom deutschen Markt verklagt wurden.
Die, die nicht verkauft werden dürfen?
Diese Touch-Petzer sind weggehend wie warmes Himmel.
Eigentlich ist doch der Google-Move schon, also sieht doch schon sehr kalkuliert aus. Also pass auf, die denken sich, sie kamen schon zu spät, weil sie haben erst mal Apple irgendwie, da gab es ja schon Gerüchte, bevor das iPhone rauskommt, dass Apple dem nächsten Telefon rausging, ging ja schon ein Jahr vorher los. Wenn man sich die Source kurz anguckt, weiß man, dass es schon 2004 haben die da schon losgekodet, also das hat Apple schon ein paar Jahre vorher geplant. Ich weiß nicht, wann Google davon Wind bekommen hat. Ich weiß nicht, wann der Schmidt irgendwie rausgeflogen ist oder gegangen wurde, wie auch immer. Jedenfalls wusste auch Google, dass sie nicht von heute auf morgen die Hardware plus irgendwie die Software rausbringen können. Also was machen sie? Sie schummeln sich erst mal dieses Anduit in den Markt, machen da eine Weile Feinschliff, bis es einigermaßen okay ist, schaffen erst mal die Basis und schieben jetzt die Hardware hinterher. Es ist doch eigentlich total schlau, wie hättest du es denn anders machen wollen?
Schon sieben Jahre später geht der Plan perfekt auf.
Man hätte sie zum Beispiel Motorola zu einem Zeitpunkt kaufen können, wo sie irgendwie nicht zwölf Milliarden Euro ist, aber dafür bezahlen müssen.
Also ich meine, also das sah doch ziemlich nach einem Panikkauf aus.
Die haben vorher noch den, die haben noch vorher sich dann noch so wertvoll präsentiert und angebandelt und war da nicht auch mit...
Aber jetzt sagt man gerade, dass es denen so schlecht geht, da hätten sie noch viel mehr bezahlen müssen.
Hätte Google irgendwie 2004 oder 2005 angefangen, ein Telefon zu entwickeln und hätte sich langsam angefangen, die entsprechende Kompetenz aufzubauen...
Dass die hinterher sind, ist schon klar.
Also wenn sie so einen langfristigen Plan gehabt hätten, dann hätten sie mehr als genug Zeit gehabt, auch sich ihre eigene Hardware-Abteilung dafür aufzubauen, hätten dafür einen Bruchteil des Geldes bezahlt und hätten wahrscheinlich im Wesentlichen besseres Ergebnis als sie jetzt haben.
Also wenn sie als Gerätehersteller erfolgreich sein wollen, dann müssen sie da irgendwie einen Brand schaffen, wo die Leute irgendwas mit assoziieren. Motorola hat natürlich einen Brand, aber dass die jetzt ein besonders gutes Standing haben, weltweit, ja, das kann man so nicht sagen. Die hatten mal eine gute Zeit und es mag auch immer noch eine Menge Leute in den USA geben, die sagen, oh ja, ein Motorola-Telefon, das kaufe ich mir gerne. Aber Android ist im Konsumermarkt derzeit einfach noch keine Größe. Das mögen zwar viele Leute auf ihrem Telefon haben, aber bestimmt nicht, sind die in den Laden reingegangen und gesagt, ich möchte das tollste Android-Telefon haben, sondern die gehen da rein, wie das die Leute einfach zum Telefonladen machen und sagen, ich brauch ein neues Telefon, mein altes ist kaputt oder ich hab gehört, es gibt das jetzt auch in der Brause.
Du meinst, die meisten wissen gar nicht, dass ein Android drauf ist?
Nein, da kommt einer der Händler und sagt, ja, ach, sie brauchen gar kein iPhone hier, das ist ja viel besser, weil das hat irgendwie eine 0,2 hinter dem Komma bei irgendeinem Wert. Ja, da ist der Bildschirm ja etwas größer, das ist ja viel besser. Und dann sagen die, ja, alles klar, ich kauf das. Dass das Android ist und dass da irgendwie theoretisch eine Plattform, ein Ökosystem dahinter ist, das erschließt sich den wenigsten. Das ist natürlich in Nerd-Kreisen ganz anders. Aber die Nerd-Kreise sind an der Stelle überhaupt nicht entscheidend.
Also 2009 hätten sie Motorola maximal günstig für unter 10 Milliarden bekommen können. Davor und danach war es mehr wert.
Sie hätten sie ja überhaupt nicht so einen Laden kaufen müssen. Sie hätten sie auch genauso machen können wie Apple. Ich meine, Apple hat sich auch nicht einen Telefonhersteller gekauft, sondern hat sich einfach zu einem Telefonhersteller werden lassen. Die haben sich einfach hingesetzt und haben das einfach selber gebaut und gelernt, wie man das macht. Und an manchen Stellen halt besser als die etablierten Firmen zu dem Zeitpunkt.
Weil es ja auch erst jetzt geht, dass man irgendwie sich da seinen Baseband-Chip irgendwie einkauft. Das wäre vorher nicht gegangen. Zehn Jahre vorher hätten sie das Somehow von Google haben müssen, hätten es nicht gehabt. Und da wäre es einfach nicht funktioniert.
Ich sehe einfach nicht, wie dieser Plan aufgehen soll. Ich stehe gerne hier in einem Jahr. Und lasse mir das erzählen, wie erfolgreich dieser Deal gewesen ist. Aber ich halte diese ganze Motorola-Geschichte für einen totalen Fail.
Vielleicht bin ich da auch einfach nur optimistisch, aber ich kann mir nicht anders vorstellen, wie Google sich das sonst denkt.
Ich glaube, die haben sich nicht so nett viel gedacht. Ehrlich gesagt, ich habe das Gefühl, dass die...
Bei 12 Milliarden denkst du schon so ein bisschen.
Also hier ist der Graph von Motorola Mobility. Ich habe vorher falsch geguckt.
Aber die gibt es ja noch nicht so lange.
Ja, aber hier im September geht die Kurve auf jeden Fall steil nach oben davor. Hat es nur 7 gekostet.
Ja, die haben da noch mal ordentlich was drauf gelegt.
Die haben sich ausnehmen lassen.
Aber richtig. Ich habe das Gefühl, dass es mit Google gerade......
bergab geht? Ja. Ist Google Plus schon wieder gestrichen?
Naja, noch nicht ganz.
Aber irgendwie...
Ich meine, so nehmen wir mal an, das war jetzt mit Motorola ein Fehler, wovon ich jetzt im Augenblick erstmal ausgehe. So eine Fehler kann sich auch eine sehr, sehr reiche Firma nicht beliebig viel erlauben.
Ja, ich würde den Teufel auch nicht immer gleich an die Wand malen.
Na ja, bis die 12 Milliarden wieder drin sind, vergeht eine ganze Menge Zeit.
Ich will weiter an dir unterstreichen. Ich bin weiter an Google, ist evil und so, von mir aus.
Aber keiner weiß derzeit, was sie vorhaben.
Hab ich doch gerade gesagt.
Du weißt es nicht, du glaubst es.
Das sieht doch genau so aus.
Ja, es herrscht vollkommen eine Ungewissheit. Und vor allem herrscht diese Ungewissheit auch genauso. Zum Teil in der Developer-Community. Weil in diesem Android-Markt Geld zu verdienen ist schwierig. Es ist unmöglich, aber es ist schwierig. Es hat viel was mit deiner Kundenverkaufung zu tun, mit hier irgendwie Incentives zu subscriben und werbefinanziert etc. Aber einen Bezahlmarkt gibt es dort nicht. Und vor allem über Telefone hinaus ist Android nicht existent.
Dann stelle ich dir die Frage mal ein bisschen anders. Dann ist es ein bisschen fieser. Warte, warte. So Tim, was würdest du denn an Googles Stelle machen?
Was würde ich an Googles Stelle machen?
Also du kannst dir jetzt sogar zwei Szenarien aussuchen, wo du einsteigst. Entweder den jetzigen Zeitpunkt oder kurz, also als sie noch nicht Motorola gekauft hatten.
Du meinst jetzt in Bezug auf Smartphones.
Also in Bezug auf Android halt. Ja irgendwas müssen sie ja vorhaben.
Ich kann so lange mal sagen, was ich glaube, was ich machen würde. Ich hätte, ähm, würde mir jemanden für User Interfaces einbauen, um das Ding ein bisschen cool zu machen. Ich würde die Hersteller probieren, richtig an die Kantarie zu nehmen, in Sachen bringt Updates raus für die Dinger, sorgt dafür, dass die immer den gleichen Softwarestand haben, eine Plattform festlegen, was sozusagen die Gold-Referenz ist, was einzuhalten ist, klare Regeln definieren, was auf die Geräte drauf muss, was nicht drauf sein darf, um für die Entwickler ein halbwegs homogenes System zu schaffen. Ich würde den Store komplett überarbeiten, viel, viel bessere Zahlungssysteme einbauen, sodass das alles wirklich vernünftig läuft. Da haben sie irgendwie nach wie vor kein Hemdchen.
Sag es, Max. Das, was du beschreibst, ist...
Scheiße.
Windows Phone 7. Das ist exakt Microsofts Strategie, was du da gerade beschreibst. Und das finde ich insofern auch sehr interessant. Microsoft hat das nämlich verstanden. Die haben genau analysiert, was die Probleme bei Android sind. Oder vielleicht haben sie es nicht bewusst gemacht, sondern nur unbewusst, weiß ich nicht. Aber Tatsache ist, dass sie genau diese Punkte, die man so bei Android gerne kritisiert, und ich finde auch zu Recht, dass das eben da anders ist. Und sie haben halt vor allem ein klares Modell. Das muss man Microsoft zugute halten. Sie sagen, wir bauen euch die Software, ihr zahlt dafür. So, klarer Deal. Du kannst Telefone bauen, du holst dir die Software von Microsoft und du kriegst dafür aber auch eine Infrastruktur, die die notwendigen Voraussetzungen hat, dieses Sicherheitsproblem anzugehen, das Softwarequalitätsproblem anzugehen, Softwareupdateproblem anzugehen. Das Problem an der Stelle allerdings ist, ich sage nicht, dass das jetzt der Gewinnerweg ist, ich sage nur, dass es der Weg, den Microsoft eingeschlagen hat. Microsoft muss aber auch, um das sicherzustellen, Anforderungen, Mindestanforderungen an die Hardware stellen, was sie ja tun. Das heißt, dass die Telefone dann aber auch weitgehend identisch sind. Und von daher so Diversifikation so ohne Weiteres nicht möglich ist. Und am Ende kommt es eigentlich immer wieder drauf hinaus, dass Apple an der Stelle irgendwie von allem die beste Mischung hat. Sie haben alles unter Kontrolle. Sie haben da irgendwie ein Sicherheitsmodell. Sie haben ein Abqualitätsmodell. Sie verdienen überall.
Und ich finde, das spricht alles dafür, dass Google das jetzt genau so macht. Sie bringen selber das Phone raus, haben den Markt im Griff, haben die Geräte im Griff, haben die Updates dann noch nicht. Haben die Updates dann im Griff. Also alle Probleme, die gerade da sind, könnte man dadurch lösen, dass Google das Phone und das OS selber macht. Und ihre Partner können sie ja noch ein, zwei Jahre mitschleifen und werden die dann aber langsam das Wasser abgraben und werden die austrocknen lassen.
Ja, aber die Margen scheinen bei all diesen Modellen nicht besonders toll zu sein.
Ja, aber was an Marge möglich ist, zeigt der App hervor. Also, dass da was geht und dass Leute auch bereit sind, wenn Hardware, Software und Update und Service stimmt, dass man da ein bisschen was nehmen kann.
Das stimmt mehr als nur das. Und das sind alles Bereiche, in denen Google, also Google hat keinen eigenen Verkauf. Google hat ein unglaublich schlechtes Marketing. Motorola weiß ich nicht, ob die überhaupt, also die werden auch ein Marketing haben, aber das kenne ich jetzt keiner.
Also mit dem Verkauf glaube ich, ist da noch das geringste Problem.
Ich glaube, das ist gar nicht so ein kleines Problem. Diese ganzen, Apple hat diese unglaublich vielen Stores.
Ich war noch nie in einem Store und habe irgendwie seit vier Jahren ein iPhone.
Ja, aber das geht anderen Leuten anders. Es gibt sehr viele Leute, die kaufen...
Die meisten Leute kaufen noch nicht im Apple Store. Die bestellen online.
Die Leute gehen in den Laden und kaufen da.
Auf welchem Planeten kommt ihr denn, ey?
Aber dir ist schon bewusst, dass der Apple Store als Laden der erfolgreichste Laden ist. Weltweit, von allen Läden. Also nicht von Computerläden, sondern von allen Läden, die irgendwas verkaufen. Nichts ist so profitabel wie ein Apple Store.
Das heißt der Bioladen und meine Straße?
Einschließlich Juwelierläden, Klamottenläden und Supermärkte.
Es gibt niemanden, der pro Quadratmeter so viel Gewinn macht wie Apple.
Ich hab hier noch eine schöne Grafik. Ich werf das auch gleich mal in den Chat hier, damit alle mitgucken können.
Und selbst wenn du online das Zeug kaufst, ich war in diesem Apple Store in Dresden und ich wollte mit einem iPad rausgehen und ich bin mit zwei iPads rausgegangen. Dieser Laden, die haben da ein geiles Ladenkonzept. Das hat Google natürlich nicht. Und daran ist ja auch dieses Nexus One Stück weit gescheitert, als es probiert haben, das selber zu verkaufen. Nämlich, dass es null funktioniert hat. Niemand hat dieses Telefon gekauft. Und dann haben sie sich doch den Providern wieder anbiedern müssen. Und Motorola hat auch keine Geschäft. Die kennen auch nur das Geschäft über die Provider und die Provider diktieren, unter welchen Bedingungen man in den Laden kommt. Außer du hast so ein geiles Gerät wie Apple, das hat die entsprechenden Provider angekrochen. Und ich sehe nicht, dass Google da irgendwie...
Und sie knicken auch ein. Ich habe jetzt gerade gelesen, dass das neueste 3er Android-Update jetzt auch das Tethering ausschaltet.
Nee, das ist nicht 3, das ist 2, 3, 6 oder irgendwie so was. Das gibt es noch.
Ja, entschuldigung, ich meinte auch 2er. 2er, 3er ist das Honeykump-Zeug.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das ein Bug ist, obwohl noch nicht so richtig klar kann sein, dass das ein Bug ist.
Hallo?
Man weiß es einfach.
Das merkt man. Das merkt man auch als Entwickler, wenn plötzlich das Tethering nicht mehr geht. Also das kann mir keiner erzählen.
Wir werden es sehen. Es kann auch ein Bug gewesen sein, es kann auch sein, dass es Absicht ist. Ich hab keinen blassen Schimmer, aber irgendwie hab ich das Gefühl, dass...
Ich verstehe deine Grafik dann nicht.
Was ist das denn für eine Grafik?
Ich hab hier mal diese Auswertung von Asymco. Der hat ja immer diese schönen Analysen.
Der hat sich mal...
Ist das der Preis und Profit angeschaut der Smartphone-Hersteller?
So einer Breite ist es sozusagen der Marktanteil und einer Höhe ist es aber der Gewinn.
Genau.
Und Apple hat so einen ganz schmalen Streifen an Marktanteil. Sagen wir es 5% oder was sind das? 10% sind es nicht.
Unit-Share heißt das.
Aber irgendwie verkaufen 8-fache von dem, was Nokia einnimmt.
Und die leere Box nach oben hin ist der Ladenpreis von dem Gerät. Und die gefüllte ist der...
Du musstest es wohl auch mal verlinken jetzt hier im Chat.
Im Chat ist es schon drin.
Man muss es vielleicht etwas plastischer umschreiben. Also hier sind die Firmen aufgeführt. Apple, RIM, HTC, Motorola, Samsung, Nokia, Sony, Ericsson und LG. So als die wesentlichen Teilnehmer in diesem ganzen Telefonmarkt weltweit.
Also Apple verdient an jedem Gerät schon mehr als die anderen Kosten.
Also so kann man das auch sagen. Also hier sind halt die Verkaufs... Also was man hier raus sieht ist, Apple hat einen... kann sich derzeit einen unfassbaren Entverkaufspreis leisten. Also sie sind in der Lage, das iPhone deutlich teurer anzubieten als alle anderen und sie werden trotzdem gekauft. Und der Grund dafür, denke ich, liegt auf der Hand. Sie haben einfach eine extrem starke Marke, wo die Leute einfach dabei sein wollen. Auf der einen Seite und auf der anderen Seite haben sie vermutlich auch ein extrem starkes Produkt, was die Leute einfach auch wertschätzen. Da sind wir uns wahrscheinlich auch alle einig.
Also die gesamte Infrastruktur...
Diese Verkaufspreise erzielt keiner auch nur im Ansatz. Die teuersten hier in der Aufstellung sind HTC mit 350 Dollar und Apple liegt halt locker bei 650 Dollar ungefähr. Und die Marge, die sie da fahren, ist halt auch extrem gut, sodass sie eben im Schnitt an jedem Gerät 300 Dollar gewinnen. Machen. Im Schnitt. Und die anderen, der Beste ist derzeit noch RIM und diese Zahl ist dwindling, liegt gerade mal so bei ungefähr 80 Dollar. Und bei HTC liegt es ungefähr so bei 60 Dollar, würde ich mal sagen. Und das sind schon so die Top-Player und Samsung liegt vielleicht mal so bei zwischen 30 und 40 Dollar, während Motorola und Nokia und Sony Ericsson und LG alle Verluste fahren beim Verkauf. Und das ist sozusagen die Situation. Und Motorola, dieser kleine dünne Streifen, der gar kein Geld macht, aber trotzdem teure Telefone hat, das ist das, was ich jetzt Google geschopt.
Das sind doch nicht nur Smartphones, sondern das sind Telefone, die generell die Idee herstellen. Es wäre mal spannend, das Ganze für Smartphones zu sehen.
Das stimmt.
Ja, wobei ich glaube, diese Unterscheidung wird nicht mehr lange relevant sein. Also alle Telefone werden über kurz oder lang Smartphones sein. Es wird einfach bald keiner mehr was anderes wirklich nennenswertes bauen. Also klar, ein paar Märkte wird es noch geben, da wird es auch noch lange noch, aber das ist einfach nicht mehr das Relevante. Schon gar nicht ist das der Bereich, wo man irgendwie nennenswerte Margen erzielen kann. Das ist halt einfach da. So und das ist jetzt Apples Position und man sieht eben auch, sollte tatsächlich mal der Fall kommen, den ich noch überhaupt nicht sehe, dass Apple irgendwie, naja, unter Preisdruck gerät. Dass tatsächlich irgendein anderer Provider über den Preis in der Lage ist, auf diesem Markt Welle zu machen und etwas so brauchbares zu einem guten Preis anbietet, dass die Leute sagen, aber bevor ich mir jetzt so viel Geld für ein iPhone ausgebe, obwohl das so cool und so toll ist und meine anderen Freunde das auch alle haben, und ein Jahr alt ist, kaufe ich doch dieses Telefon XY. Guck mal, wie viel Hub Apple hat, den Preis zu senken. Und man hat das schon bei dem iPod gesehen.
Was nicht drin ist, sind ja die Kosten, die sagen profon.
Das hier sind die Kosten pro Phone, das hier ist der Gewinn pro Telefon. Also du siehst, Apple macht mehr Gewinn pro Telefon als ein Rim-Telefon kostet.
So in etwa, als fast alle anderen Kosten außer HTC. Das heißt, die können jetzt über den Preis, ich glaube, die haben noch gar nicht angefangen. Ich meine, Apple ist gerade dabei, immer noch dieses Premium-Segment zu adressieren. Die sind gar nicht aus 100% des Marktes zu haben, obwohl sie jetzt schon sich von der 25%-Marke nähern. In dem Moment, wo sie sich diversifizieren und vielleicht mal mehr als ein Telefon anbieten. Also gut, sie verkaufen auch das Alte mit. Man könnte sagen, sie haben jetzt eh mehrere im Markt. Aber im Kern ist es halt nur diese eine Serie. Und sie haben keinerlei Diversifikation. Es gibt kein billigeres Telefon in dem Sinne. Und das könnten sie aber machen. Man muss sich ja nur den iPod-Markt anschauen, wie sie den angegangen sind. Da gab es am Anfang auch nur den iPod. Und später gab es dann halt den Nano und den Shuffle und so weiter. Und Stück für Stück haben sie eben die anderen Preissegmente auch noch mit adressiert. Und das eben auch so erfolgreich, dass es eigentlich in keinem einzigen Marktsement gibt es irgendeinen Competitor, der ein erfolgreiches Produkt hat, was es mit Apple da aufnehmen kann.
Vor allen Dingen finde ich ja krass, hier hat ja auch der Gruber letztens geschrieben, dass jetzt, obwohl das iPhone 5 vor der Tür steht, bei AT&T irgendwie das iPhone 4 noch das Best Selling Phone ist und das 2. Best Selling ist das 3GS.
Also in den USA jetzt nur. Ja, und das Telefon ist über ein Jahr alt.
Ja, und das 3GS noch viel älter.
Wobei das ist insofern natürlich eine problematische Größe mit diesem Best Selling Phone, weil es sich ja nur auf ein Gerät und nicht auf eine Gerätefamilie bezieht. Also in dem Moment, wo du schon mehrere Varianten hast, fällst du da aus dem Vergleich raus.
Und das ist ja noch nicht genug, dann verkaufen sie halt noch irgendwie tonnenweise von diesen iPads. Wahrscheinlich mittlerweile schon mehr als iPhones, oder? Noch nicht?
Nee, das noch nicht, aber das ist auf jeden Fall rising.
Das geht so ab. Jeder hat ein iPad, außer ich, aber ich auch bald.
Jetzt kommen wir nochmal zu einem interessanten Punkt. Letztes Mal hatte ich doch diese Sache mit dieser Product Transition nochmal angesprochen.
Ja, da hast du uns schon ein paar Mal von den Mundfässern geredet.
Da hat irgendjemand angedeutet, dass es die Product Transition gibt.
Ich hab mir nochmal Gedanken darüber gemacht, was das sein könnte.
Trommelwirbel.
Ja, ich hab keine Ahnung, ob ich da richtig liege. Ich kann damit auch total falsch liegen. Ich trau mir zumindest mal was. Man muss ja auch mal daneben liegen können.
Hallo, ich hab bei der WWDC diese blöde Ur-Prophezeit von wegen nichts trauen hier.
Wie hast du daneben gelegen?
Ja, siehst du, aber ich hab nicht was getraut. Aber die kommt noch, ich glaub die kommt noch.
Das stimmt, das stimmt. Also, was könnte es sein? Ich meine, was steht denn dieses Jahr überhaupt noch an? iPhone steht an.
Weihnachten!
Und der iPod steht an. Das ist, glaub ich, das Einzige. Es wird kein neues iPad kommen. Mac Pro vielleicht, keine Ahnung, aber...
Das ist keine große Transition.
Genau, das denken wir auch so. Also wenn sie da irgendwas einschneidendes machen, weiß ich gar nicht, ob das jetzt überhaupt noch...
Irgendjemand interessiert...
.so erwähnenswert wäre. Zumindest in dem Kontext dieses Financial Reports.
Ich denke, bei Mac Pro kommt demnächst so ein Update und es wird nicht mal announced, sondern es kommt halt so ums Doort.
Es gibt keine Macbook Airs mehr, es gibt keine Macbook Pros mehr, es gibt keine iMacs mehr, es ist alles, 2011 ist es eigentlich durch. Es gibt nur noch iPhone und iPod.
Die neu kommen. Weil ich jetzt gerade so ein bisschen auch so, hä?
Also wo sich jetzt was noch tut, wo man jetzt erwarten kann, also man weiß ja gar ja, vielleicht stellen sie ja noch irgendwas komplett Neues vor und dann stehen wir wieder da und haben es nicht geahnt. Aber wenn man nur davon ausgeht, was wahrscheinlich ist, und das Wahrscheinliche ist ja meistens das Naheliegende, blieb halt das iPhone und die iPods. Und beim iPhone, ehrlich gesagt, erwarte ich keine Überraschung. Also wir können gleich noch mal darüber mutmaßen, was das iPhone 5 denn bringen wird. Aber dass es kommt, denke ich, ist unstrittig. Und das iPhone 4 wird dann wahrscheinlich den Platz des iPhone 3 GS übernehmen. Ob sie es nochmal überarbeiten, schneller machen, einen schnelleren Prozessor da reintun oder so, keine Ahnung. Weiß ich nicht. Aber ich sehe da keine grundsätzliche Änderung des Prinzips kommen. Bleibt iPod. iPod ist jetzt 10 Jahre alt, oder?
Wir, keine Ahnung, könnte ich kommen.
Wir haben 2002.
2002? Sicher?
Nee, 2001, oder?
Ende 2001, hm? Ja doch, also ja, 10 Jahre.
2001, Wikipedia meint 2001, Februar 2001.
Februar 2001.
Der Alphard ist ein 10-jähriges und keiner hat was gesagt?
Nee, 23. Oktober 2001. Also doch. Also ziemlich genau 10 Jahre. So, und seitdem hat diese ganze Produktlinie so einiges gesehen. Neue Modelle hab ich ja eben alles schon angedeutet. Sie haben ja User Interface ein paar Mal überarbeitet etc. Und irgendwann kam dieser iPod Touch dazu. Und sie sind ja in diesem Bereich sehr erfolgreich. Und was ist so, wenn bei Apple ein Produkt sehr erfolgreich ist?
Es wird angestellt.
Es könnte über einen Haufen geworfen werden, weil man ja vielleicht noch was Erfolgreicheres rausbringen könnte. Und wenn ich mir so überlege, Produkttransition, iPod, da ist noch eine Menge Holz. Das Clickwheel könnte dran glauben. Also ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass der iPod Classic wegfällt. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass auch der iPod Nano...
Moment, welche gibt es denn im Augenblick noch? iPod Classic gibt es doch der Einzelne, der noch einen Clickwheel hat, oder?
Das ist der mit der Platte, ja? Das ist 160 GB oder so, ne?
Ich glaube. Dann gibt es den Shuffle noch mit... ohne Buttons eigentlich im Wesentlichen.
Nee doch, der hat Buttons.
Ja, ich weiß, aber er hat nicht viele Buttons. Also im Wesentlichen ein Schalter, mit dem du den Shuffle modligst. Nee, ich hab den aktuellen. Er hat einen Button, wo du da drauf lange draufdrückst, um die Playlist durchzuzyklen und einen Schalter zum Anmachen und auf Shuffle.
Nee, das ist nicht der aktuelle.
Du redest vom Nano, oder?
Du redest vom alten Schuffle.
Nee, ich rede vom aktuellen Schuffle.
Na, der hat vorwärts, rückwärts, Menü, Plus und Minus.
Ach so, ach ja, stimmt. Scheiße, ich hab mich vertan. Ja, natürlich. Aber ich benutze den nicht. Ich benutze diese Tasten nicht.
Es gibt vier iPods derzeit.
So sieht er aus.
Schuffle, Nano, Classic und Touch.
Und da wird auch mit Buttons geworben.
Was könnte jetzt passieren? Also der Classic könnte wegfallen und komplett durch Touch ersetzt werden. Ist das schon eine Product Transition?
Nein.
Also nach dem Classic kräht auch kein Hanover, oder?
Ich weiß nicht, ob das ein Nano so erfolgt sein soll.
Das ist doch nicht mal eine Pressemitteilung wert, wenn die das ändern.
Ja, das stimmt.
Also, weil ich weiß nicht, wie der iPod-Markt so aussieht. Der ist ja schon noch ziemlich bedeutend eigentlich, oder?
Aber sie könnten den Nano auch auf iOS umstellen.
Ja, das mag alles sein, aber das ist nichts, worüber Steve irgendwie so einen Alarm machen würde.
Ich glaube, das war ja nicht Steve, das war Oppenheimer.
Ich glaube nicht, dass Nano mit iOS kommt. Das wäre so ein...
Was?
Na, das wäre so ein Un... Also, wie will man dann ein vernünftiges User-Interface draufbringen? Also, iOS ist ja nur was mit dem App Store, das heißt, es muss dafür auch...
iOS ist nur was mit Touch Display.
Da ist jetzt schon ein Touch Display drauf.
Ich weiß, dass da ein Touch Display drauf ist, aber das iOS braucht den App Store. Ansonsten ist das, ich meine, wenn da jetzt... Wie willst du für so einen... Also, vielleicht haben sie es hingekriegt, aber für so ein kleines Display, ein vernünftiges Betriebssystem, vernünftige Navigation, vernünftige Bedienung hinkriegen, wenn es...
Da haben sie ja jetzt auch drauf.
Ja, aber du kannst halt nicht irgendwie... Du hast da keine Möglichkeit, auch nur anzuseisen, zu zeichnen Texteinzelte... Ja, also echt mal.
Und dafür dann Entwickler kriegen, die für dieses kleine Display entwickeln, wo du nicht mal Text rein kriegst?
Na vielleicht schmeißen sie den Nano auch komplett weg und ersetzen ihn durch irgendein anderes iOS-Test.
Warum sollten sie das tun?
Weil es erfolgreich ist. Ja, weil sie mehr iOS haben wollen. Weil iOS ihre Zukunft ist und weil sie auf iOS setzen und deswegen in diese Richtung denken. Der Touch könnte auf jeden Fall sehr billig werden. Ich glaube, es gibt... Wenn es einen iPod Touch gibt, der... Was kostet das Ding jetzt? 150?
Der kostet im billigsten Fall 229.
229 Dollar. Wenn sie den im Preis massiv senken, wenn er so ein bisschen iPhone 4 mäßig auch noch vielleicht ausgestattet wird, eine großartige Kamera rein kriegt und auch als Kamera besser noch funktioniert, so mit iOS 5 und kriegt vielleicht noch seine eigene Taste oder zumindest die Lautstärke-Tasten etc. Das ist ja absehbar, dass das so sein wird. Und ihm vielleicht auch noch 16 GB RAM spenden, 16 GB Flash spendieren. Und jetzt kostet er 230 Dollar und danach kostet er nur noch 150 Dollar. Oder vielleicht 150 Dollar, sagen wir mal so was. Und dafür dann vielleicht aber auch so den Nano wegfallen lassen und sagen, ja war ganz schön so mit der Uhr und so, aber kam nicht so richtig an und ist so ein Touch OS, was nicht reinpasst und wir wollen eigentlich, dass jeder jetzt so ein Teil in der Hand hat, so ein dickes und wenn du was kleines haben willst, dann kauf den scheiß Schafel und dann wäre es wieder ein Nano.
Ich halte dagegen und ich sage, die Product Transition wird sein, dass der iPod Touch rausfällt. Und zwar wird er ersetzt durch ein günstigeres iPhone. Also bisher gibt es halt dieses iPhone 4, das ist das Telefon und du kriegst irgendwie, da hinten gibt es auch noch das 3GS, das kannst du billig kaufen. Das gibt es ja hier in Deutschland auch nach wie vor zu kaufen. Aber alle denken immer, iPhone ist sauteuer. Und ich glaube, es wird so kommen, dass es ein iPhone gibt, was irgendwie, also ich weiß nicht wo genau die Differenzierung zwischen der Luxus-Variante, dem iPhone 5 und dem iPod 5 Nano oder wie auch immer es heißen wird, wo da die große Differenzierung sein wird, weil sie wird sicherlich nicht nur über den Preis sein, weil das machen sie eigentlich normalerweise ja nicht. Also dass sie zwei Produktkategorien haben, die... Also iPod Touch, du kriegst kein billiges iPhone. Was ist ein billiges iPhone in deinen Augen? Na es gibt eins für 99 Dollar. Mit Vertrag.
Jaja, so funktioniert das in Amerika.
Ja, aber es gibt nur ein iPhone, also es gibt zum Beispiel bei den iPods, gibt es nicht wirklich, hier ist der billige iPod, den verkloppen wir dir noch, weil der ist aus Plastik und hier total billig und scheiße und leck mich und hier ist der teure und das ist die Version, die du eigentlich haben willst, sondern sie haben Geräte, die du könntest, also es gibt sicherlich viele Leute, die sagen, hey ich kauf mir lieber so ein iPod Nano als so ein iPod Klassik, weil das sind zwei komplett verschiedene Produktkategorien, die nichts miteinander zu tun haben.
Ja, iPod Touch und iPhone sind auch zwei unterschiedliche Produktkategorien.
Genau, und wenn sie jetzt plötzlich zwei iPhones haben und sagen, sie würden es nicht sagen, das ist das billige iPhone, das ist das teure iPhone.
Sie haben ja jetzt schon zwei iPhones.
Ja, aber das wird halt nicht vermarktet großartig. Das wird nicht großartig beworben, das 3GS. Oder hast du irgendwo Fernsehwerbung dafür gesehen?
Nein, das machen sie keine Arbeit.
Wir sprechen ja von der großen Product-Transition.
Die Leute gehen in den Laden rein und sagen, ich hätte gerne ein iPhone. Wollen sie das teurer oder wollen sie das günstiger haben?
Ich glaube, die Leute kommen in den Laden und sagen, ich hätte gerne ein iPhone und hier ein iPhone 4, aber wenn sie es ganz billig haben wollen, hier haben wir noch ein iPhone 3GS. Sodass das dann noch unter der Ladentheke zu leicht wird.
Aber warum spricht das jetzt dafür, dass der iPod Touch wegfallen soll, das verstehe ich nicht. Der iPod Touch ist doch unverzichtbar.
Weil du in diesen iPod Touch einfach einen SIM-Kartenslot einbauen könntest.
Und dann?
Und er wäre ein Telefon. Und ein billiges Telefon.
Du musst ja nicht nur einen SIM-Kartenslot einbauen, du musst einen Baseband-Chip einbauen, der ist teuer.
Was kostet der?
Jungs, wir können mal zusammenfassen, ihr wisst nicht, was die nächste Frage ist.
Jetzt kommt hier die große Ansage, der große Move, aber das überzeugt mich alles bisher gar nicht.
Es wird ein günstiges iPhone geben, was offiziell nicht so heißt, was aber ein iPhone ist, um diesen ganzen unteren Rotz da so ein bisschen, um das nochmal schön in die Breite zu treten.
Der iPod-Touch kann nicht wegfallen und kann auch kein Telefon sein, weil er einfach einen Riesenmarkt erschließt, den das iPhone derzeit nicht kriegen kann.
Warum sollen sie sonst keine... Was wäre sonst die große Product-Transition? Du hast doch gerade gesagt, sie machen Großes, sie werden erfolgreiches Produkt wegschmeißen.
Die Product-Transition ist ja nicht das Entscheidende, sondern das Entscheidende ist, wo sind ihre Märkte? Und der iPod-Touch hat einen Markt, den das iPhone nicht kriegen kann.
Welchen?
Kinder.
Wieso sagen Kinder keine Telefone haben?
Weil das Geld kostet, Verträge kosten, etc. Und weil das Geld teuer ist, wenn du da den Chip reinbaust...
Jedes Kind hat ein Telefon.
Nein.
Welches Kind hat kein Telefon?
13-Jährige.
Wir haben hier 12- Aber hallo. Dann haben sie jetzt...
Ich hab mich gerade länger mit Vättern unterhalten, die irgendwie 13-jährige Töchter haben.
Also dann kennen wir unterschiedlich 13-Jährige.
Die ganze Schulklasse läuft da mit iPod-Touch durch die Gegend.
Dann kennen wir unterschiedliche Eltern.
Ja, wir kennen unterschiedliche Eltern.
Aber die haben doch alle auch ein Telefon. Die haben iPod-Touch und ein Telefon.
Nein, die hat kein Telefon.
13-Jährige ohne Telefon, arme Kinder.
Du, die kommen damit total gut klar. Die wissen, wo die Hotspots sind, besser als wir. Und die haben da ihre Games drauf und so weiter. Und die können auch sehr gut unterscheiden zwischen ich bin jetzt online und ich bin nicht online.
Und nebenbei haben sie noch ein Telefon.
Die können auch mit ihren Freunden spielen. Ja, es gibt halt dann auch Eltern, die eben ihren Kindern nicht komplett die Telefonregelung ausschauen.
Kann man bitte irgendjemand eine Statistik raussuchen, wie viele 13-Jährige in Deutschland ein Telefon haben?
Ja, wenn es die gibt. Ja, natürlich gibt es 13-Jährige, die Telefon haben.
Das ist nicht das, was ich sage.
Und ich würde sagen, es gibt aber 80%. Ja, das bezweifle ich.
Aber die haben wahrscheinlich...
Und selbst wenn nicht, nach dem Gerät werden sie dann halt eins haben.
Vielleicht kommt dir das Kitphone raus.
Ist auch ein Preisargument. Ich meine, der Touch ist einfach billiger, weil da ist einfach weniger drin als in einem iPhone. Deswegen werden sie diesen Preis niemals für ein iPhone erzählen können, wie sie mit einem iPod Touch erzählen können. Und das ist halt der entscheidende Punkt. Wenn etwas 50 oder 100 Dollar billiger ist, dann ist es halt billiger. Naja, wir werden sehen. Das ist ja doch Apple TV.
Ich finde ja auch den Nano aktuell den unkonsequentesten iPod von allen.
Handybesitz bei Kindern und Jugendlichen. Tatsächlich hat jemand die Statistik ausgebuddelt.
12-
bis 13-Jährige, 75 Prozent.
Was ist das hier? Handybesitz bei Kindern und Jugendlichen nach 2007 und 2008.
Auch schon uralt. Und jetzt sag nicht, ist seitdem weniger.
Ja, wahrscheinlich seitdem jetzt auf 30 Prozent gesunken.
Ich würde mal sagen, die 14- bis 15-Jährigen haben die 100 Prozent angeschlagen. Du kannst alles eine Stufe nach rechts schieben, sozusagen von den Balken.
Wobei es bei den 14- bis 15-Jährigen zurückgegangen ist.
Ja, es ist noch weit über 50 Prozent wahrscheinlich.
Was?
Ist krass, hätte ich nicht gedacht. 14 bis 15, ok, 12 bis 13, aber schon 75 Prozent?
Und ich glaube, hier im Chat kommt natürlich auch, die haben natürlich keine Verträge, die haben Prepaid-Handys. Siehst du, wann das auf dich zukommt, das Thema, dass du deinen Kindern hier endlich ein Telefon in die Hand drücken musst.
Das ist doch ganz viele Eltern. Ich würde mich nicht wundern, wie viele Eltern ihren Kindern ein altes iPhone in die Hand drücken. Dann hier find my iPhone und aktivieren, damit sie wissen, wo die Kids gerade sind.
Die Frage ist auch, wie der Smartphone-Anteil hier ist. Kannst du verlieren Telefone?
Natürlich sind das billige Telefone. Aber wenn du ein iPod Touch deinen Kindern schenkst und ihnen noch ein Telefon dazu schenkst, pack das beides in ein Gerät und du hast ein billiges iPhone. Das kostet dann auch nicht mehr, als beide Geräte getrennt. Die Kids sind glücklicher. Du kannst nebenbei noch all die Leute, die eigentlich gerne ein iPhone hätten, aber im Augenblick so einen billigen Android mit abgreifen.
Wie heißt diese Klingeltonenbude und so, wo die ihre ganze Kohle herkriegen. Weil die Kids irgendwie diesen Scheiß klicken.
Na dann verkauft sich der iPod Touch wahrscheinlich gar nicht millionenfach, sondern das ist alles nur eine Fata Morgana.
Wieso? Ich hab nie gesagt, dass er sich nicht verkauft. Ich hab gesagt, die haben Handy und ein iPod.
Es klingt jetzt nicht unplausibel, dass ein billigeres iPhone, sozusagen, sich jetzt nicht auch...
Ich bezweifle einfach, dass sie mit einem voll ausgerüsteten Telefon in derselben Preisregion vorstoßen können. Aber vielleicht liege ich falsch.
Na, bei der Marge, die sie da haben...
Vielleicht liege ich falsch. Ja, gut, diese Marge haben sie auch gerne.
Ja, aber am Anfang, sie haben doch den Preis vom iPhone so quasi in den ersten drei Monaten, haben sie doch mal ziemlich massiv gesenkt.
Um 200 Dollar.
Um 200 Dollar, ja. Das war von 800 auf 600. Das ist ein Viertel. Das ist eine ordentliche Preissenkung.
Aber seitdem nie wieder.
Seitdem nie wieder, das stimmt. Aber warum haben sie es damals gemacht? Weil sie in dem ganz hohen Preissegment wahrscheinlich doch wieder zu wenig Geräte verkauft haben. Und Apple wäre, die wären doof, wenn sie sich nicht dem Markt anpassen. Wenn sie mitkriegen, dass Smartphones langsam billiger wären und dass es viele Leute gibt, die ein Smartphone haben wollen, aber nicht bereit sind, dafür so richtig viel Geld auszugeben. Und warum sollte Apple diesen Markt nicht probieren zu bedienen?
Gut, wir werden es sehen. Langweilen wir unsere Hörer nicht weiter mit unseren...
Wir wollen schon Schluss machen.
Nö, aber wir können ja vielleicht mal von diesem Markt-Thema weg, ich habe das Gefühl, dass wir jetzt schon zwei Jahre drüber reden.
I said that is the most expensive phone in the world and it doesn't appeal to business customers because it doesn't have a keyboard, which makes it not a very good email machine.
Diesen Schnipsel, den kann ich auch immer wieder gucken.
Also wenn du häufiger mal das Sound einspielen willst, ich kann dir auch hier ein professionelles Audiokabel anbieten.
Ja, weil dann kommst du hier mit deinen colloquiai Sounds irgendwie auf voller Kanalbreite angebratselt und bürstest erstmal den Chat weg.
So ich hab jetzt mal hier so ein sehr Mac-lastiges Thema. Kennt ihr Shrine of Apple?
Ich hab es die ganze Zeit auf deinem Bildschirm schon.
Ich hab diese Seite, ich hab, das ist, das ist so Apple Fanboy Hochglanz Porn irgendwas. Das sind, das sind so.
Da sind wir ja genau richtig.
Apple Produkte gigantisch gut fotografiert, uraltes Zeug, teilweise noch so irgendwie von einer Apple Liza, die Platine mit fotografiert und so. Man sitzt wirklich da vor und es ist so mit einem schicken Video dazu.
Meiner ist nicht dabei.
Schnell, weil es wird langsamer.
Also meiner ist nicht dabei.
Also ich hab hier.
Alle Apple Produkte halte ich für etwas übertrieben.
Hab ich gesagt alle?
Nee, nee, die sammeln, sie probieren welche zusammenzukriegen. Und.
Da fehlt einiges.
Ja, ja, da fehlt extrem viel.
Das meiste fehlt.
Aber zum Beispiel haben sie einen Mac LC, sie haben eine Leise, haben sie dabei. Sie haben bisher zum Beispiel auch nur ein iPhone 4. Das ist ja.
Weißt du, was ich zu Hause noch für ein geiles Gerät hab?
Das war früher immer ganz wichtig, weil es war nicht so easy.
Den ersten Power Mac G3.
Ein Apple SCSI CD-ROM-Laufwerk. Weil die haben ja nicht jedes Laufwerk genommen. Und deswegen manchmal ging es nicht anders. Und dann musste ich irgendwie in den tiefsten Keller, musste mein Apple SCSI CD-ROM-Laufwerk rausholen.
Das war eine, das war ein Traktor, das Gerät. Nicht weil es groß war, sondern weil es einfach Sachen weggeschafft hat, das hat einfach extrem gut funktioniert. Noch mit diesem Caddy, wo man die CD einlegt.
Nee, Schublade glaube ich.
Mit Caddy habe ich so ein Gerät, da kann man irgendwie CDs mit brennen, so ein riesen Klopper, der ist bestimmt 15 cm hoch, aber der nicht von Apple.
Ein Apple CD-Laufwerk mit SCSI, ohne Caddy?
Das war das Apple CD 300 oder 600.
Ja, ich glaube CD 300 heißt das Ding, ist noch relativ langsam. Also 300 heißt ja dann noch Double Speed.
Was mir hier gerade auffällt, hier ist so ein Power Mac G3, so ein bisschen von der Seite fotografiert. Und zum einen ist das Gehäuse, teilweise, das sieht man hier auf dem Foto, ist das teilweise transparent, was ich, also das war vor dem iMac mit teilweise transparenten Gehäuse hinten. Und hier hinten so einen riesengroßen Apple-Logo drauf.
Oh fuck, die Kamera kenn ich auch noch.
Das sah schon so ein bisschen einigend aus.
Achso, genau, die 300, da war der Nachfolger von dem 150er. Genau, der 150er hatte noch den Caddy.
Ja, auf jeden Fall, falls ihr euch mal schick so Apple-Produkte angucken wollen, Powerbooks haben sie auch sehr schöne. Die ersten, hier so ein Powerbook 100 war das, glaube ich, was sie hatten.
Geil, ich kann mir hier einen iPhone-Doc anschauen in 3D und was auch immer.
Oh, jetzt haben sie richtig viele Powerbooks. Powerbook 150, 100, Powerbook 165 und das Powerbook G4. Und zwar das, das ist ein Titanium, glaube ich.
Mensch, Mensch.
Und nicht einfach so irgendwelche von irgendwelchen Leuten, die noch irgendwie auf dem Dachboden mit dem iPhone fotografiert ein Foto machen, sondern so richtig schön.
Also ich meine, so alte Macs und so, kennt man ja. Hier sind ja auch so ein paar Geräte dabei, von denen man sich überhaupt nicht vorstellt, dass es sowas jemals gab. Zum Beispiel ein Geoport-Modem.
Ja, da sind auch schon extrem scheiße Sachen dabei, oder? Ich glaube, da ist auch das Netzteil von einer Quick-Tech-Kamera mit dabei.
Die Quick-Tech war cool.
Ja, die hatte ich bei Pixel Park mal irgendwie eine.
Quick-Tech 2, glaube ich sogar.
Ist nicht 150?
Irgendwie gibt es da zwei Modelle, oder?
Es gab, glaube ich, zwei Modelle.
Ja, es gibt 100, 150, 200.
Na, ich weiß nicht mehr, welches es war.
Und was hat sie für eine Auflösung?
46x480. Also, Digital-Kamera. Eigentlich die erste Digital-Kamera.
Das war aber schon die spätere Quick-Tech. Die erste war so flach. Ach genau, da ist er. Quick-Tech 100 und 150.
Wollen wir jetzt noch länger in Fotos rumstochern, was sowieso keiner nachvollziehen kann? Und in der Vergangenheit schwelgen.
Lass mich kurz drüber nachdenken.
Das ist ein Mac-Thema. Das ist etwas anderes.
Das ist etwas Lockeres, nach dieser anstrengenden Markt-Analyse.
Mit den Kindern.
Und ich will mir jetzt den nächsten Android-Gerät kaufen, damit ich auch mal dazu beitrage. Mal gucken, ob es klappt. Ich werde auf dem Laufenden halten. Hier ACOS, diese furchtbare... Was machen die eigentlich? Media Player, MP3 Player.
Bevor der iPod rauskam, haben die das gemacht.
Die haben den ACOS 35 angekündigt. Es ist ein Radiowecker mit Android drauf. Wird bestimmt mit in die stolzeste Statistik der aktivierten Android-Geräte mit einfließen. Was ich daran ganz geil finde...
Von 550.000 Anmeldungen musst du ja schon ein bisschen was bringen.
Ja, also es ist halt... Es hat zwei vernünftige Boxen drin. Ich würde es gerne als Küchenradio haben. Ich will gerne ein Küchenradio haben und ich möchte gerne ein Küchenradio mit Airplay haben. Und so Airplay-taugliche Geräte sind so scheiße teuer. Unter 600 Euro gibt es da nichts. Die klingen bestimmt geil und die sehen alle auf jeden Fall geil aus.
Du willst ein Küchenradio mit Airplay haben?
Na ich möchte gerne ein Küchenradio haben, wo ich schön Musik von meinem iPhone aus drauf abspielen kann.
Mit Airplay halt.
Genau, und das hätte ich gerne zu einem okayen Preis.
Was ist das?
Weniger als 600.
Also in dem Fall kostet es 150 jetzt dieses Gerät. Und ich wüsste jetzt keinen Weg, außer jetzt irgendwie mit Airport Express und dann da irgendwelche Aktivboxen anschließen oder sowas, worauf ich ehrlich gesagt überhaupt keinen Bock habe. Darum werde ich mir so ein Teil holen, da gibt es so eine Software für, die heißt... Nee, das hat natürlich offiziell kein Airplay, aber es gibt hier eine Software, habe ich mal geguckt, gegoogelt, die heißt Airbubble für Android.
Ist doch gehacktes Ding der Key.
Genau, und die macht dann, und dann hat man damit auch Airplay. Und ich hoffe mal, wenn das halbwegs funktioniert, dann habe ich da so ein Ding, was im Zweifelsfall selber halt Radio kann, was jetzt der Haupteinsatzzweck ist, weil halt der Empfang bei mir in der Küche so schlecht ist, dass man da, also mit FM kann man da echt nichts machen. Und darum will ich das über WLAN haben. Und alternativ, wenn ich Lust habe, kann ich darüber auch Musik hören. Das finde ich eigentlich ganz...
Also du meinst dieses Home Connect, ne?
Da gibt es noch unter dem gleichen Namen haben sie noch ein Deck-Telefon vorgestellt, auch mit Android. Wobei auch ein Deck-Telefon mit Android ist, glaube ich, gar nicht so verkehrt, wobei er hat kein Market, wenn man damit seine Adressen synchronisieren könnte. Weil ich finde es ja bis heute so furchtbar, ich muss jetzt auch ein Deck-Telefon wieder einsetzen, dass man da sein Adressbuch nicht mehr synchronisiert kriegt. Also insofern wäre das durchaus nochmal eine Überlegung wert.
Das gibt es dann auch gleich bei Google App. Zum Synchronisieren.
Na bei Android ist doch hier, wenn alles überleitet wird... Ja, hab ich ja sogar, aber auch damit kriegt man sein Adressbuch nicht vernünftig synchronisiert. Das kriegt man dummerweise, man kann damit mit gmx und web.de glaube ich, kann man sein Adressbuch synchronisieren. Also mit so ziemlich niemandem, was ich brauche. Und ansonsten kann man da irgendwie, es gibt natürlich so Tools, mit denen kann man sein Adressbuch bei Google exportieren und das dann in ein entsprechendes CSV-Format umwandeln für die Fritzbox und das ist alles, das möchte man. Also das möchte ich nicht.
Leute, hier schreibt gerade einer, er nimmt mit uns mit in die Dusche. Wir haben Nackthörer.
Wieso? Das heißt nicht, dass er nackt duscht?
Der hat eine Hose an beim Duschen. Hast du keine Hose an beim Duschen?
Nee, ich trage immer Bikini. Nackthörer.
Nackthörer, sehr schön. Bleibt auch das nicht aus.
Es gibt tatsächlich ein Gigaset.
Das sind auch nicht tot zu kriegen, ne?
Es gibt ein Gigaset-Telefon mit Mac-Sync. Scheint auch irgendwie zu funktionieren.
Aber das tot zu kriegen, ist denn jetzt diese Certificate Authority so langsam, ne? Habt ihr jetzt irgendwie, gibt's ja hier gerade die neueste DigiNotar-Meldung irgendwie.
Kannst du das vielleicht mal alles zusammenfassen? Ich hab den Überblick verloren.
Na ja, also da gab es halt so eine Certificate Authority, die halt so lustig SSL-Zertifikate und wahrscheinlich auch andere PKI-Applikationen verkaufen. Ja, also wenn man so ein SSL-Zertifikat für seine Webseite braucht, kann man da hingehen. Und wie war das jetzt? Wurde das gestohlen oder hat das jemand gehackt oder weißt du?
Gehackt?
Hat sich die CA gehackt? Das U-Zertifikat. Und hat damit sozusagen Zertifikate ausgestellt an...
Na, der hat ja nicht das Zertifikat selbst bekommen, sondern er konnte dafür sorgen, dass von ihm eingereichte Dinger zertifiziert werden. So, wenn er das Ganze, den Masterkey hätte, dann könnte er sich ja ohne Ende bis zum jüngsten Tag irgendwie Zertifikate ausstellen. Das hat er wohl nicht.
Aber er hat für Google, Facebook und...
Lauter große Buden.
Lauter große andere Buden halt lustig Zertifikate erstellt, die halt, ja, scheinbar...
Die Person.
Oder die Gruppe. Man sagt ja angeblich iranische Hacker, weil da irgendwie ein Zert irgendwie in Persisch irgendwie heißt, ich bin der größte Hacker, was auch immer genau da drin stand. Aber ob das nun stimmt, ist ja noch eine andere.
Was man jetzt halt... Was halt so diese Implikation davon ist, ist, dass halt in dem Moment, wo man so was machen kann, sich Max zum Beispiel mit seinem kleinen Web-Server als Facebook ausgeben kann und oben das Schlösschen erscheint und alles sehr vertrauenswürdig aussieht. Und die Möglichkeit schneidet Max aber heimlich den ganzen...
Ich hab mit Facebook nichts am Hut.
Den Verkehr mit, genau. Und naja, als ersten großen Knall hat dann irgendwie Holland, die Regierung, da wo auch DigiNotar operiert, sich das jetzt erst mal verstaatlicht, das Unternehmen, weil sie halt auch ihre... Was war das, ihre Ausweis?
Sie nutzen auf jeden Fall auch irgendwelche Dienste von DigiNotar und die sind auch gehackt worden, das heißt, sie sind ganz schön am Arsch und sie können es nicht mal zurückziehen, weil dann deren Rechner von der Regierung, welch was auch immer die für ein Netzterren betreiben, nicht mehr miteinander reden könnte, wenn die Zerts nicht mehr funktionieren, das heißt, die lassen es sogar weiterlaufen.
Nee, ich glaube, im Augenblick wissen sie noch nicht, ob es gehackt worden ist oder sie wissen zumindest nicht, ob damit Zertifikate erzeugt worden sind. Das prüfen sie noch nach, da deutet im Augenblick noch nichts drauf hin. Also, könnten Glück haben, aber das ist halt diese offizielle holländische Staatszertifizierungsstelle, die quasi mit dabei war.
Naja, auf jeden Fall, das war so der erste große Knall, dass die gleich mal gesagt haben, oh, das nehmen wir mal, das meint es.
Was auch schon ein bisschen komisch ist, weil es eigentlich eine amerikanische Firma.
Ja, da haben die irgendwie, da ist noch auch nicht klamm, unter welcher Rechtsgrundlage sie das getan haben, aber jetzt kann es ja auch erstmal egal sein. Und jetzt kam hier gerade bei, also so, genau, dann war so der nächste Schritt, dass gestern oder vorgestern so ein Typ auf Paste bin, rumgepostet hat, dass er ja noch vier weitere CAs gehackt hätte.
Auf Paste bin.
Ja, ja, es wurde schon auf Twitter gemunkelt, dass Paste bin mehr Leaks hat als WikiLeaks mittlerweile. Genau. Und hat halt eine CA explizit genannt, nämlich GlobalSign. Und die haben heute, spontan den Dienst eingestellt, ne? Ja, haben den Zertifikatsverkauf spontan eingestellt und einen Monster-Audit gestartet. Also, äh, entweder die haben richtig Muffensausen von diesem herumgepose, was vielleicht einfach nur ein Bluff ist, oder da ist halt wirklich was im Busch. Und dann war das wahrscheinlich auch, also wenn der ernsthaft noch vier weitere CAS gehackt hat, dann kommt da echt mal ordentlich Wind ins Geäste.
Ja, aber es war schon immer klar, dass wenn die Leute es irgendwann nicht mehr schaffen, die Verschlüsselung zu knacken, also wenn wir beide jetzt, ich und Hucke, wir verschlüsselt kommunizieren und sie können das unterwegs nicht mitlesen, dann wird man natürlich anfangen, die Endpunkte anzugreifen. Also dass man Huckels Rechner hackt oder meinen, oder im Fall von SSI halt irgendwie sich die Zerts irgendwie besorgt, weil die Verschlüsselung an sich scheint ja bei sich ja zu sein.
Ich hab mal mit jemandem darüber, wir unterhalten jetzt im Büro und der meint, also dann war es so, ja der Iran, der muss ja, ich meine, der hat keine eigene Zertifizierung. Also wenn China jetzt, wenn die sich ein Zertifikat für Facebook ausstellen wollten, China Telekom steckt bei jedem drinnen, die würden sich halt ein Zertifikat für Facebook ausstellen. Wenn Deutschland ganz dringend mal hier irgendwie ein Zertifikat für Gmail oder Facebook braucht, dann machen sie sich das halt bei der Telekom. Also es ist doch, außer Iran hat doch wahrscheinlich jeder irgendwie Zugriff jeder Staat auf eine entsprechende Zertifizierungsstelle.
Na ja gut, ob das jetzt halt auch wirklich, also ja gut, wenn es halt wirklich von iranischen Hackern benutzt wurde, um jetzt hier irgendwelche Dissidenten und was auch immer auszuspionieren. Das ist ja die eine Sache, aber kann ja auch sein, dass es einfach nur Hacker waren, die mal sehen wollten, was so geht. Also man erinnert sich ja auch noch an den Kongress, was der Vorletzte, wo dann RapidSSL noch MD5 Fingerprints auf ihren Zertifikaten ausschließlich hatte und die mit einer Handvoll Playstations mal eine Collision erzeugt haben und ein Zertifikat hatten, was den gleichen Fingerprint hatte wie das von RapidSSL, also von der CA, und damit dann auch sofort loslegen konnten. Und die haben jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht im Auftrag von den iranischen Regierungen oder so gehandelt. Na ja, mal gucken, was geht so. Und da gibt es ja so ein paar Hacker, die auch durchaus mit sportlichen Interessen unterwegs sind.
Klar, also ob jetzt der Iran hinter dem konkreten Heck steht, das kann man sicherlich, wissen wir nicht, aber dass der Iran prinzipiell ein großes Interesse an solchen Zertifikaten haben dürfte, das, glaube ich, steht außer Zweifel.
Aber die schicken dann nicht einen Idioten los, der sich dann irgendwie Facebook holt, oder?
Natürlich Facebook, wenn du Desidenten ausspionieren willst, dann musst du Facebook haben.
Die nutzen Facebook?
Natürlich, die nutzen die ganzen großen Dienste.
Die ganzen großen Dienste, ja. Ich meine, wenn die Facebook benutzen, dann haben die da eh verloren.
Na, Ägypten-Mann.
Wie Ägypten-Mann.
War es gerade so Revolution und so?
Über Facebook.
Na ja, definitiv. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie den Namen Facebook-Revolution verdient, aber dass die Social Networks da einen erheblichen Anteil gehabt haben, das, denke ich, steht vollkommen außer Frage. Es ist nicht so, dass dadurch, der die Revolution ausgelöst wurde, aber durch diese neue Form der Kommunikation gab es überhaupt erstmal die Möglichkeit, dass die sich da einfach zu einer Kabale zusammenschmieden konnten und dann zum gleichen Zeitpunkt gestartet sind.
Na ja, auf jeden Fall, wenn du so eine Zertifikate hast, dann ist es auf jeden Fall total natürlich, dass man dann erstmal seinen ganzen Internetverkehr durch irgendwelche Proxys jagt und da, wo Facebook dransteht, dann halt mal das nochmal so durch den Proxy jagt. Also das haben, das, also würde ich an der Stelle von diversen Regimen auf jeden Fall auch tun. Weil, weil, also ich verstehe, also ich weiß nicht, ob, also Al-Qaeda macht das bestimmt nicht, aber viele Leute scheinen sich schon auf Twitter und Facebook und so noch relativ ungehemmt auszutauschen und ja, da ist man dann natürlich schlecht beraten.
Also in Chat kam hier so ein bisschen Frage auf, wieso ich denn oft die Idee kommen würde, dass es selbstverständlich ist, dass der Iran sowas haben möchte, gerne so ein paar Zertifikate. Ich glaube, das ist einfach, das gehört zu einem modernen Geheimdienst dazu. Ich glaube, der BND macht das genau so, das macht, also macht Geheimdienste deren Aufgabe, es ist Informationen dran zu schaffen, die machen das, indem sie digitale Kommunikation abhorchen. Und für einen vernünftigen Mittelsattack brauchst du heutzutage dann Zertifikat, wenn die Seiten verschlüsselt sind.
Und jetzt gerade, wo eben auch durch diesen Fire-Sheep-Dings, wo dieses Fire-Sheep für Firefox auch mal eben so Sessions mitzuschnitten.
Bestimmt, seitdem brauchen sie auch Zertifikate.
Seitdem ist ja jetzt auch bei Facebook, also bei Facebook ist zum Beispiel ab Oktober für alles HTTPS zwang, Twitter hat HTTPS-Authentifizierung.
Also bei Facebook kann man es einschalten. Das solltet ihr auf jeden Fall machen. Bei Twitter kann man es auch einschalten.
Bei Facebook kann man es einschalten?
In den Privacy-Settings. Die Einstellung ist glaube ich relativ klar. Ab Oktober ist es für alle apps und so auch Pflicht. Und ja, das ist jetzt sozusagen die neuste Entwicklung gewesen. Das heißt, wenn du da noch ran willst an diese Social Networks und so weiter, dann musst du das so machen.
In den Privacy-Settings sicher? Ich glaube, das sind in den Account-Settings. Security, da gibt es einen Security. Secure Browsing gibt es eine Einstellung. Also Account, Account Settings, dann der zweite Punkt, Security, keine Ahnung, wie der auf Deutsch heißt, und dann Secure Browsing.
Und warum hat Apple das Digi-Notar-C immer noch nicht zurückgezogen?
Ja, das ist eine sehr gute Frage.
Also auf Mac kann man es ja selber machen. Man öffnet die Keychain, geht zu System irgendwie, tippt oben in den Suchfeld Digi-N ein und das Zert, was dann kommt und Digi-Notar heißt, geht man drauf, drückt Backspace und Chaka-Boom.
Genau.
Umzack, Return, weg ist es. Aber okay, hab ich gemacht. Aber wie macht man es auf dem iPhone?
Ja, Moment. Also erstens ist es so, dass es natürlich eine Revocation für dieses Zertifikat gibt. Das heißt, auf eigentlich allen Seiten, wo noch so ein Digi-Notar-Zert dran klebt, sollte es eigentlich so sein, dass dann schon eine Warning kommt und du siehst, dass das Zertifikat revoked wurde. Also ich hab eine Testseite besucht und da kam eine Warning. Allerdings gab es halt in dem Artikel, wo diese Testseite verlinkt wurde, eben auch noch den Hinweis darauf, dass es unter bestimmten Umständen auf dem Mac halt auch dazu kommen kann, dass es keine Warning gibt. Und der sichere Weg wäre eben, dieses Digi-Notar-Zert aus der Keychain einfach ganz rauszunehmen.
Also ich kann ja mal gucken hier.
Keychain.
So, da gab es dieses Online-Zerts-Checken-Dings. Das ist ja hier in den Preferences drin. Certificates. Hier Online-Certificate-Status-Protokoll. Meinst du das, ja? Das ist alles irgendwie auf off bei mir. Und ich glaube, es ist auch default.
Und das ist für die Revocation Lists?
Ich glaube ja.
Na, das wäre dann natürlich sehr schlecht.
Also steht ja jetzt, Certificate Revocation List, CAL ist off. Dann gibt es hier noch Best Attempt und Require if Certificate Indicates. Ich kann das ja mal einfach einschalten. Wenn ab jetzt irgendwie alles langsamer wird bei mir, dann, ja, merke ich das ja.
Naja, auf jeden Fall, wie gesagt, wenn jetzt halt Global Sign sozusagen der nächste noch ist und die Drohung war es, dass da noch zwei, drei andere CAs dabei sind, dann kann da eben schon nochmal ordentlich Unruhe entstehen. Also nicht nur... Ach so, warte mal. Jetzt bei iOS ging es auf jeden... Was sagt der im Chat? Das abgelaufene Zert habe ich gestern noch getestet. Was heißt das? Es ging noch ohne Warning oder es wurde gewarnt? Das wäre wichtig zu wissen.
Ich finde das nicht mit HTTPS bei Facebook. Wo stellt man das denn ein?
Wo hast du das gefunden, Max?
Du gehst oben links auf Account, also bei den Einstellungen.
Guided Facebook Browsing.
Oben rechts. Account. Da Account Settings. Dann auf Security, der zweite Punkt von oben links.
Und dann der zweite Punkt von oben. Secure Browsing.
Exakt.
Sicheres Durchstöbern. Sicheres Durchstöbern.
Sicheres Durchstöbern heißt das auf Deutsch?
Ja, aber sicheres Durchstöbern eben nicht mit Digi-Notar. Und da ist das sichere Durchstöbern eher invertiert gemeint. Aber das ist halt auch wieder so die Sache, dass dieses ganze SSL-Geraffel, das ist ja eigentlich auch so ein Nerd-Range schon seit eh und je, dass dieses Web of Trust und dieser gekaufte Trust von diesen CA-Entitäten eigentlich auch totaler Mist ist.
Ja, ich will DNS-Sack haben.
Das wär gut. Wollen wir auch.
Müsste das nicht langsam durch sein?
Aber es war doch auch Mist, warst du nicht auf dem Kongress bei dem Vortrag?
Nee, war ich nicht.
Gibt's online?
Dem Kong... Du warst hier wieder...
Im Sinne von Bernstein.
Ich kann mich jetzt wieder natürlich... Ich kann mich ja mal so schlecht erinnern irgendwie. Aber DNS-Tag basiert am Ende darauf, dass es auch irgendwie eine zentrale Stelle macht. Und das hat mir schon gereicht, dass ich mir auch dachte, das will man eigentlich nicht.
Wie eine zentrale Stelle?
Na, bei DNS-Tag läuft alles nachher am Ende bis auf die Route-Seilbahn hoch. Und das ist mehr oder weniger eine zentrale Stelle, die das verweitert. Ein Key, der alle ruht.
Ein Key zu kneten, ja, na und? Aber ich meine, das ist doch klar. Das ist halt die Route-Zone.
Ja, aber willst du das?
Dann owns du einmal eine Route-Zone.
Und dann ist vorbei.
Na, owns du die Route-Zone, dann ist eh vorbei. Ich meine, klar, die Route-Server müssen sicher sein. Das gilt aber heute auch schon.
Darum gehen sie ja alle auf diese entsprechenden...
Aber dann, wenn man da noch das DNS-Tag drauf packt, muss man sich noch viel mehr drauf verlassen.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, da wird ja nicht am laufenden Meter irgendwas gesigned, sondern da gibt es halt die paar Top-Level-Domains, die dann gesigned werden.
Die paar Momente, das ist ja auch gerade wieder ein bisschen aufgeweicht worden.
Ja, aber wir reden jetzt hier von 200, wir reden jetzt nicht von Tausenden oder so.
Sehr geil. Im Chat schreibt jemand gerade, dass es neue Gerüchte für einen 3G-iPod-Touch gibt.
Ich gewinne! Ich gewinne! Jetzt bin ich ganz raus. Ah ja, genau. Vielleicht mal kurz erklären, was es auf sich hat mit diesem DNS-Hacks und warum ich zumindest meine oder glaube, zu wissen, dass das Erlösungen bringen könnte. Derzeit ist es so, du musst dir halt für so ein scheiß SSL-Zertifikat eins kaufen. Dann gehst du zu irgendeiner Brute, die du nicht kennst und musst dich nackt ausziehen.
Wenn du ein günstiges Zertifikat hast, wo nur das graue Schlösschen ist, dann reicht ja manchmal auch...
Ja, aber du willst halt eigentlich... Ja gut, aber die expiren alle irgendwie schnell. Das macht irgendwie keinen Spaß. Wäre es einfach und kein Problem, würden es ja alle machen. Machen aber nicht alle.
Na ja, es hat diverse Nachteile auch. Es ist ja auch Performance-Overhead. Du verlierst ja massiv an Daten.
Also das ist mittlerweile nicht mehr der Fall.
Doch, das kann ich euch tatsächlich versichern, haben wir gerade erst gebenchmarkt. Und das ist schon extrem, also nicht extrem, aber es ist schon eine signifikante...
Na gut, aber darauf geschissen. Ich meine, wenn ich jetzt für meinen Blog möchte ich einfach gerne einen SSL-Zert haben, für meinen Admin-Bereich. Das geht mir ja nur darum, dass ich, wenn ich mir in meinen Admin-Bereich einlogge, dass ich da irgendwie SSL habe.
Da brauchst du doch keinen Zert. Da kannst du ja auch mal Self-Sign.
Ja, aber Self-Sign hat immer wieder das Problem, dass wenn du irgendein Device verwendest, was halt einfach die Validität prüft, und das sollten sie ja alle tun, dass es halt unter Umständen komplett aussteigt.
Oder?
Du bräuchst das aber auch, was auch noch ein Problem wäre, du bräuchst noch eine eigene IP für den ganzen Scheiß.
Du willst am Ende auch dein eigenes Blog unter deinem HTTPS einfach laufen lassen. Und wenn du da jetzt nicht den Megatrefik hast von einer Million Leuten, die dein Spiel spielen wollen, dann geht das auch.
Das geht ja.
Der Punkt ist, es gibt nicht einfach das Tool, wo du sagst, jetzt ein Zertifikat erstellen und abspeichern und fertig. Sondern es ist halt immer dieser Prozess, der mit irgendwelchen Firmen zu tun hat, die du nicht kennst.
Die am Ende auch nur ein Perl-Skript laufen lassen.
Ja, und die dann halt wie wir sehen, wie DigiNOTAR dann einfach auch Scheiße bauen und auch nicht zuverlässig sind. Dafür zahlst du dann auch noch Geld. Regelmäßig. Und das willst du nicht. Du willst nicht regelmäßig nur, dass deine Webseite sicher ist, Geld zahlen, sondern es soll einfach nichts kosten. Wenn du jetzt deine eigene Domain hast.
Wie viele Hunderte Dollar dafür, dass sie so eine kleine digitale Signatur wahrscheinlich unterhalb von einer Zehntelsekunde CPU-Zeit irgendwie erstellen.
Die müssen schon ein bisschen Arbeit machen, wenn sie sich überprüfen etc. Aber so eine einfache DNS-Security wäre jetzt wirklich, kann ja auch ruhig was kosten, soll halt, ich zahle ja auch für meine Domain was, soll halt im Preis der Domain-Inklusivität sein.
Das ist überhaupt nicht ein, warum dieser Basic-Level von Security Geld kosten soll.
Das kostet halt wie so viel wie die Domain. Also kostet halt, ist bald einer Domain mit dabei. Domain brauchst du ja auch.
159 CA-Zertifikate habe ich in meiner Keychain.
Nö, ich will nicht mehr als meine Domain bezahlen.
Ja, sag ich doch. Inner Domain dabei, aber...
Ja, was heißt dabei? Es ist aber nicht dabei.
Ja, es sollte dabei sein.
Ja, aber dann müsste ja dein Domain-Provider dir diese Zertifikate geben.
Wär doch super. Irgendjemand muss doch... Wie soll das denn funktionieren? Irgendjemand muss doch dafür gerade stehen, für den ganzen Scheiß.
Ja, du selbst, du und dann deiner Domain. Ich wollte dir jetzt die ganze Zeit das Prinzip erklären, damit man jemand versteht, wovon wir überhaupt reden. Seit einiger Zeit gibt es halt DNSSEC. Also die Technologie gibt es schon länger, aber jetzt wird sie halt auch langsam implementiert. Sprich, es gibt ein Zertifikat für die Root-Zone, also die Root-Server des Internets, für uns derzeit. 13 sind es nicht mehr, es sind mehr, keine Ahnung, sowas. Das heißt, die sind alle irgendwie signiert. Sprich, wenn du da eine Abfrage machst, dann kannst du eben jetzt auch kryptographisch abgesichert sicher sein, dass du von der richtigen Instanz dort eine Auskunft bekommen hast. Und dementsprechend sind die Top-Level-Domains darunter, wahrscheinlich noch nicht alle, aber einige, DE gehört auf jeden Fall dazu, auch entsprechend signiert. Das heißt, wenn du bei DE eine Abfrage machst, bei den Nameservern von DENIC, und du kriegst da halt und machst es irgendwie mit DNS-Sac, dann kannst du dir halt sicher sein, dass das jetzt wirklich DENIC war, weil sie eben kriptografisch das belegt haben mit wiederum dem Key des Root-Servers etc. Und das ist halt einfach hierarchisch nachvollziehbar, dass du jetzt eben eine richtige Antwort bekommen hast und dir nicht irgendjemand, irgendeinen DNS-Server, man in the middle-mäßig dazwischen geworfen hat, der dir irgendwas anderes sagt.
Aber davon ist noch nicht mein Treffik verschlüsselt?
Nein, nein. Das bezieht sich überhaupt nicht auf Treffik oder sonst irgendwas.
Man kann sich nur erst mal darauf verlassen, dass die DNS-Information stimmt.
Das ist zum Beispiel beim Camp. Das erste, als ich meinen Rechner aufgemacht hab, war Google plötzlich in Russisch. Ah, stimmt, Nameserver eintragen, alles klar. Und dann auch wieder Google, ganz normal. Aber dass so DNS-Servers spoofen ist auf so CCC-Veranstaltungen auch mal.
Das war nicht gespooft, das war, weil Google dachte, dass der IP-Range vom Camp irgendwie in Russland ist. Nein, die haben gedacht, dass es so ist. Wir waren auf einem ehemaligen...
Ja, aber das Netz kam ja nun von ganz woanders.
Google hat das mal gegoogelt.
Aber DNS-Servers spoofen ist trotzdem ein großer Hackersport, davon mal abgesehen.
Ok, jetzt kommt das nächste Ding. Theoretisch, und da weiß ich nicht, wie es dir mit den Werkzeugen so aussieht, und wie einfach das ist. Das ist bestimmt nicht einfach, aber theoretisch ist es jetzt vorstellbar, dass du mit deiner Domain unter.de dich dann auch von.denig signieren lassen kannst. Sodass dein Nameserver, den du dann betreiben kannst, der quasi autorativ für deine Domain-Auskünfte rausgibt, auch entsprechend kryptographisch abgesichert nach außen zur Kenntnis geben kann, dass das eben jetzt... Was hast du für ein Domain, Max? 343max.de 343max.de, so der Nameserver von 343max.de sagt dann eben, ja, ich weiß Bescheid über 343max.de, meine Aussagen sind zuverlässig, ich kann das hier kryptographisch auch belegen, dass ich auch der Richtige bin, der das tun darf. Und in dem Moment, wo du so weit bist, kannst du natürlich auch für deine ganzen Records in deiner Domäne entsprechend kryptographisch sichere Aussagen treffen. Und das eröffnet überhaupt erstmals die Möglichkeit, dass man eben auch Zertifikate für deine Webseiten direkt von deinem eigenen Nameserver kommen können.
Achso, du meinst also, dass mein SSL, mein Public Key, wird nicht von einer zentralen Authority ausgeliefert, sondern der wird mit per DNS?
Von deinem Nameserver, so wie die IP-Adresse von dir kommt schon heute. Dann käme dann auch das Zertifikat gleich mit. Und dann könnte man eben sicher sagen, ah, und das ist das Zertifikat zu dieser Webseite, dann verbinde ich mich zu dieser Webseite, da kommt dann das gleiche Zertifikat, alles ist super.
Oh, das will ich haben.
Genau. Und das keine Kosten, alles unter deiner Kontrolle. Du kannst dir ja tausende Millionen von Zertifikaten erzeugen, ohne dass es irgendwas kostet. Du musst halt nur aufpassen, dass da in der Büchse nicht gehakt wird.
Nein, man bräuchte den Key ja nicht mal auf der Büchse liegen zu lassen. Obwohl, für SSL würde man einen anderen Key nehmen als für...
Naja, ich sag nur, du musst ja natürlich immer darüber sagen, deine eigene Infrastruktur ist dann halt das nächste Ziel, aber das ist ja auch heute schon. Aber grundsätzlich erlaubt DNSSEC einfach eine Architektur, in der eben diese ganzen blöden CA-Firmen, die man eh hasst, einfach nicht benötigt würden. Zumindest nicht, wenn man einen eigenen Domain hat.
Ich hab ja zum Thema Security, ich sitze ja an so einem kleinen Projekt, bei dem ich gerne Daten über meinen Server austauschen möchte, tendenziell relativ sensible Daten, die ich gar nicht wissen möchte von meinen Usern. Und will darum in die entsprechende App eine Verschlüsselung einbauen. Und das ist schon mal richtig schön kompliziert. Das ist echt pain in the ass. Besonders gemein ist es deswegen, weil ich hab auf der einen Seite eine Browser-Extension, das heißt, da hab ich nur JavaScript. Das heißt, ich muss die Encryption einmal JavaScript machen. Und einmal auf dem IOS, also ein C oder Objective-C, wobei das sowas ist ja mal ein C. Und jetzt hab ich mir mal so ein paar Bibliotheken für angeguckt, hab da jetzt dank alicelikebob, der mir so heißt auf Twitter, der hat mir halbe Vorträge geschickt, wie dieses ganze Security-Zeug funktioniert. Dieses ganze Securitys. Na ja, du hast nicht einfach nur ein Passwort. Also ich dachte so, alles klar, man hat hier Daten, und da hat man ein Passwort, dann nimmt man ein Passwort und man sagt, hier schmeißt man mit dem Daten zusammen, und derjenige, der auf der anderen Seite das Passwort hat, der kann es wieder ausmachen. Würde mir total reichen, diese Form von Sicherheit.
Schön wär's.
Du brauchst ein Key und du brauchst ein IV, also hier Initialization Vector.
Ja, dann machst du aber schon nicht normale Verschlüsselung, sondern kommst jetzt mit Public...
AIS-Verschlüsselung. Stinknormale AIS-Verschlüsselung. Was die nämlich alle machen mit den Passwörtern, ist nämlich aus deinem Passwort ein Key und ein IV zu generieren. Dieser Prozess ist aber schon mal, wenn ich das so richtig kapiert habe, nicht so hundertprozentig standardisiert. Auf jeden Fall ist er bei keiner dieser Bibliotheken dabei. Wenn es um Security geht, kann man ja innerhalb von ungefähr einer Millisekunde, wenn man davon keine Ahnung hat, also eigentlich ist ja schon, sobald man anfängt, sich mit dem Thema zu beschäftigen, hat man massive Sicherheitslücke eingebaut, sodass ich sowas auf keinen Fall selber implementieren möchte. Wahrscheinlich wird es jetzt darauf hinauslaufen, dass ich einfach total auf das Passwort verzichte und mir direkt ein Key und ein IV generieren lasse und die dann halt mit dem User austausche, was für meine Bedürfnisse absolut okay ist. So, und dann kann man immer noch, dann hat man das ganze Zeug zwar verschlüsselt, aber man kann auf der anderen Seite immer noch nicht verifizieren, dass man auch, dass niemand diese Daten manipuliert hat. Weil die können sich nicht selber verifizieren, sondern da kann man dann zufällig einen Bit umkippen innerhalb dieser Nachricht.
Na ja, dann du willst halt eben nicht nur verschlüsseln, du willst auch noch das authentizieren und so weiter. Ich möchte das noch notdürftig authentizieren. Aber dafür brauchst du dann nur noch eine CheX-Summe mit dran.
Ja, dafür muss man auch eine CheX-Summe mit dran. Und dann hat man plötzlich wieder so ein Geheimnis.
Es gibt so auch alles in Fertig.
Also ich hab bisher nichts gefunden, was es da in Fertig gibt, in JavaScript geschrieben.
Ja, in JavaScript, das klingt auch nicht so gut.
Es soll eine Browser-Extension werden. Ich hab keine andere Wahl als JavaScript.
Aber irgendwo hast du ja dann einen private Key auch auf der JavaScript-Seite sozusagen.
Ja, der wird dann im Browser abgespeichert.
Den dann jeder sehen kann und benutzen kann.
Nö, jeder kann den nicht sehen. Also jeder, der Zugriff auf deinem Rechner hat, kann den sehen.
Naja, worüber lieferst du die aus?
Die Extension.
Die wird einmal runtergeladen, installiert und dann ist der Key in deinem Browser.
Der wird im Local Store.
Hat jeder den gleichen Key?
Nein, nein. Man kriegt auch, man kann auch jederzeit sagen, hier schmeiß mal die Keys weg hier und dann wird die automatisch neu generiert. Bei Safari gibt es sogar eine Option. In Chrome gibt es leider nichts entsprechendes. Safari hat eine sehr schöne JavaScript API, die auch extrem viel kann. Ich bin mir jetzt nicht hundertprozentig sicher, aber wenn mich nicht alles täuscht, dann haben die nämlich zwei Setting-Storages. Und zwar ein normales und ein secure. Dann kannst du deine Schlüssel sogar im Schlüsselbund ablegen. Und dann sind die, glaube ich, ziemlich gut geschützt. Chrome hat leider nichts Vergleichbares. Und dann ist natürlich Verschlüsseln und Key-Generierung und sowas alles in JavaScript zu machen, ist jetzt sicherlich nicht die schönste Lösung. Aber ich habe eine Lösung, bei der ich mir sicher sein kann, dass solange ich jetzt nicht explizite Hex gegen meine User vornehme, ich keinen Zugriff auf deren Daten habe. Und das ist das, was ich erreichen will. Und das hat mich jetzt die letzten drei Abende fast in den Wahnsinn getrieben, dieses Thema. Jetzt habe ich es erstmal, wenn wir nämlich auf beiden Seiten denselben Key und denselben IV, weil mit dem IV da steht auch nirgendswo. Und die ganzen Beispielimplementierungen für iOS zum Beispiel, die ich mir so angeguckt habe, die setzen den IV bei der entsprechenden Kryptoroutine auf nil. Und dann hat iOS halt irgendwie einen eigenen IV eingebaut. Das funktioniert dann mit anderen iOS-Geräten, aber es funktioniert natürlich nicht mit der entsprechenden JavaScript-Lösung zusammen. Und bis ich das erstmal gebeilt hatte mit diesem dämlichen IV, sind schon ein paar Stunden vergangen. Und bis ich dann sozusagen in zwei Krypto-Algorithmen dasselbe Ergebnis raus hatte und die Daten wieder entschlüsseln konnte, das waren drei Tage, da bin ich echt geschrien vor Begeisterung.
Aber es ist halt so, wenn man sich so ein bisschen mit Sicherheit beschäftigt und man will, dass es wirklich sicher ist, dann ist auch immer Arbeit zu investieren. Also es gibt halt nicht die Sicherheit ohne nachzudenken und ohne sich damit zu beschäftigen. Das ist auch immer so, wenn ich hier irgendwie den Kunst-Studenten so ein bisschen erkläre hier, wer jetzt welche Daten eigentlich so von ihnen lesen kann und wie das so bei Facebook ist und bla. Und dann kommt immer so die Frage, ja und wie, wie kann ich mich schützen? Wie kann ich verschlüsseln und so weiter? Dann erkläre ich ihnen, wie man so E-Mails verschlüsseln kann und so weiter und so fort. Die schalten halt auch sowieso nach zwei Minuten spätestens ab. So zu kompliziert gibt es das nicht auch einfacher. Mit so einem, am liebsten so einem Button so mit einem Schlüssel drauf, wird es secure.
Ja und warum gibt es das nicht?
Ja, weil du kannst, also geht nicht. Du musst halt immer investieren.
Weil man Security nicht outsourcen kann. Nicht wirklich.
Also Sicherheit ist auch immer zu einem gewissen Anteil deine eigene Angelegenheit.
Na ja, es gibt verschiedene Formen von Sicherheit. Also das ist nämlich der Punkt, um den ich mich auch frage. Weil ich hab jetzt auf Twitter einen Haufen Diskussionen angefangen und dann kommen dann auch schnell so Themen wie ja, JavaScript, Browser Security im Browser ist per se immer scheiße. So, weil, und das liegt jetzt relativ auf der Hand, also jetzt zum Beispiel nehmen wir mal an, ich würde, ich gehe auf eine Seite, ich bin jetzt Provider und wenn jemand eine Nachricht schreibt, dann wird die nicht unverschlüsselt an meinen Server geschickt und in der Zwischenzeit und dann da unverschlüsselt abgelegt, sondern ich würde so vorgehen, ich liefere per JavaScript eine Krypto aus, verschlüsselte im Browser mit dieser Krypto und der Server empfängt nur verschlüsselte Daten. Und der Nachteil an der Sache ist, also der größte Nachteil, der da auch gerne angeführt wird, ist ja, aber der Server, der böse Server, der kann ja auch falsche, ein falsches Server-Script ausliefern, was die Daten noch mal zusätzlich unverschlüsselt überträgt und schon bist du unsicher oder total unverschlüsselt und schon hat ein Angreifer deine Daten. Okay, das stimmt, aber wenn die Daten auf dem Server nur verschlüsselt liegen und der Server auch den entsprechenden Schlüssel gar nicht hat, dann ist man plötzlich gegen Einbrüche sicher. Nämlich, wenn da irgendwo ein Server gehackt wird, auf dem ich mich vor 120 Jahren mal meine Kreditkartendaten hinterlegt hab, aus irgendeiner Kurzbeheraus- oder aus irgendeiner Beklopptheit heraus, und da wird heute eingebrochen, dann ist das immer noch mein Problem. Wenn die Daten mit einem Schlüssel verschlüsselt sind, den selbst ich nicht mehr habe, dann ist das kein Problem. Dann haben die halt Datenmöge geklaut. Und ich finde, man sollte so für dieses ganze Security-Scheiß, also das ist zumindest das, was ich jetzt in diesen ganzen Gesprächen mitgekriegt hab, ja, es gibt so eine mega Maximal-Security, aber die meisten Leute wollen doch, also die wollen doch nicht jetzt gleich gegen den iranischen Hardcore-Hacker geschützt sein, sondern die wollen doch erstmal, dass jetzt die Familie nicht in ihre Mails guckt oder ähnliches.
Ja, aber wie willst du das, wenn du dich nicht wenigstens so eine Stunde oder zwei damit, wie es funktioniert, beschäftigst? Also einfach nur blind vertrauen ist ja die eine Sache, aber bis du das jetzt rausgefunden hast, hast du ja schon Zeit investiert.
Wie viel Ahnung hast du von Schlüsseln?
Wie, von was für Schlüsseln?
Schlüssel, physische Schlüssel, diese Dinger aus Stahl.
Mehr als der Durchschnittsbürger wahrscheinlich.
Ich bin der Durchschnittsbürger, ich hab davon überhaupt keine Ahnung. Ich vertraue den Dingern einfach, dass sie eine gewisse...
Weil du nicht auf dem Camp warst.
5 Minuten braucht man für den.
Weil ich nicht auf dem Camp war, ich weiß auch gar nicht, ob ich der...
Max, 5 Minuten, wir sagen, die Amis sind schon 5 Minuten tops.
Dann nehmen wir den hier, der ist ein bisschen sicherer. Es führt aber, es mag sein, dass der nicht...
Was ist denn an dem sicher?
Das ist ein Schlüssel. Stinknormaler Schlüssel. Im Augenblick ist das das einzige, was wir haben, was besseres haben wir nicht.
Aber hallo.
Oh, kommt, wer hat was besseres?
Also, Pokel, Schlüssel.
Das ist aber ein Bestmesser.
Aber klar gibt es bessere Schlüssel. Aber ohne Ende.
Ja, ich bin ein Kryptiko, weil gerade im Chat die Frage kommt. Ich bin ein Kryptiko vorbeigekommen. Die haben auch gleich eine schöne RSA-Verschlüsselung und alles pipa po. Das macht echt eine Menge her. Ich habe jetzt aber das Problem daran ist, vielleicht hat ja da jemand was auf der Gegenseite eben im C kommt.
Also da hätten wir zum Beispiel einen mechanischen elektrischen Schlüssel.
Oh, ein Autoschlüssel. Na die sind ja total...
Das ist ein Türschlüssel tatsächlich. Dann hätten wir hier auch noch solche Schlüssel mit irgendwie von drei.
Okay, ich wollte jetzt gar nicht über Schlüssel diskutieren. Alles, was ich sagen wollte ist...
Du musstest jetzt schon das ausführen lassen.
Nein, muss ich jetzt nicht.
Das ist interessant.
Du hast das da aufgemacht.
Nein, was ich sagen... Hallo, darf ich erst mal kurz mein Thema...
Abnormativ durch, Max. Du hast jetzt ein Thema aufgemacht und kannst es jetzt nicht abwirken.
Ne, das stimmt.
Doch, natürlich kann ich das.
Ja, aber wir wollen das nicht. Ist doch interessant über coole Schlüssel zu reden.
Sollen wir jetzt über Schlüssel reden?
Kann ich mal einfach meinen Satz zu Ende bringen?
Na gut.
So, man braucht von Schlüsseln keine Ahnung zu haben, um sie zu verwenden. Jeder besitzt Schlüssel und für jeden geben sie eine gewisse Ahnung. Das ist eine große Sicherheit, weil wenn der durchschnittliche Einbrecher kommt, dann macht er sich in den seltensten Fällen die Arbeit, dann das Schloss zu knacken, sondern wenn, dann bohren sie meistens das Schloss aus. Also selbst die durchschnittlichen Einbrecher sind zu doof, dieses System zu hacken. Also dafür ist es offensichtlich gut genug. Und warum gibt es sowas nicht auf der IT-Security-Ebene? Warum gibt es da nicht dieses Schloss und ich hab hier einen Schlüssel und damit kann ich meine Mails weitgehend verschlüsseln?
Gibt's doch, aber du willst ja nicht für dich verschlüsseln, sondern du willst ja anscheinend auch mit anderen oder mit einem Server, also mit einer anderen Seite was machen. Das ist so, als wenn du einen Schlüssel hast, wo mehrere Leute Zurecht haben und da kommen wir halt nun mal zu diesem digitalen Teil, was Huckel gerade gezeigt hat und da muss man auch wissen, wie die funktionieren und so weiter. Oder der, der die Dinger einbaut.
Ja, der, der die Dinger einbaut.
Ja, aber du bist doch nicht der normale User. Du willst ja jetzt gerade was bauen. Du bist der Typ, der Schlüssel verkauft oder installiert. Der muss ja auch auskennen.
Ja, aber installier mal auf deinem iPhone das MIME-Zertifikat. Also auf der aktuellen iPhone-Generation geht's ja eh nicht. Aber generier mal so ein scheiß Mail-Email-Krypto-Zertifikat, das du mir jetzt verschlüsseln und signieren kannst.
Du drehst durch.
Das ist, und das ist, ich hab das gemacht. Ich bin zweimal gescheitert. Ich hab von dem scheiß Dreck Ahnung, wie soll meine Oma das hinkriegen? Wie sollen, wie sollen wir alle Security einsetzen, wenn es einfach niemand auf die Reihe kriegt?
Das ist aber auch nicht einfach. Es muss einfach werden.
Ja, aber es muss einfacher gehen.
Mehr würd ich gar nicht sagen.
Ich sag ja auch nichts anderes außer, dass du dich zu einem gewissen Grad halt trotzdem damit beschäftigen musst. Es wäre wünschenswert, wenn es weniger ist, als jetzt zum Beispiel bei GNU-PG oder sowas. Weil du verstehen musst, wie es funktioniert, um sicher, um überhaupt da drin Vertrauen überhaupt zu haben, dass es sicher ist. Sonst kommt halt irgendjemand, hier ich verkauf dir, hier ist sicher. So und du willst nichts damit zu tun haben, glaubst mir, dass es sicher ist.
Es ist ja auch nicht so, dass du dich mit deinem Türschloss nie beschäftigen musst und dass es da nichts zu verstehen gibt.
Richtig viel zu verstehen gibt es ja nicht.
Da musst du schon mal wissen, wann ist es zu und wann ist es nicht zu.
Ein Aufruhrschutzblende ist zum Beispiel auch noch so.
Es ist was, was jeder Sechsjährige hinkriegt. Also solange ich das Ding nicht selber einbaue, ich hab als Sechsjähriger einen Schlittel gehabt und bin in die Wohnung gekommen, konnte die Wohnungstür aufschließen, konnte es wieder abschließen.
Aber es ist nun mal alles nicht so einfach im Internet.
So viele Sachen sind so einfach im Internet. Warum ist ausgerechnet das so kompliziert?
Im Internet können die Leute da noch nicht mal ordentlich diskutieren miteinander, ohne sich gleich an den Google zu kümmern.
Schlimmer.
Noch schlimmer als Podcast dieses Internet.
Alles, was ich sagen wollte, ist, dieser Security-Scheiß, der muss auch irgendwann mal einfach werden. Und zwar jetzt vielleicht nicht beliebig einfach.
Da sind wir uns, glaube ich, auch alle einig. Da brauchen wir überhaupt gar nichts zu diskutieren.
Mehr wollte ich gar nicht sagen. Jetzt können wir gerne über Schlüssel reden.
Ja, naja, also auf jeden Fall könntest du dein Wissen über normale Schlüssel und warum du auch mehr Angst haben solltest, kannst du dir auf so einem Camp oder im Kongress, wenn die Lockpicker da sind, auf jeden Fall aktualisieren lassen.
Aber letztendlich kann man auch sagen, dass die meisten Türen, die kann man, also hat irgendwie Zähdpunkt, die ja letztens ja auch so eine schöne Geschichte erzählt, wo irgendwie irgendwelche dubiosen Leute an irgendeiner Wohnungstür mit einem Schlagbohrer versucht haben, um die aufzubohren. Dabei hätte wahrscheinlich ein behärzter Tritt gegen selbige auch gereicht. Also wenn man halt irgendwie so eine billige Baumarkthaustür hat, mit irgendwie kleinen Scharnieren und einer Scheißblende, die wird halt aufgetreten. Dann braucht man auch keinen coolen Schlüssel. Aber wenn man zumindest so diese Grundvoraussetzung erfüllt hat und dann irgendwie zumindest mal so eine Blende mit Aufbohrschutz hat, nicht einen Baumarktschloss nennen, wo man eine Büroklammer reinsteckt, um es aufzumachen.
Das Krasse ist doch, in den meisten Fällen funktioniert es doch erstaunlich gut mit diesem mit diesem schlechten Schloss. Das ist ja, also ich hab...
In den meisten Fällen würde Rot13 reichen.
Also so kann es ja nicht kommen.
Naja, aber ich meine, das wäre doch sogar das, wieso soll man damit nicht kommen? Indem man fragt, ich brauche hier so, dann machst du Rot13, dann kriegt das erst mal, dann versteht...
Dann kann keiner schon wieder drüber greppen, dann muss ja schon wieder einer richtig ausgabben.
Genau so ist es mit dem Hausfimlo.
Jemand kennt sich immer aus, klar. Ja, und das Ding ist, an der Tür können nicht 23 Millionen gleichzeitig versuchen, das Schloss zu knacken im Internet oder sonst, also...
Im Internet sind halt Bots und Tools unterwegs, die das für einen machen, das ist das Problem.
Da hackt ja auch niemand selber, weißt du, da sind halt die Chinesen, die da dir einen Rechner vollballern und...
Ich bin mir der Problematik durchaus bewusst, ich wollte es jetzt auch nicht so eins zu eins übertragen, aber ich fände jetzt zum Beispiel mit diesem, hier mit Fallwort und allein, ich finde das, das ist genau diese Verschlüsselung, die ich haben will. Ich schalte das ein, ich richte da ein Passwort ein, ich sichere meinen Key auf irgendeinen USB-Stick, den ich hoffentlich so gut versteckt habe, dass niemand findet und...
Oder du gibst ihn gleich Apple.
Oder ich geb ihn Apple. Ehrlich gesagt frage ich mich, ob Apple sich den nicht auch so holt. Ob der CIA sowas zulassen würde, egal. Auf jeden Fall habe ich jetzt eine Verschlüsselung, von der ich jetzt mal davon ausgehe, dass sie hinreichend sicher ist, weil entsprechende Kryptografen stürzen sich da drauf.
Genau. Aber du hast zumindest schon mal in der Wikipedia nach AIS wahrscheinlich geguckt und hast dich zumindest auch da ein bisschen informiert.
Für Fivebot? Keine Sekunde lang.
Du wirst schon mal irgendwas zu AIS und so weitergelesen haben. Du weißt, dass es ein Standard ist.
Aber es ist wieder die Standardverschlüsselung, die du nicht mit jemand anderem tauscht, wo du irgendwie Mails schicken willst.
Ja, aber guck mal, bis Apple das eingebaut hat, war das auch kompliziert. Wie kompliziert war es vorher, sich eine verschlüsselte Partition anzulegen?
Unter Linux?
Total einfach. Braucht man höchstens ein zehnseitiges Manual durchzulesen? Nein, tatsächlich. Also, ich will ja nichts anderes sagen als man... Man kann das einfach machen. Und wenn selbst Linux das hinkriegt, dann ist das ja... Das beweist ja meinen Punkt noch umso mehr.
Das Verschlüsseln an sich war ja eigentlich noch nie so das Problem, sondern eher halt dieses Keys austauschen und signieren und dieser ganze Scheiß.
Doch, auch das Verschlüsseln war schon ein Problem, weil das konnte... Also, das können die meisten Leute einfach nicht.
Wieso? Das gab es doch schon vorher mit...
Point taken. Wir sind uns alle einig, Sicherheit muss einfacher werden. E-Mail-Verschlüsselung ist schwierig. Domain-Verschlüsselung ist noch schwieriger.
Hätte ich auch gar nicht gedacht, dass dieses Digi-Notar-Thema sich dann gleich noch so universenspeichend aufhält.
Abgesehen davon, über Schlüssel könnte man eigentlich auch noch mal reden.
Das ist doch dieser Standard, dieser dicke...
Wie hast du es bezeichnet?
Ein elektromechanischer Schlüssel.
Das ist so, dass in dem Schlüssel ist... Erstens hat er ein kleines Display, muss man mal sagen. Zweitens ist da eine Batterie drin, natürlich für das Display. Aber auch, dass wenn du den Schlüssel in das Schloss steckst und die Signatur passt oder der Key oder was auch immer, die dafür ein Voodoo machen, dass die Batterie in dem Schlüssel einen kleinen Magneten in dem Schloss auslöst, der das Häkchen frei gibt, dass man überhaupt erst mal drehen kann. Sonst kann man nämlich nicht drehen. Das heißt, zusätzlich zur mechanischen Absicherung ist da noch der Key drin, der dafür sorgt, dass man überhaupt drehen kann. Da wird wirklich magnetisch noch so ein kleiner Pin freigegeben und sonst kann man nicht umdrehen. Das heißt, man kann auch, wenn Hucke diesen Schlüssel verliert, nicht picken, kann er zu sich nach Hause gehen, kann seinem Schloss sagen, den Schlüssel hab ich verloren. Und wenn dann der Dieb mit dem Schlüssel kommt, dann sagt das Schloss, mag ja sein, aber deine Signatur ist nicht mehr gültig und ich mach den Pin nicht frei und du kannst nicht drehen.
Ach so, dass das Schloss in der Tür entriegelt, nicht der Schlüssel. Es ist nicht, dass du da mit einem Magneten kommen musst, sondern innen gibt es einen magnetischen Riegel, der nur freigegeben wird, wenn der richtige Key kommt.
Genau, und das Schloss selbst ist aber stromlos. Das heißt, das wird über den Schlüssel irgendwie ausgelöst.
Genau, hier sind so zwei Kontakte und wenn du reinsteckst, speist sozusagen die Batterie im Schlüssel, diesen ganzen, für diesen kleinen überhaupt.
Das heißt, selbst dann, also da kann gar kein Stromausfall sein und so weiter und so fort, das ist auch ein eigener Einer, du musst kein Stromkabel verlegen und so weiter und so fort.
Aber du brauchst dann eine entsprechende IT-Infrastruktur in deiner Tür, die dann die Schlüsselverwaltung macht, sozusagen.
Ne, du kannst, es gibt einen Programmierschlüssel, mit dem du auch den Zylinder sozusagen unabhängig von einem...
Und wo speichert dann diese Tür das im Schloss?
Naja, ne, du hast halt, du hast noch eine Station noch dazu. Da steckst du deinen neuen Schlüssel, den du jetzt benutzen willst, halt rein und provisionierst den irgendwie, keine Ahnung. Und dann gehst du irgendwie mit dem Masterkey, der muss glaub ich da auch einmal rein. Und dann gehst du mit dem Masterkey zum Schloss und ich weiß nicht, ob du dann...
Ja, aber es muss ja in, ich meine wenn...
So wird im Schloss gespeichert, weil es muss ja da sein.
Genau, irgendwas wird im Schloss auf jeden Fall gespeichert.
Also das Ding hat Flash sozusagen oder irgendwie...
Da muss man mal unsere Hardcore-Schlüssel-Experten im Club befragen. Die kennen sich damit noch um einiges besser aus.
Aber ich hab auch schon überlegt, was so...
Es ist aber auch eher ein System für mehrere Schlösser und mehrere Schlüssel, weil...
Nö, ist klar, aber so generell, wenn man so Infrastruktur hat, die man auch mal von jemand anderem nutzen lassen möchte, aber vielleicht nicht immer so, da will man ja irgendwie sowas haben und...
Ich weiß nicht, ob es flexibel genug ist, als dass du da andauernd irgendwie Schlüssel umprogrammieren kannst. Vielleicht ist ja noch zu aufwendig. Du denkst ja schon wieder was an so von 7 bis 10 darf er und danach nicht, oder so in die Richtung schon, also so richtig flexibel?
Ja, noch besser fände ich es, dass man was, was ich, an verschiedene Leute Schlüssel rausgibt und dass ich dann so übers Internet sagen kann, der darf jetzt von dann und dann auch mal aufschließen.
Das ist halt eine relativ alte Generation, da gibt es auch natürlich schon wieder die nachfolgende Generation.
Okay, die Alternative wäre halt Chipkarte, ne? Also, und RFID...
Der Herr Kijowski zum Beispiel im Club, ne?
Gibt es nichts Ungehacktes derzeit bei RFID?
Also bei den Schlüsselkarten glaube ich nicht.
Aber im Club gibt es ja genug Expertise diesbezüglich, da kannst du dich...
Aber das war jetzt nicht von dir zu Hause, das...
Der von zu Hause war dieser kleine Blaue.
Was war denn da auf dem Display drauf? Dieses traurige Baby-Gesicht, was den Windows-Kur erinnert?
Nee, der war neutral. Wenn du es reinsteckst und du bist halt nicht berechtigt, dann macht er ein trauriges Gesicht. Und wenn du reinsteckst und bist berechtigt, dann macht er ein Smiley und dann kannst du drehen. Und ich hatte mal, mir ist der einmal runtergefallen, also einer davor, dann hatte der so ein Displayfehler genau über dem Mund und das sah aus wie so ein kleines Hitler-Bärtchen. Und dann, wenn du reingesteckt hast in die falsche Tür, dann hat er auch ein trauriges Gesicht gemacht. So, der traurige Hitler.
Es ist eine Freude mich für Sie zu eröffnen und zu wissen, dass ich eine gute Tat getan habe.
Hitler ist traurig.
Als ich von Dms Visionen werden langsam war, musste da die Batterie auswechseln, oder wie ist das?
Ja, also für den Schlüssel, den hab ich jetzt schon anderthalb Jahre, da musste ich die Batterie noch nicht wechseln.
Okay, also das ist selten genug.
Also ich schließ auch nicht sehr viel da in der Uni rum, aber er entlädt sich zumindest nicht selber in der Hosentasche oder so.
Hey, wo hast du denn die Ersatzschlüsselbatterien? Die liegen da in dem Schupffach, den sie sich abgeschlossen haben. Türenperse aufmachen.
Themen, Themen, Themen.
Na hier, das große Orakel.
Das große Orakel? Achso, meinst du, wir müssen nochmal iPhone 5 aufmachen oder was?
Ja, wir kommen nicht drum rum, glaube ich.
Ich hab noch ein Thema.
Ich hab auch noch ein Thema, aber wir können trotzdem über das iPhone 5 reden. Obwohl ich da ein bisschen Angst habe davor, beim Thema.
Jetzt hast du ja gerade schon hier den Mac-Rumor schonmal geöffnet, dass Max eigentlich recht hat.
Ich weiß nicht genau, was Max vorhin gemeint hat. Ob er von 3G Data sprach oder von Telefon. Ich hab immer Telefon gehört. Das Rumor sagt nicht Telefon, sondern das sagt einfach, dass das Ding wie das iPad quasi 3G Data haben könnte. Ist aber nicht eine SIM-Karte im Sinne von Telefonieren, sondern halt nur Data Only.
Ja, das wäre natürlich die andere Option. Wobei steht das da irgendwo, dass es nur Data Only ist?
Na ja, ich mein, sonst wär's ein iPhone. Was ist denn sonst noch der Unterschied?
Na ja, schlechteres Display, schlechtere Kamera, all diese Features, was jetzt schon beim iPod Touch schlechter ist, als beim iPhone. Hast du mal ein iPod Touch und ein iPhone der aktuellen Generation nebeneinander gehalten? Da hast du das eine hat ein verdammt geiles Display, das andere hat ein schlechtes Display.
Ja, und so richtig scheiße, wenn du das scrollst, siehst du so Streifen, als wenn die da irgendwie eine geringere Wiederholungsrate haben. Also sieht schon ganz schön anders aus. Also echt so wie so diese, kennst du diese ganz billigen Displays, die so Streif-Effekte haben?
Ja klar, die Software soll ja dieselbe sein, aber es ist halt so ein bisschen billiger. Und vielleicht lassen sie aber wirklich den Telefonteil fest und weg und sagen, guck mal, hier, FaceTime Voice. Und telefonieren kannst du dann eben erstmal nur im W-Lan, solange bis die Provider irgendwann mal einknicken. Ich meine, irgendwann muss der Schritt ja auch mal gegangen werden.
Ich komm echt nicht mehr hinterher. FaceTime ist es auf dem iPad Touch oder nicht?
Ja, ich glaub schon. Guck mal, da oben ist sogar das Icon. Sogar in dem Screenshot da oben links ist das FaceTime-Icon.
Das ist kein Screenshot, sondern das ist eine Rumor-Seite.
Ja, das ist eine Rumor-Seite und die haben ein offizielles Pressebild. Das iPad hat ja auch FaceTime.
Das kommt mir echt nicht mehr hinterher.
Es gibt auch gar keinen FaceTime-Icon.
Beim iPad und beim iPhone schon. Beim iPad hab ich das jetzt mal in der letzten Woche. Meine Freundin war in Frankreich und da konnten wir mal schön FaceTime nutzen. Auf dem iPad macht das, hätte ich nie gedacht, aber macht wirklich Spaß. Es ruckelt leider ziemlich, weil das WLAN da auch nicht so stabil war. Aber es ist schon echt cool. Und vor allen Dingen, sie hat sich da das Geld gespart, sich da extra eine SIM-Karte zu holen, weil sie ja WLAN hatte. Und wenn wir da irgendwie das per Roaming hätten, so lange sprechen wollen, wie wir das so gemacht haben, dann wäre ich jetzt arm oder wären wir jetzt arm. Und so war das echt. Macht schon Spaß, dieses FaceTime.
So, also ich lese das hier eher als Data. Auch wenn sie irgendwie, ich meine, sie reden von 3G capable. Die kann eigentlich nur Data, Data connectivity. Davon ist die Rede. Ich meine, das könnte ich mir durchaus vorstellen.
Da würdest du mitgehen.
Aber ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass es ein Gerät gibt, was eben viel billiger ist, dass sie also den iPod Touch, wie sie ihn heute haben, einfach viel billiger machen, um nochmal in ganz andere Bereiche vorzustoßen. Und ob der Nano das überlebt, weiß ich nicht. Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob dieser Nano erfolgreich ist.
Ja, ich weiß auch nicht. Ich sehe eigentlich auch mehr Leute als mit Nano aktuell so.
Die Leute wollen doch alle so ein Teil haben. Andererseits, wenn es die nicht mehr gibt, dann ist nur noch dieser Shuffle da. Und dann gibt es irgendwie nichts Kleines zum Laufen und so weiter. So für Jogger, glaube ich, ist das scheiße.
Aber für Jogger, die nehmen noch Shuffles. Ich glaube schon. Also ich meine, ich habe den jetzt ja auch, ne? So für Sportmarchi und da. Ich dachte ja auch, ich war eigentlich nie ein Shuffle-Freund. Aber ich muss sagen, das ist voll okay. So mit diesem Voice-Over und so. Ich komme damit klar. Machen wir mal eine Playlist vorher im iTunes. Klar, mit hier Podcast, da Mucke, da Elektro. Da hast du nicht gesehen und dann geht's los.
iPod Touch 3G, wo man sich die Voice-Capabilities im App-Store nachkaufen kann. Das Telefon-App kostet irgendwie 30 Euro. Oder per Monthly-Subscription.
Nein, ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob das nicht ganz weitreichende Folgen hat, ob das als Telefon gilt oder nicht, was so die Zulassung von dem Teil betrifft. Naja, ist kein Telefon, das meine ich. Das iPad ist kein Telefon.
Aber hat 3G.
Ja, aber es hat auch...
Wenn es auch telefonieren könnte, würde es unter Umständen in eine andere Kategorie fallen, rechtlich, zulassungstechnisch, was weiß ich.
Also das kriegt doch jeder Schiener. Das ist doch dieses... Diese Tablets, die man dann immer, die Android drauf haben, die aber telefonieren können sie immer noch. Also wenn die das hinkriegen, dann kriegt Apple das auch hin.
Ich sage nicht, dass sie das nicht hinkriegen können, sondern dass es irgendwie finanzielle Implikationen hat. Das ist das, was ich meine.
Ich würde es auf jeden Fall cool finden, wenn man sich das Telefon per App Store nachkaufen kann.
Aber was fehlt denn in diesem iPod Touch sonst noch zum iPhone eigentlich?
Na, dass du das einfach in den Film kriegst.
Ich meine, das Ding hat ein Mikrofon, das Ding hat irgendwie einen Lautsprecher. Wo ist denn der Lautsprecher bei dem Teil? Er hat keinen Lautsprecher oben.
Ich weiß nicht, ob er da ist. Also er hat einen Lautsprecher, aber auf jeden Fall.
Ja, aber er hat keinen Lautsprecher da, wo man dann das Ohr hätte. Also wenn man sich das Ding ans Ohr hält, da ist kein Lautsprecher, oder?
Wie wär's denn damit? Man braucht das iPod-Headset, um damit telefonieren zu können. Das ist der Unterschied. Ein klassisches Telefon, das hält sich so ganz normal ans Ohr, so wie wir das jetzt machen.
Na gut, so ist das ja jetzt auch schon mit Skype und so.
Und da noch jetzt noch eine 3G-Karte rein. Und du kannst irgendwie, es gibt eine Telefon-App, und du kannst eben mit telefonieren. Aber wenn du cool und hip sein willst, dann brauchst du nach wie vor das iPod.
Hoffentlich lassen sie das bald mit den SIM-Karten sein.
Da kannst du lange drauf warten, glaube ich. Da haben die Provider irgendwie zu wenig Bock drauf.
Die wollen ihre Software installieren. So, iPhone 5. Dennis.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, was da kommt.
Mir fällt jetzt ein, ich bin mit meinem iPhone 4 zufrieden und ich könnte mir nicht vorstellen, was besser wird.
Außer schneller.
Also, schneller finde ich wichtig, weil ich finde es noch nicht schnell genug. Es gibt Dinge, da warte ich zu lange.
Ja, aber es ist schon eigentlich ganz cool. Ey, wie gesagt, schneller geht immer.
Ja, dass das ganz cool ist, da sind wir uns glaube ich auch alle einig. Aber wenn ich sagen würde, was wäre für mich ein Incentiv für ein Upgrade? Abgesehen davon, dass wir alle Fanboys sind. Und wir sowieso immer das größte haben.
Also zum Beispiel, ich glaube, dass die die Optik mit dem Rahmen und so, also Apple geht hin oder her, vielleicht machen sie da irgendwie ein bisschen was anders, aber ich glaube, im Großen und Ganzen werden sie das genau so wieder rausbringen. Da werden sie nichts dran ändern. Das machen jetzt noch mal alle so. Du meinst jetzt, dass mit dieser Metallrückwand zum Beispiel und so?
Also zum Beispiel diese ganzen Mockups mit dünner und so ein bisschen so eher Keilförmigkeit und so.
Könnte ich mir schon auch vorstellen. Wende mal diese ganzen Mockups und diese Ruhmaus mal aus. Einfach nur so von dem, was angenommen, wir hätten nichts gelesen. Es wäre überhaupt nicht klar, dass überhaupt ein Telefon kommt.
Also mir fallen nur so Upgrades ein, wie von mir aus Double, hier Dual Power, weißte schon. Multi-Core also. Und mehr Flash natürlich. Mehr RAM weiß ich nicht, vielleicht auch.
Sehe ich aber eh nicht. Eine Verdopplung steht an, weil das hat ja nun schon, letzte Generation hat sich nichts geändert. In der Speicherausstattung und 64 GB fände ich mal ganz angemessen.
Also ich finde, es könnte auch leichter sein, übrigens.
Das mag ich gar nicht.
Ich mag nicht so ganz leichte Sachen.
Es gibt so viele Sachen, wo du viel Platz brauchst. Also hier so Navigations-Applikationen, die gehen mal locker mit 2 GB. Es gibt auch viele Spiele, die tonnenweise Speicher fressen. Also den Bedarf für 64 GB ist auf jeden Fall da. Und ich hab halt immer alles voll mit ein paar Videos, die so für, falls ich mal unterwegs bin und ich will mal einen Film sehen, hab ich halt immer so ein paar ungesehenen Filme immer schon mal so draufliegen.
Gut, Speicher.
Speicher, CPU, okay. Das sind aber alles keine nennens, keine grundsensitüren Besserungen.
Bessere Kamera geht auch immer.
Bessere Kamera wird mit Sicherheit kommen. Schnellere Kamera.
Das wäre mir echt was wert. Das finde ich auch. Also diese Zeit, die es dauert, bis dieses Ding aktiv wird, das dauert einfach viel zu lange.
Ich habe ja mal mein iPhone in der Hand und jetzt halte ich es mal so. Die haben ja jetzt mit iOS 5 den Auslöser hier, dass man den Volume-Plus-Button im Kamera-App drücken kann und dass man dann den Auslöser hat. Früher habe ich das iPhone immer so gehalten, dass der Volume-Button quasi nach unten war, weil das Kameraobjektiv ist hier oben in der Ecke. Wenn man das anders rumhält, dann hält man ungefähr so die Kamera, und der eine Finger ist dann quasi direkt vor der Linse. Das heißt, die werden irgendwas an der Linsenanordnung garantiert ändern oder dieser Volume-Rocker wird auf die andere Seite wandern.
Ich halte es nicht so. Ich habe aber auch in einer anderen Position immer den Finger davor.
War das nicht, dass jetzt so eine Warnung vorne auf dem Display kommt, wenn man den Finger drüber hatte?
Wie jetzt als Rumor? Oder heute ist schon so, bloß wir haben es noch nie gesehen?
Weiß ich jetzt nicht.
Also ich hab das... Also ich hätte gerne mal so eine LED nach vorne oder so.
Ins Gesicht so.
Oder einfach eine Taste, um einfach das Ding als Taschenlampe zu benutzen. Nur was ganz einfaches.
Ich will leichter.
Ja, ich brauch immer Licht und ich mach dann immer das Telefon an und dreh die Helligkeit hoch, weil es keine schnelle Möglichkeit gibt, diese Lampe anzumachen.
Ja, lad dir doch eine dieser hunderttausenden Taschenlampen-Apps runter.
Ja, und dann noch ne App auswählen. Also, ich meine, um nur mal Licht zu haben. Einfach so eine Taste und Licht an und fertig. Das würde mir völlig ausreichen.
Das tastlose, weitgehend tastlose iPhone ausgerechnet für Licht.
Na, was denn hier zum Beispiel, wenn du irgendwie Plus und Minus gleichzeitig drückst oder sowas? Oder wenn du, keine Ahnung... Irgendwas, einfach eine scheiß Taste, um das Ding anzumachen.
Also, ich glaube, sie ändern noch den Formfaktor und ob sie nochmal ein geileres Display hinkriegen, weiß ich nicht. Aber es sind alles nicht so die Kracher. Ich fände zum Beispiel, Dennis ja nicht, aber ich fände leichter wäre auch ein Feature. Ich finde das ein ganz schöner Steine.
Also was ist technisch noch mit ziemlicher Sicherheit?
Was ist denn hier überhaupt mit dem Chat? Was glauben die denn? Was fehlt euch denn bei dem iPhone? Dünnheit.
Aber ich glaube, da können sie nicht mehr viel machen, wenn sie noch mehr RAM reinstecken.
Geigerzähler.
Die Japan-Edition.
Die haben sie ja jetzt auch eingebaut, in gewisser Hinsicht, ne?
Achso, mit dieser Warnung, stimmt.
Also die Erdbebenwarnung, das war es.
In iOS 5 gibt es eine Erdbebenwarnung, genau.
Das ist cool, das will ich auch für Deutschland haben.
Ja, haste quasi.
Ja, was ich schon an Erdbeben verpasst habe, kann ich mich an einen erinnern. Hardware-Keyboard, Höhen-Sensor, Klopperscan-Funktion.
Minimal größeres Display.
Hardware-Keyboard, iOS wird endlich offen, weil ansonsten wird das nie was mit dem iOS.
Ich muss sagen, dass dieses Gerücht mit dem größeren Display, das verstört mich.
Weil das so lange anhält?
Also was wäre denn das Pro und das Contra? Ich meine das Contra ist klar, aber was ist...
Nee, sag doch mal das Contra.
Das Contra ist, dass du einfach für Millionen Ups da draußen auf einmal die Größe änderst.
Genau, gut, das hast du noch mal gesagt.
Und damit änderst du halt alles.
Warte, warte, meinst du, wenn sich die Auflösung ändert?
Ja, nun einfach das Display etwas größer.
Also mehr ein paar Pixel dazu, das kommt nun auf gar keinen Fall. Sie vergrößern jetzt nicht die Pixel-Anzahl? Ja.
Ok, aber wenn sich jetzt nur mit der schon bestehenden Pixel-Anzahl das Display einfach ein Stück größer wird, das heißt dadurch auch die DPI leicht sinkt, wo ist das Problem für irgendwelche Apps?
Also meine AI-App zum Beispiel hätte ein Problem, weil das i, das ich dann daneben halte, als Größenreferenz, als größer angenommen wird, als es, oder als kleiner angenommen wird, auf jeden Fall geht alles durcheinander.
Okay, das ist jetzt nicht Millionen Apps, die dafür angepasst werden müssen, sondern es ist eine App, die dafür angepasst werden muss.
Weil es bei Apple noch keine API gibt, wo man die Debitzahl auslesen kann, oder wie? Oder gibt es die schon? Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht so genau.
Das weiß ich auch nicht. Auf jeden Fall geht alle davon aus, dass das Ding halt genauso groß ist. Ich gebe zu, dass die meisten Programme wahrscheinlich gar nicht mal unbedingt darunter leiden würden.
Ich kann keins außer dein AI-App.
Na gut, aber größeres Telefon heißt, dass das Telefon größer ist.
Aber mal ehrlich, breiter würde ich das jetzt nicht haben wollen. Es liegt genauso gut an. Die haben die Breite nicht umsonst so geregelt.
Aber es sind noch so ein halber Zentimeter links und rechts Platz.
Ja, weil du hast doch Hände irgendwie. Wir beide haben Hände, da kann doch keiner mithalten.
Aber ich meine jetzt hier, da ist ja noch schwarzer Rand. Den könnten sie auch ein bisschen ins Metall gehen.
Aber da kommt ja immer ein Pflasterrahmen drum rum, damit das Apple-Gate, das Athenagate nicht stört.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob sie jetzt schon soweit sind, aber ein Display, was ein Modus hat, also so ein Modus zwischen an und aus. Also nicht nur dieses...
Now we are talking, genau, das was sie da als Patent hatten, dass durch das Display durch irgendwie hinterhinter noch so LEDs sind, die so Symbole durchs Display durchscheinen lassen, obwohl das Hauptdisplay eigentlich aus ist. Da gab es immer noch so ein Patent, oder? Das hätte ich gerne. Weil ich hätte es gerne so leicht blinkend, also nicht blinkend, so leicht, wie sagt man, so an und ausgehen, so stresslos, dass ich zum Beispiel eine SMS hab oder dass da ein Anruf war, weil jetzt musst du halt immer erst draufklicken, um zu sehen, alles klar, da war nichts, oder alles klar, du hast gerade keinen Empfang. Und das könnte das ja irgendwie mal so dezent irgendwie durchs Display anzeigen.
Ich meine, so diese AMO-LED-Displays, die können das ja schon. Die können ja, die leuchten ja selber. Das heißt, du kannst ja, es wird ja nur, es verbraucht ja nur Teil, der Teil des Displays Strom, der gerade beleuchtet ist. Wo gerade ein Pixel an ist. Das heißt, du würdest einfach das Display schwarz machen. Würdest nur ein paar, irgendwie ein paar Icons leuchten lassen, würde nicht viel Strom verbrauchen. Könntest du vielleicht noch ein bisschen dunkel machen. Und das wäre gegeben. Ich weiß nicht, ob diese AMO-LEDs-Display mittlerweile gut genug sind und in ausreichender Stückzahl produziert werden können. Ich zweifle ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen daran. Aber das wäre auf jeden Fall nochmal was Geiles.
Also wie sie es mit der Technik machen, ist mir am Ende eigentlich irgendwie Schnuppe. Aber ich finde, da könnte man noch was machen, dass ich irgendwie sozusagen durch mein iPhone auch irgendwie informiert werde, ohne unbedingt jetzt immer draufklicken zu müssen oder so.
Hier kommen auch noch ein paar schöne Sachen. Vorschlag. Homebutton mit Touchfunktion. Beim Schieben nach oben geht die Taschenlampe an. Na ja, also ich meine, man könnte ja schon noch eine Touchfläche schaffen oder so. Laserpointer. Das werden sie glaube ich nicht machen.
Pointerstift kannst du auch verknicken.
Aber hier, Major Product Transition wäre auch mal ein iPhone ohne Homebutton.
Wie man einen bauen.
Das gab es ja auch als Gerücht.
Was auf jeden Fall noch kommt, das ist jetzt definitiv kein alleiniger Selling-Point, aber das ist, dass dieses Airplay über Wi-Fi, also beim iPad 2 und Apple TV kann man ja den Inhalt des Displays bzw. Bildschirmausgabe auch über Wi-Fi auf dem Fernseher haben, was eigentlich ein total geiles Feature ist. Und ich wette, das wird für das iPhone auch kommen, dass du dein Fernseher als externes Display von deinem iPhone nutzen kannst.
Jetzt reden wir über Software, ne?
Das ist nicht Software, sondern es ist auch Chip, weil du brauchst die entsprechende Leistung, die Grafikkarte, die in der Lage ist. Du musst ja diese gesamte Ausgabe, die du auf der Grafikkarte machst, parallel dazu nochmal über das Wi-Fi schicken. Und ich glaube, im Augenblick ist der Grund, warum das iPhone nicht kann, ist eine Hardware-Beschränkung.
Das Mirroring geht nicht?
Dieses Mirroring geht nicht, genau.
Das geht nur auf dem iPad?
Das geht nur auf dem iPad.
Aber auch auf dem alten iPad? Ach echt? Nicht auf dem alten?
Also auf dem alten geht es nicht mal über Kabel. Also das iPad, auf dem alten, da hat das jemand per Jailbreak hingekriegt. Da ist es offensichtlich ein reines Softwareproblem, dass Apple das nicht freigeschaltet hat. Aber mit diesem Wi-Fi-Mirroring, das ist nochmal eine andere Ausnummer.
Ja, so eine Blink-LED kommt hier auch noch.
Das wird auf keinen Fall kommen.
Auf gar keinen Fall. Und schon überhaupt gar nicht wird das blinken, solange da nix ist. Also ein Blinken soll schon gar nicht. Ich sehe diese Leuchte hier am Laptop, die halt so leicht pulst.
Also mir würde das weiterhelfen.
Mein Laptop hat ja nicht mal mehr.
Ich meine, es gibt einen, ich hab ein Problem.
Oh, das ist doch viel zu schmal dafür. Nee, der hat keine.
Mich stört eine Sache, die müssten sie aber eigentlich per Software lösen.
Wobei das ist eigentlich auch geil. Weil es ist halt, es gibt kein An und Aus mehr. Klappst das Ding auf und dann ist es immer da. Der hält ja auch irgendwie 30 Tage im Sleep-Modus durch. Warum brauchst du da eine Lampe? Ich meine, machst du noch eh nie aus.
Ja, das ist wieder typisch Apple. Letzten Mausbutton gekillt, letzte LED gekillt. Irgendwann löschen sie noch das Keyboard und das Display. Und dann haben wir unser Brain Interface. Und dann gibt es am Ende das perfekte von, ja, also eigentlich Apples perfektes Produkt, wäre eine Alukugel. Ohne alles. Keine Buttons, keine Ecken, kein nichts mehr.
Aber eine Unibody Alukugel. Aus einem Stück, aber trotzdem in den Hohl. Niemand weiß, wie sie es geschafft haben.
Das ist ja auch bei dieser Apple Remote, die ich ja auch sehr schätze, die ist ja auch aus einem Stück. Und sie müssen die Elektronik da auch irgendwie durch, da wo das Clickwheel ist, durchgefunden haben.
Ich hab mir bei iFixit eine entsprechende Anleitung dazu angeguckt. Ich glaube, die gehen einfach durch den Batterieport hinten.
Das ist einfach keine Platine mehr, sondern die haben die Elektronik wahrscheinlich auch auf so dieses orangene Billigkabel, da musst du ja gar nicht mehr auf was festen. Das ist eine Platine.
Ich hab das, ja, ja.
Aber es ist halt, also...
Unibody-iPhone.
Wieso, wir sind schon fertig, das kann doch wohl nicht sein. Das Scheißteil wird irgendwie der Mega-Breakthrough und wir sitzen hier und haben nicht auch nur einen Funken-Ahnung.
Ja, so ist es doch immer.
Apple lacht sich ein, die Konkurrenz liegt sowieso am Boden. Die machen jetzt erst mal ein Jahr Pause.
Ja, die Konkurrenz von Apple, aber ich meine, wir sind ein Macintosh-Podcaster, da müssen wir noch irgendwie...
Oder Steve ist nochmal rasch zurückgetreten.
Oh Gott, was ist das für ein hässliches Ding, damit wir die nicht so tun haben? Die machen ein Jahr Pause, die haben es gar nicht nötig, ein neues Phone rauszubringen. Das ist einfach so geil.
Weißt du, was mich am meisten nervt an meinem Telefon? Also was mir wirklich richtig am allermeisten stinkt?
Jetzt kommt es, fehlt bestimmt wieder ein Podcast-Feature.
Das ist noch mal ein ganz anderes Thema. Damit fange ich jetzt gar nicht erst an.
Gut.
Es ist Helligkeit. Also was mich wirklich total nervt ist, jeden Tag ändere ich die Helligkeit mehrere Male. Und es ist völlig nervig, ich muss in die Settings gehen und irgendwie in diesen blöden Slider rumnippeln und so. Und es ist irgendwie nicht möglich, dass dieses Telefon mal eine Helligkeit einstellt, die der Außenhelligkeit auch entspricht. Ich meine, da gibt es so einen Automatik-Modus. Warum? Also nachts, wenn ich im Bett das Ding benutze, dann möchte ich es so dunkel wie möglich haben. Ich stelle es auf den niedrigsten Wert. Wenn du mit dem niedrigsten Wert dann allerdings raus ins Tageslicht gehst am nächsten Tag, dann erkennst du gar nichts. Das heißt, du siehst nichts mehr auf diesem Telefon. Du schaltest es ein und du musst die Hand davor halten, um irgendwie auch nur zu erahnen, wo die User-Interface-Elemente sind. Das Teil ist nicht in der Lage, mit seinem scheiß Helligkeitssensor festzustellen, dass es draußen strahlend hell ist. Und der doch mal vielleicht das Display vielleicht so hell machen sollte, dass man überhaupt mal irgendwas erkennt. Das heißt, wie ein Blinder tippe ich dann in diesem Teil rum, irgendwie ratend, wo jetzt wahrscheinlich die Icons sind, nur um dann in Settings, Menü, Helligkeit, um dieses Teil dann hell zu machen, damit ich es überhaupt benutzen kann. Also ich kann es vorher gar nicht benutzen.
Dieser Auto-Brightness-Switch, der tut auch eigentlich nichts.
Ja, der tut so ganz bisschen sowas. Aber das ist nicht das, was ich davon erwarten würde. Also ich meine, Auto-Brightness würde ich erwarten...
Auto-Brightness.
Ich würde erwarten, dass wenn ich Auto-Brightness einschalte, dass ich dann überhaupt gar keine Helligkeit mehr einstellen kann.
Ja, aber dann wärst du ja richtig gearscht. Ich glaube, das wird mit iOS 5, das ist so was, was ich wirklich nochmal, da muss man eigentlich nur, eigentlich baust du nur ein hübsches Icon, ein Slider und noch irgendwas drunter. Ich hab noch keine Idee für das drunter, weil iOS 5 bietet ja eine API für die Einstellung der Helligkeit an. Also man kann ja dann per In-App, per Call, gibt's einen offiziellen API-Call, um die Helligkeit des Displays einzustellen. Das heißt, es wird ungefähr 48 Fantastillionen billiger Apps geben für 79 Cent, die alles nicht so weitermachen, als einen Helligkeitseicon zu haben und einen Slider, mit dem die Helligkeit einstellen kannst. Und ich überlege, ob ich sowas auch baue. Ich glaube, das wird weggehen. Leute wie Tim, die dann die Helligkeit einstellen wollen, so schnell über eine einfache kleine App. Das wird es viele geben.
Na dann, ran an den Speck.
Ja, es ist halt schnell gemacht.
Wir überlassen dir mal den Markt großzügigerweise.
So blöd es klingt. Das ist das, was mich am meisten nervt an diesem iPhone.
Ich seh schon den neuen Apple-Spot. Sie hatten ein New iPhone 5.
Improved reliability heißt das bei Apple.
Also mit welchem Killer-Feature kommen sie? Mit gar keinem. Sie sagen einfach nur alles besser.
Gehen wir noch mal alles durch. Das kann doch nicht sein, dass wir irgendwas... Vielleicht kommt ja doch diese scheiß Bezahlnummer. Oder, äh...
Gibt's denn neue Standards, die nicht LTE sind, wo du das iPhone nochmal nachlegen könnte? Davor, da gibt's doch noch 14 Mbit, oder wo sind wir jetzt gerade bei 7 noch, oder? Oder sind wir schon mal 14, ich hab keine Ahnung.
Also hier, wie heißt das, was ist der aktuelle Bluetooth-Standard? Bluetooth 3, Bluetooth 4? 4.0. Der soll ja noch mal so extrem stromsparend sein. Ach genau, das hatt ich mit der... Das wär ein schönes Feature. Das MacBook hat ja schon...
5 GHz WLAN?
Oh Gott, das wird Zeit. Ja, aber das ist sowas, das sollte endlich mal kommen. Das sollte einfach da sein. Darüber möchte ich gar nicht reden müssen.
Das wäre wünschenswert, oder?
Auf jeden Fall.
Wäre wünschenswert.
Die Frage ist, ob sich das ohne weiteres realisieren lässt, weil das ist ein Antennenproblem.
Das macht auch niemand sonst, ne? Also es hat niemand in einem Phone 5 GHz, oder? Also ich kenne zumindest...
Ja, ist ein Killerfeature.
Naja, aber das wär schon so ein...
Schön zu haben.
Du könntest halt zu Hause deine ganzen WLANs auf 5 GHz bringen.
Aber wie wär's denn, wenn sie tatsächlich dieses Airplay-Mirroring, wenn sie das nutzen, um... Also Apple ist doch sowieso schon in diesem Spielemarkt. Da sind sie doch echt fett. Und da haben sie doch Nintendo, diese 3DS haben sie doch mal richtig schön abstreitig gemacht. Ich meine, wie wär's denn, wenn sie das wirklich zu einem, nicht nur zu irgendeinem kleinen, ja, ja, wir haben sowas jetzt drinne, hier Airplay-Video- Mirroring eingebaut, sondern wenn sie daraus ein richtig mega fettes 100%ig funktionierendes Feature machen. Die bringen neue in Apple TV raus, deren eigenen WLAN-Hotspot eingebaut hat. Und du kannst dich mit deinem iPhone davor setzen und du nimmst das Ding als Steuerung für dein Apple TV und kannst darauf so richtig geile Spiele auf deinem Fernseher spielen. Und es gibt halt so, und das wird so das Zentrum des gesamten Marketing. Ja, aber das nicht nur einfach. Ja, aber dass das nicht, dass das so einer der Haupt, dass wir noch irgendwas drinne haben, dass das wirklich perfekt funktioniert oder ist das wirklich so richtig, weil im Augenblick, also das ist zumindest bei mir zuhause ruckelts noch ganz ordentlich, über WLAN das zu machen.
Ja, das ist eine Beta-Version.
Ja, ich glaub auch, weil mein WLAN einfach zuhause nicht gut genug ist. Und darum bauen sie noch eben sozusagen, dass das auch wirklich perfekt funktioniert, die ganze Scheiße. Und dafür haben sie was drinne, um so richtig an diesen Spielemarkt ranzukommen, um da so Nintendo auch nochmal, und wie sie nicht alle heißen, nochmal auf einer anderen Ebene zu zeigen, wo der Hammer hängt.
Das tun sie glaube ich eh schon.
Naja, sie finden im Augenblick auf dem Fernseher quasi nicht statt.
Ja gut, aber das ist ja absehbar, dass das jetzt kommt, also gut. Aber die Frage war ja, was ist in dem iPhone drin?
Irgendeine Hardware-Anstattung dafür.
Was das Ding als Telefon oder als Smartphone toller und besser und erstrebenswerter macht, als das Gerät jetzt? Ich meine Akku ist natürlich immer ein Thema. Mehr Akku, mehr Speed, das geht immer. Aber so von der grundsätzlichen Funktionalität her, das kann doch nicht sein, dass uns da nichts einfällt.
Aber es wäre auch der Job von Apple, sich was Neues einfallen zu lassen.
Ich lese gerade, das Galaxy hat 5 GHz WLAN.
Ist das nicht ein Tablet?
Das ist doch das, was Apple kopiert hat.
Galaxy S2.
Aber wenn das Galaxy Apple kopiert hat und 5 GHz hat, dann müsste das ja auch schon drin sein. Apple, freischalten bitte!
Na gut, dann 5 GHz WLAN, schneller, mehr RAM, mehr Speicher, mehr Akku, ein bisschen ein tolleres Display, eine bessere Kamera.
Aber alles nur Upgrades, Upgrades, nichts Neues. Apple muss mit irgendwas Coolen im Neuen kommen.
Sonst wird das nicht stehen.
Was war denn beim iPhone 5?
Oder die sind echt fies und bringen wirklich diese Säcke an iPhone 5?
Aber was war beim iPhone 5 alles cool? Das Retina-Display vor allen Dingen. Und Kamera vorne und hinten und Facetime. Aber das war's dann.
Also es waren schon signifikante Upgrades.
Aber beim Display ist halt, also das brauch... Also für mich, also ich wüsste nicht, wie sie das jetzt noch sehr viel besser machen könnten, dass sie das als großes Feature preisen könnten. Also das Display ist schon mal...
Ehrlichkeit halt fixen. Ich will das irgendwie noch nicht so richtig glauben, dass uns da nichts einfällt, dass wir dieses Scheißteil noch mal anschauen.
Ich glaube, dass noch Features nachkommen, die einfach Software-Features, die noch nicht angekündigt sind. Zum Beispiel irgendwie sowas wie eine Navi... Sie haben ja diese Spracherkennungsbude gekauft, dass da in dem Bereich irgendwie nochmal was kommt.
Warum gehen sie von Google Maps weg? Das ist noch die Frage.
Genau. Also Google Maps ist nicht nur davon weggehen, sondern auch mal endlich die anderen Features nachrüsten, die Google Maps schon lange hat. Also ich hab die mal gesehen unter Android, die laden ja keine Bitmap-Karten runter, sondern die haben ja diese Vektorkarten, die du dann beliebig rein- und rauszoomen kannst. Also da ist Apple mittlerweile richtig hinterher. Und ich glaube nicht, dass sie so weit hinterher sind, weil sie einfach sagen, das ist uns egal, sondern weil sie da was richtiges in der Hinterhand haben. Und das wird dann... Welche Software-Features hat doch eigentlich bisher jedes neue iPhone auch irgendwelche Software-Features? Die sie einfach nicht bei der alten Generation nachgerüstet haben.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es da überhaupt eine API dafür gibt für diese Maps-Geschichte mit den Vektoren.
Naja, könnten sie sich ja mit Google hinsetzen, könnten mal einen Vertrag abschließen.
Ja, vielleicht sind sie nicht mehr so gut zu sprechen aufeinander.
Umso mehr ein Grund, dass Apple sich da was eigenes für einkauft.
Ich glaube nicht, dass... Meinst du, dass sie schon so weit sind?
Und ich glaube, das hätten sie schon mit in die Betas reingetan, weil das ist was, wo du halt auch deine ganzen Developer draufschicken willst, weil...
Bei Maps tut sich glaube ich nichts.
Ich glaube auch.
Ich glaube sowas ist... Nee, die eigentlichen Key-Features, die wirklich neuen Sachen, die haben sie ja immer geheim gehalten. Das waren immer irgendwelche Sachen, für die man keine APIs brauchte. Und die waren dann einfach in dem neuen Gerät drin. Ich weiß noch, bei dem 3GS war es zum Beispiel die Spracherkennung, die vorher nicht angekündigt war. Beim iPhone 4 war es Facetime, was ja jetzt auch... Also das war nicht vorher in der Version drin. Was war es noch? Was hatten noch iPhone 4, was man nicht per 3GS nachrüsten konnte? So eine Späße. Vernünftiges Text-to-Speech, dafür eine API. Ich meine, sie haben sie drin. Keine Ahnung, warum das nicht funktioniert. Und ja, sowas halt mal schön da reinpatten.
Also mit anderen Worten, wir haben keine Ahnung.
Ja, Management Summary. Inkrementelle Verbesserungen und ein Secret Super Mega Feature. Also NFC glaube ich halt auch nicht.
Also, sorry liebe Hörer.
Die Glaskugel ist trüb.
Ja, hört was anderes.
Und ich bleib mal noch mal bei der Uhr.
Falls ihr hier wirklich irgendwie Aussagen über die Zukunft erwartet habt, das Team kann es leider nicht leisten.
Aussagen über die Zukunft, ja, die Uhr. Mit Bluetooth 4 geht das nämlich. Da hast du nämlich deinen...
Ich geb dir gleich Bluetooth 4, du...
So, kommen wir zu anderen Dingen hier. Ich hab mir noch ein Produkt zu besprechen. Hab ich mir nämlich geschoppt. Und es ist das, von dem Steve Jobs meint, dass man das ja nicht braucht.
Und jetzt wo Steve weg ist, hast du gedacht, holst du es hier trotzdem?
Ja genau, jetzt ist er nicht mehr CEO, jetzt darf man das ja auch benutzen. Ein Stylus für das iPad oder für diese Touch-Devices. Und zwar handelt es sich dabei um den...
Wer ist der?
Bamboo Stylus von Wacom.
Die mit den Mal-Tablets. Was kostet denn das Ding?
Gute Frage, das hab ich bezahlt. Wo ist die Rechnung?
30 Euro sagt der Chat.
Für so einen blöden Stift, der nicht mal malen kann.
Nö, aber liegt gut in der Hand.
30 Euro?
Jetzt ist es natürlich ein bisschen bekloppt, dass man einfach, wo man auch den Finger benutzen kann, den Stift nimmt, dazu bräuchte man natürlich dann auch die passende ab. Die gibt es auch.
Business ist ja eigentlich etwas verstanden.
Nein, meins ist aus.
Meins ist aus, es können sein, dass ich das bin. Ich hab das aus technischen Gründen, hab ich das Telefon.
Davon hast du doch trotzdem Geräusche.
Es ist wahrscheinlich meins. Es tut mir leid, aber ich muss es aufwenden.
Also bei 3G hast du eben keine Geräusche mehr.
Ich muss es auf Empfang lassen.
Ja, aber nicht wenn er exklusiv 3G macht. Er hat den GSM noch meistens eingeschaltet. Was denn?
Podcast-Disziplin.
Jetzt möchte ich auch mal mit Dennis über andere Themen reden.
Aber er macht doch nicht beides gleichzeitig.
GSM und 3G. Klar macht der GSM und 3G gleichzeitig, oder?
Nein.
Wenn ich 3G anhabe, telefoniere ich nur über 3G?
Das ist der Witz. Du bist entweder in der 3G-Zelle eingebucht oder in der GSM-Zelle. Das ist unterschiedliche Technologie. Das ist was ganz anderes.
Und ich kann nicht einfach an beiden eingebucht sein? Oder Daten über 3G machen und dann auch über GSM?
Wolltest du das?
Nein, dann bräuchte ich das.
Weil GSM robuster ist und eine höhere Reichweite hat und 3G schneller ist, wenn ich es habe. Und weil es stromspannender ist als GSM.
Brauchst du zwei Chips?
Ich dachte bisher, die schreiten einfach beide Radios an und gut ist.
Nein, dahinter war das Beste, was gerade da ist.
Dann machen sie für iPhone 5 das mal endlich beide.
Darf ich jetzt noch mal diese Sache mit dem Stift erzählen? Warum habe ich mir das gekauft? Erstens gibt es eine App, mit der das prima funktioniert. Was hast du gemacht, Dennis? Hast du dich ausgesteckt?
Ich habe ausgesteckt einen Stecker, der die Sicherung hat nicht funktioniert.
Du hast dich vorher nicht richtig reingesteckert.
Ich habe da alles gesteckt, du hast das gemacht.
Ihr denkt euch auch echt die abgefahrensten Sachen aus. Nur, dass ich hier nicht zu Ende reden kann.
Erzähl, toller Stift!
Schön auf die Affiliate.
Also Tim hat jetzt gerade auf seinen Display geklickt, weil unsere...
Scheiß auf Affiliate klingt.
Die Hörer, die gerade den Videofeed nicht sehen können.
Jetzt halt doch mal das Maul. Das ist hier eine nette Anwendung. Das Ding heißt Penultimate. Das ist mal wieder so eine Anwendung, wo ich mir gedacht habe, so geil, jetzt kann ich mein iPad mal wieder für was benutzen, weil ich das Ding eigentlich nur zum Lesen benutze im Wesentlichen.
Das findest du super.
Und um Monster Soup zu spielen, weil man auf dem iPad höre, scores erzielt auf dem iPad als auf dem iPhone. Weil man da mehr Platz hat für den Finger, nicht so...
Ja, weil du schummelst also.
Nee, nee, das ist regulär. Das ist nicht die iPhone-Version, das ist eine Plus-Anwendung.
Ja, du wolltest über den Stift erzählen, erzähl über den Stift.
Ich sei nur neidisch, weil ich mehr Punkte habe als du.
Ich weiß nicht, was du meinst.
Null Punkte hast du nämlich.
Erzähl über den Stift.
Gut, ich erzähl erst mal über diese Anwendung, die heißt PenUltimate und die ist echt cool, weil die nicht dieses Problem hat, dass wenn du drauf malst, dass du erst, ja, du kannst so schreiben, malen, zeichnen, du kannst halt oben so typischerweise eine Schriftstärke und eine Farbe auswählen, du hast da deinen Radiergummi und kannst dann einfach auf so einem Blatt Papier rummalen. Du kannst Templates auswählen, ob das Ding liniert, kariert oder blanco ist und du kannst dann auch noch für wenig Geld noch weitere Papierlayouts nachinstallieren. Da machen sie noch mal so ein bisschen extra Mark. Und für mich ist das ganz cool, wenn ich gerade hier so in meinem Studio sitze und mir immer wieder überlege, wie ich dieses Studio umbaue. Um einfach so Konzepts zu machen. Nee, mit dem Finger ist das irgendwie was anderes. Also mit so einem dicken Wurstfinger kannst du einfach nicht so schön kleine Kitzellinien malen. Also gerade wenn es darum geht hier immer so...
Aber so dünn ist der Stift jetzt auch nicht.
Nein, der Stift ist nicht so dünn, aber du fühlst den irgendwie ganz anders. Also das ist so was anderes, ob du da deine ganze Hand davor hast.
Mach nochmal jetzt ein Quadrat mit deinem Finger so.
Ich hab halt immer den Finger auf dem Bildschirm.
Man sieht weniger meinst du?
Man sieht weniger, genau. Es ist einfach ein anderes Malen. Außerdem bin ich das auch so gewohnt mit dem Stift zu malen. Also das ist etwas, was ich natürlich so tue. Ich würde, wenn ich was notiere, dann hol ich mir nicht meine Fingerfarben raus und fang an irgendwie auf dem Stift.
Aber der Neandertaler, ja, der hatte auch keinen Stift und der hat seine Höhlenzeichnung auch mit dem Finger gemacht.
Und nicht mit einem Stock.
Ja, glaub ich auch.
Oder eine Feder vielleicht.
Können wir jetzt mal wieder über so eine Stifte reden? Oh Gott, dass ich den... Ich hab mir auch sowas schon mal gekauft. Das ist echt krass, das glaubt man nicht. Es lohnt sich, dafür Geld auszugeben. Ich hab damals einen Billigstift von Hama, glaube ich, gekauft. Und das ist... Hama ist versagt in so vielen Dingen, aber die versagen auch dabei, einfach einen Plastikstift herzustellen, mit dem man auf so einem iPhone-Display oder iPad-Display rumdatschen kann.
Also solche haben da auch versagt.
Der hat nicht funktioniert. Der hat einfach nur in der Hälfte aller Fälle reagiert und sowas. Und das Ding hier funktioniert zuverlässig.
Das funktioniert super. Es hat halt so eine kleine Gummikappe. Also es schont ja auch den Bildschirm, ist aber trotzdem relativ präzise. Ist jetzt nicht pixel-perfect.
Mach mal das kleinste Kästchen, das du damit malen kannst. Okay, so klein kriegst du mit dem Finger nicht hin, ne?
Nee.
Keine Chance.
Niemals.
Ich hab so ein Prototypen gesehen.
Ja, so auch mal, was weiß ich hier, sowas schraffieren und so. Also es malt sich halt im Wesentlichen so, wie du mit einem Bleistift auch malst. Mit einem Bleistift hätte ich jetzt noch ein bisschen mehr Fine-Grain-Control, aber der Vorteil hier ist natürlich, ich kann es austrocknen, kann es abspeichern, ich kann es exportieren, etc., Und vor allem exportiert sich das auch, warte mal, jetzt bin ich gerade, nichts Falsches sagen. Exportiert sich das als, wie exportiert sich das denn noch mal? Notizbuch mailen, genau, als PDF. Und ich glaube, du hast dann auch Linien-Grafik.
Da haben wir doch einen Feature für das iPhone 5, eine Stifthalterung.
Geil, iPhone 5 mit Stylus, damit so zum reinstecken.
Nee, nee, ohne Stylus, aber mit Stifthalterung.
Ich schick mir das gerade mal hier. Ich hab das noch gar nicht ausprobiert.
Es gibt aber auch so Stifte, da hab ich leider nur mal ein Video von gesehen. Ich weiß nicht, ob das jemals in Produktion gegangen ist. Das sah so aus wie eine Unterlegscheibe, die an einem Stift hing. Das hatte den Vorteil, dass man exakt die Stelle sehen konnte, an der man gemalt hat. Hier sieht man ja nicht wirklich, weil die Spitze ist ja doch relativ dick vorne, sodass man nicht so präzise arbeiten kann. Da war so ein Loch in der Mitte, wo man durchgucken und das Haar genau sagen konnte, da wäre ich jetzt hin touchen. Das ist ja total verpixelt.
Das ist keine Line Art. Das sind keine Vektoren. Aber du kannst das halt mal eben als PDF so zuschicken und das ist natürlich echt prima. Also wenn du jetzt wirklich so eine Session hast, ja, keine Ahnung, hier Camp, Vorbereitung, machst du irgendwelche Ideen, wie du dein Zeltlayout machst, zack, noch eine Seite, noch eine Seite, und am Ende zack, hier PDF schickst du an alle. Hast du einfach dieses Problem Notizen irgendwie erschlagen, aber du hast halt trotzdem dieses User Interface Stift. Und dieser Vacuum Stift, der ist irgendwie schön, der ist schön, der ist wertig, der liegt irgendwie auch so ein bisschen schwerer in der Hand, also jetzt nicht zu schwer, aber der hat halt so, hat einfach so ein gewisses Gewicht, das ist jetzt nicht so ein Klasseteil.
Also es muss ja ein Software-Problem sein, irgendeine Software mit der man, mit der mehrere, also zwei iPads, jeder hat so seinen Stift und malt rum, und dass man quasi an derselben Grafik arbeitet.
Schön, also meines Wissens leistet dieses Penultimate das nicht, vielleicht gibt es da so eine App. Was ich sehr gut finde an dieser App ist, im Gegensatz zu Sachen wie hier Adobe, wie heißt das? Nicht Elements.
Ach, dieses Photoshop Mini.
Es gibt da auch so eine Scribble-Sache und so weiter. Die haben immer das Problem, wenn du da irgendwie so eine Kritzellinie machst, dass die während du sie malst, ist sie so relativ jaggy. Und dann lässt du halt los, und dann kommt die Software und berechnet dir da eben die Rundungen rein. Aber du siehst nicht während des Malens schon das, was du eigentlich gemalt hast. Und das ist halt hier bei diesem Penultimate nicht. Also während du hier eine Linie ziehst, trackt der irgendwie das und malt das. Das hat so einen ganz leichten Delay. Hast du das eigentlich auf deinem Ausbild, ob der Delay da genauso ist auf dem iPad 2?
Es war auf jeden Fall ein Delay da. Also es ist nicht instant.
Aber vielleicht ist der Delay noch kleiner als hier?
Kannst du das mal vergleichen?
Ich kann jetzt auch einfach mein iPad mal überreichen. Mal dein iPad. Öffne hier vielleicht noch dieses Penultimate.
Was denn?
Da kommt schon wieder ein Affen auf dem Bild. Schmerzen. Nicht weiterscrollen, das war es doch hier schon.
Also der Unterschied ist nicht existent.
Ich paste es mal in den Chat. Ich finde ja für diesen Internethumor immer wieder großartig, dass so ganz normale, unspektakuläre Bilder mit wenig Zeilen, Text zu doch großartigen Gesamtkunstwerken zusammenkomponiert werden. So geschehen auch bei dem letzten Link im Chat, wer nicht dabei war, live.
Hat's verpasst. Oder muss ein Chat-Log nachgraben.
Eine App, die ich gerne mal wieder auf dem iPad nutze, die ich mal wieder ein bisschen ausgeburgelt habe.
10.06 Uhr, 22.06 Uhr.
Ist Flipboard, falls sich noch jemand daran erinnert, die ich sehr mag. Ah, jetzt lacht Tim auch noch über den schlechten.
Das ist aber wirklich nicht toll.
Welcher Film ist das denn?
Terminator 3 ist das, glaube ich, oder?
Nee, 2. Wo er in die Bar geht und sich erst mal Klamotten holt, weil er so nackig da auf der Welt gefallen ist. Na ja, gut, weitermachen.
Ja, Flipboard, kann man sich mal wieder angucken. Macht echt Spaß damit, Artikel zu lesen und so'n Scheiß. Und Twitter und dieses ganze Getöse. Buddelt das mal aus. Ist besser geworden als es früher war.
Ist ein bisschen sprachlos oder wie?
Ich lese dir gerade den letzten Link, der hier gerade reingekommen ist. Ich trau mich aber gerade nicht, das Thema wieder anzureißen.
Mit dem Stift?
Google.
Ach so, das war eben gerade auch bei Gruber.
Das ist wirklich, das geht echt zu Ende. So, das war Penultimate und der tolle Bamboo-Stift. Und wer schon immer überlegt hat, sein iPad so als Notizblatt zu benutzen, das ist eine Kombination, die ich super finde. Ich fände es cool, wenn ihr noch andere Tipps habt, was es sonst noch so für Scribble-Applikationen gibt, die auch gut sind. Habe ich jetzt eigentlich gesagt, warum ich das Ding so gut finde, dass er die Linie gleich macht? Ja, habe ich gesagt. Genau.
Also ich fände es tatsächlich noch gut oder wünschenswert, wenn da die Linien, Grafiken kämen, also als PDF. Und, wann ihr Experten, ich habe ja immer noch keinen iPad, und ich will ja ein iPad auch haben, wann ist nochmal der Release-Cycle, oder wie ist der Release-Cycle für das iPad ihr Ausgleich?
Frühjahr würde ich sagen.
Frühjahr.
Was heißt wie jedes Jahr? Es gab bisher zwei iPads, und die waren nicht in einem Jahresabstand.
Fast. Neun Monate? Aber angekündigt wurden sie zum gleichen Zeitpunkt. Warte mal. Das erste iPad hatte ich kurz nach der Republik, also auf der ersten vorletztes Jahr sind alle auf...
Du schlagst doch in deiner fucking Wikipedia nach.
In deiner fucking Allwissen in Müllhalde.
Ich kann ja mal kurz noch was anderes berichten. Ich hab nämlich neues Internet hier.
Stimmt, du hast jetzt ja VDSL haben wir gehört, ne?
VDSL 2.
Da-da.
Ging als erstes schon gleich kaputt raus.
50 Megabit. Na ja, ich bin jetzt Telekom-Kunde geworden mit einem weinenden Auge, wobei ich zugeben muss, dass ich nicht damit gerechnet hätte, dass die Bestell-
und Installations-Experience...
Also das eine wurde Ende März 2010 verkauft, das andere am 11. März 2010. Exakt ein Jahr.
Verkauft.
Ne, das eine wurde im März angekündigt, kam noch aber erst Ende April oder Mai raus.
Das eine wurde im Januar angekündigt und kam im März raus. Die zweite Version Ende April. Und ich weiß nämlich noch, dass auf der Republika vor zwei Jahren saßen alle mit einem iPad 1 rum. Und vor einem Jahr war dann das iPad 2 angekündigt. Ich glaube, ich hatte es sogar schon. Ja, ich hatte es. Ich habe probiert, auf der Republika meinen iPad 1 zu verkloppen. Die fucking Wikipedia hat es gewusst.
Die fucking Wikipedia weiß es. Es war wieder besser. Besser, besser, besser. Besserpedia. So. Wir sind sehr konsequent hier. Was wollte ich gerade erzählen? Ach ja, Internet. Ich habe also die Telekom-Nummer gekauft und war sehr überrascht. Also erstens, ich habe da schon länger mit dem Gedanken gespielt. Das Ganze wurde dann ausgelöst durch diese Drohung, dass es irgendwie demnächst kein richtiges ISDN mehr geben soll dazu, sondern nur noch so ISDN über Internet simuliert. Das kommt für mich natürlich nicht in Frage, weil ich bin ja Altschul und bei ISDN habe ich auch so romantische Gefühle. Aber vor allem habe ich hier so ISDN-Kollegs, von denen ich möchte, dass sie ordentlich funktionieren. Und da ist natürlich, also das wollte ich einfach nicht. Deswegen habe ich dann gleich zugeschlagen, habe gesagt, ok, jetzt kauf ich, weil ich keinen anderen Provider gefunden habe, der mir schnelles Internet liefern kann. Also weder Kabel Deutschland, noch Alice, noch irgendeiner anderer, war in der Lage, irgendwas schnelles zu liefern. Hierher, also an dieser Adresse, auch wenn es in der Nähe angeblich überall irgendwo was gibt, aber es ist ja immer die Sache, muss ja genau in deiner Hausnummer auch irgendwie angeschlossen werden können. Und da gab es halt nur Telekom. Da hab ich das bestellt und war die ganze Zeit überrascht, wie freundlich die alle waren und wie kompetent die sich da alle verhalten haben. Besonders bei dieser Business-Hotline, wo ich gleich angerufen habe. Ich hatte eben guter Tipp, einfach gleich Business-Hotline anrufen.
Auch wenn du gar nicht Business-Kunde bist?
Ich weiß nicht genau, was sie als Business bezahlen. Ich bin selbstständig.
Aber zahlst du da noch business-mäßig?
Nö, das ist ja eigentlich der normale VDSL-Kram. Das kostet 50 Euro im Monat und dann hast du 50 Megabit down und 10 Megabit up. Und die kriege ich auch. Also ich übertrage Daten mit SFTP mit 1,1 Megabyte pro Sekunde hoch.
Das haben wir im Club auch.
Und das ist schon...
Achso, nicht sogar 100 MB zu Hause?
60.
Ja, aber de facto ist das eine Verelffachung meiner Upload-Kapazität. Ja. Das heißt, ich kann jetzt einen Podcast in no time hochladen, wo ich hier vorher eine Stunde rumgesessen habe und dann am Ende festgestellt habe, oh Scheiße, war die falsche Datei. Und dann noch mal eine Stunde, kann ich halt jetzt das ganz anders machen. Also ich hab mal wieder was wegeditiert, was mich immer total genervt hat. Dann war natürlich das Problem, dass ich dafür ein passendes Modem brauchte. Und da hatte ich ja noch diese Fritzbox hier rumliegen, die zuletzt so schlecht funktioniert hat. Die war dann auch kaputt, wie sich herausgestellt hat. Die hab ich dann noch mal getauscht. Und mit der neuen ging es dann auch. Das heißt, damit konnte ich dann eben ohne jetzt hier so ein komisches Speedport-Teil da von der Telekom mieten zu müssen rangehen. Allerdings dachte ich mir das so, dass ich das Teil eben nur in diesem DSL-Modem-Konfiguration betreibe. Die kann man da auch einstellen, sodass er dann theoretisch dahinter einem anderen Gerät über PPP-OE den Zugang zu dem DSL geben müsste.
Dann dachte ich mir, könnte ich ja meine Time Capsule wie vor verwenden zum Einwählen. Ja, Pustekuchen. Die Time Capsule kommt da nicht durch. Ich weiß nicht warum. Ich hab dann über Twitter ein bisschen herumgefragt. Wenige Leute haben diese Konfiguration. Irgendjemand meinte, bei ihm ginge es.
Die gibt's ja immer.
Na gut, aber das macht für mich halt so ganz den Eindruck, als würde da generell irgendwas nicht gehen. Ich weiß nicht was. Ich hab keine Ahnung. Ich hab mir jetzt auch da keine Traces gemacht. Für sowas hab ich viel zu wenig Zeit. Sollte das jemand mal gelungen sein, diese Kombination würde mich das interessieren. Find ich halt ein bisschen schade, weil ich hab einfach mit dieser FritzBock Einwählprobleme. Also es ist einfach dieses ganze Back to my Mac-Dingsbums. Das funktioniert einfach mit den Apple-Routern deutlich besser. Und es ist mir dann auch egal warum. Ich will mich einfach zuverlässig hier einwählen können, von außen und sicher. Und ich hab da einfach nicht dieselbe Experience. Ich hab keine Ahnung, woran es liegt. Man kriegt da ja auch nicht immer die Erklärung. Aber hier auch so mit, ich starte irgendwelche BitTorrent-Client und die kriegen dann halt auch keine Ports freigekloppt in dem Router. Bei dem einen geht es, bei dem anderen geht es nicht. Bei dem anderen Rechner mit Nutt-PMP oder U-PMP. I don't know, wer da der Schuldige ist, ob es an der Fritzbox liegt, ob es an dieser U-PMP-Library liegt, die alle verwenden. Ich weiß es nicht. Tatsache ist nur, wenn ich eine Time Capsule habe, dann funktioniert alles. Dann komme ich problemlos rein und problemlos raus und mit der Fritzbox komme ich weder problemlos rein, noch problemlos raus. Und mal geht es und mal geht es nicht. Und das macht mich total matig. Und deswegen hätte ich halt gerne die andere Konfiguration, die sich aber so jetzt irgendwie nicht erschließt. Alternative wäre, dass ich mir noch so ein VDSL Modem hole und da dann eben das mit ohne Fritzbox mache, aber da das Ding halt hier eh noch rum stand, dachte ich mir so, bringe ich das Ding mal auf, wie auch für irgendwas zum Einsatz. Weil ansonsten ist der Nutzen von diesem Gerät für mich doch eher überschaubar. Aber meine Telekom Experience war gut. Auch so mit dem Typen, der hier irgendwie kam, es angeschlossen hat, alles sehr kompetent.
Da war ich, als ich hier den umgezogen bin, war ich auch extrem glücklich bei so einer alten, das was, so gesagt, hey, ich werd umziehen, haben die irgendwie eingetütet, ja, alles klar, am Montag, also ich bin Sonntag umgezogen, Montag, nach dem Umzug, stand die Telekomfrau da, hat als erstes, so, sind sie jetzt so weit, können wir jetzt ihren alten DSL-Anschluss abschalten? Ich meine, wie oft hat man erlebt, dass die eine Woche vorher den alten DSL da am Schluss abschalten oder so was, ja, sie ziehen noch nächste Woche um, jetzt wird der halt abgeschaltet erst in dem Moment, in dem es wirklich fällig ist. Und ja, und jetzt fangen sie halt an hier und dann war nicht mal ein Kabel gelegt, da hatte ich erstmal spontan das Kabel angeschlossen unten im Keller und ein neues Kabel verlegt. Und ich dachte, das dauert bestimmt drei Wochen, aber es hat echt gut geklappt.
Ja, das war allerdings, also bei Kabel Deutschland war das auch sehr ähnlich. Also da bin ich ja auch nach wie vor sehr zufrieden eigentlich.
Habt ihr die frohe Botschaft bekommen, man kann Final Cut Pro wieder kaufen?
Ja, hier fragt gerade noch einer, hier gibt es so ein Wunschthema noch im Chat, ob ich erzählen könnte, warum ich zu Vim gewechselt bin und was der Vorteil zu Textmade ist. Ja, also lange Zeit haben wir die Webcoder auf dem Mac, ich mach's mal, versuch's mal kurz zu halten, haben wir Textmade benutzt. Textmade war ja mal eigentlich der tolle Texteditor, wenn man halt so Ruby gecodet hat und so, hatte halt einfach ein paar schicke Features, hat sich gut angefühlt. Aber wird seit eh und je nicht mehr weiterentwickelt. Und naja, und irgendwie haben irgendwie alle um mich rum sowieso schon immer Vim oder Emacs benutzt. Und wenn man halt auch ein bisschen Server administriert hat, wie Dennis schon richtig bemerkt hat, das ist den unglaublichen Vorteil, dass der Editor auf dem Server im Terminal der gleiche ist, den man halt sonst auf dem Desktop auch schon benutzt. Das heißt, man kennt schon die ganzen Shortcuts und so weiter und so fort und muss sich gar nicht umgewöhnen, weil sonst ist es so, hast halt deinen clicky-bunty Texteditor auf dem Desktop und wenn du dann auf dem Server unterwegs bist und dann ist halt gerade nur Vim installiert oder VI., stehst du erst mal doof da. Naja, und dann ist halt der Vim tatsächlich auch einfach sehr mächtig. Also wenn man erstmal irgendwie so das grundsätzliche, die grundsätzliche Operation von diesem Vim verstanden hat und wie die Commands da funktionieren, macht das doch alles ziemlich Sinn und man kann sich da doch sehr gut arrangieren. Allerdings würde ich das jetzt auch nicht jedem empfehlen und es gibt jetzt übrigens einen Editor, den ich gerade beta teste und wo ihr euch auch um einen Invite bewerben könnt. Das ist der erste native OSX Editor, der Textmade ernsthaft...
MacVim hat ein Diskettensymbol zum Speichern.
Ich hab die toolbar nicht eingeblendet. Ich seh das gar nicht.
Das ist halt klassisch, man. Bei den Telefonen ist da auch noch ein Hörer.
Das ist Retro.
Das macht man heute so.
Ja, aber diese Hörer gibt es auch noch.
Hier zum Beispiel ist ein Hörer.
Ja, da bist du halt hinterher mit deinen Geräten. Aber das iPhone hat keinen Hörer.
Jetzt lass mich mal hier kurz weiter erzählen. Also, wer sich wirklich diesen Mac-Wim antun will, oder Wim, oder was auch immer, dem sei gesagt, ladet euch irgendwie dieses Vi- und Wim-Buch von O'Reilly runter, lest die ersten zwei Kapitel, das reicht schon, dann habt ihr den verstandenen Editor, wie das so funktioniert, und dann kann man mit diesem Editor schon sehr, sehr, sehr viel machen. Der stürzt selten ab, der, also so gut wie nie eigentlich, der frisst große Textfiles, der hat Split-Views, der hat unendlich viele Plugins, und man kann wirklich alles damit tun. Toll! Wenn man lieber klicken will, gibt's jetzt eben für Mac zumindest eine würdige Text-Made-Alternative, die sich da anbahnt. Der Link ist gerade im Chat gelandet. Chocolate-App heißt da Schokolade. Und der, wenn man da in den Irk-Channel geht und sagt hier, ich hätte gerne mal so ein Beta-Invite, da hängen meistens Leute rum, die noch einen Invite-Code übrig haben. Dann kriegt man den und dann könnt ihr euch in einer Kette Invite-Codes schicken. Ich hab leider meinen, den ich bisher habe, schon weggegeben. Das Schöne an diesem Chocolate ist, der hat die Features, die ich in Wim habe und in Text-Made vermisse, zum Beispiel Split-Editing. Sie haben es auch so gelöst. Also mit zwei Dateien gleichzeitig arbeiten. Genau. Das ist auch sehr schön zu benutzen. Man klickt ja einfach am Project-Drawer mit Command gedrückt an. Einfach so Multiple Select und dann kriegst du die in den Split-Views. Hat auch dieses Konzept von Bundles und Snippets in Text-Made. Der Project-Drawer ist auch ganz schick und aufgeräumt, hat auch schon viele Languages drin und Themes und eigentlich alles, was man so braucht. Und wie gesagt, das wäre so der Editor, den ich, wenn jetzt Text-Made wirklich einfach so bleibt, wie er ist, wonach es ja auch aussieht. Das Duke Nukem Forever, der Text-Editor sozusagen. Dann würde ich glaube ich eher auf den gehen.
Duke Nukem Forever ist rausgekommen.
Ja eben, aber die haben auch viel früher angefangen. Text-Mails hat er erst später. Das kann auch lange dauern. Der fühlt sich bisher ganz gut an. Er ist halt in der Version 0.03.4 gerade. Das heißt, die sind wirklich noch sehr am Anfang. Aber dafür kann er schon einiges. Und gecrashed ist er mir bisher auch nicht. Also wie gesagt, ich hab den Invite-Code so bekommen. Ich hab die angetwittert, da kam nichts. Dann bin ich in den Irk-Channel gegangen, hab gesagt, ich will einen Invite-Code. Und dann hatte einer gleich einen übrig. Und jetzt geht der gerade in der Firma rum, weil jeder Neue, der sich anmeldet, kriegt halt auch einen Invite-Code. Das heißt, ihr könnt euch hier mal organisieren. Und dann, Moment, bei der nächsten Sendung im Chat schreiben, die längste Invite-Code-Kette, die ihr zustande bekommen habt. Hab ich eigentlich mal? Ja, ich hab's mehrfach probiert.
Auch jetzt so mit der Zeder?
Ja, eigentlich jede Version. Immer wenn der Gruber und so schreibt, neue BB-Edit-Versionen, und toll, hab ich's mir runtergeladen.
Und das ist halt von Mac OS normal, ohne X-Zeiten, und das geht irgendwie gar nicht.
Ja, nee, die machen halt schon viel. Die haben coole Features, aber ich glaube, das ist wirklich eher ein Text-Editor als ein Programmier-Editor. Also für Text-Editing ist er cool. Man kann auch damit programmieren, aber ich finde, Text-Mate, MacWim, Chocolate, die sind da irgendwie näher dran am Programmieren, oder irgendwie so das Syntax-Highlighting und schon alleine.
Aber können Text-Mate, ich hab da nie so eine vernünftige Autocompletion hinbekommen?
Na, die benutzen die USX Autocompletion. Wenn du Escape drückst, wird alles completed, was du schon mal getippt hast.
Aber nur in dem Dokument?
Genau, bei MacWim ist das zum Beispiel so, da hast du halt eine Projektweite Completion. Also alles, was in diesem ganzen Projekt schon mal getippt wurde, kannst du completen, das ist schon um einiges besser.
Aber keine automatische oder irgendwie sowas?
Genau, also es ist keine IDE, die sprachagnostisch da irgendwelche Autocompletions macht.
Also ich bin ja mittlerweile, ich hab ja einen PHP mit einer IDE entwickelt, ich entwickelt JavaScript mit einer IDE, jetzt Xcode, also jetzt Objective-C selbstverständlich auch und ich möchte ehrlich gesagt nicht mehr ohne, ich möchte nicht mehr ohne vernünftige Autocompletion arbeiten und mit einer Navigation, mit der man automatisch zu den entsprechenden Definitionen springen kann und sowas.
Das hast du im Editor auch, Jump to definition, das hast du in Macrim, das hast du in TextMate, das hast du in Chocolate, das gibt's schon. Was halt viele so von IDE's dann immer sagen, ja und hier Refactoring Support, aber das ist halt bei so dynamischen Scriptsprachen wie Ruby, wo du halt den Meter im Meter im Meter Programming betreibst, das ist halt, funktioniert's nur noch bis zum gewissen Grad und eigentlich ist es da nicht mehr sinnvoll. Projektnavigation ist für so eine Projekte auch schnell genug. Klar, weil in so einer Objective-C-Geschichte oder Java, wo du halt auch tausende Klassen und Files und Header und sonst was hast, ist eine IDE unerlässlich, aber für so dynamische Scriptsprachen brauche ich es überhaupt gar nicht.
Du machst Ruby, ne?
Ne und hör auf mit diesen Java-Programmen.
Hast du das mal ausprobiert?
Ne, ja, habe ich, aber geht gar nicht. Wirklich, da kriege ich total sofort Plug, wenn ich sowas sehe.
Also ich mache ja viel mit PHP-Storm nach wie vor, so JavaScript-Zeug und das bisschen PHP-Zeug und HTML. Und die Usability mag eine totale... Also das sieht aus, ja, ist Java, sieht halt nicht gut aus. Aber diese JetBrains-Leute, die haben... Echt mal so für PHP, JavaScript und HTML haben die einfach mal die beste IDE, die man sich vorstellen kann. Und die haben auch eine Ruby-IDE, RubyMine. Und wenn die auch nur halb so gut ist wie die PHP-Variante, dann ist das echt eine fucking geile IDE. Also die ist wirklich... Ich hab selten... Und gerade so mit Refactoring, die kann JavaScript refactoren. Und zwar wirklich auf einem Niveau, bei dem ich... Also ohne, dass irgendwas fehlt. Das ist...
Ich hab... Na, ich bin einfach kein IDE-Freund.
Gib dir mal eine Woche.
Nee, ich hab's schon mehr verprobiert, glaub mir.
Eine vernünftige Autocompletion ist echt was wert.
Ich bin kein IDE-Mensch. Ich bin ein Editor-Mensch.
Womit codest du denn, Max, jetzt so eine Object, das sie machst?
Mit Xcode. Und ich bin... Ich weiß nicht, ich hab nie mit Xcode 3 gearbeitet. Du jammerst ja auch so über Xcode 3. Ich komm ja mit Xcode... Also ja, es crasht hin und wieder mal. Und es könnte ruhig besser sein. Aber ich bin groß und ganz damit zufrieden. Und ich find's ganz gut. Und für die Autocompletion, die ist... Also die Features, die IDE-Features sind tatsächlich in vielen Bereichen in PHP Storm besser. Also da kann man zum Beispiel so find usages, was ja manchmal ganz geil ist, so finde mir automatisch alle Stellen, an denen dieser Code verwendet wird und gerufen wird, um zu gucken können, kann ich jetzt hier, kann der Parameter raus, kann ich das Problem ins Reflektor und ohne, dass es Probleme gibt und sowas. So was hat... fehlt mir in Xcode doch.
2011, Friends, don't let their friends coach websites in PHP. War der Tweet vom HTML5 Twitter-Account fand ich ganz großartig.
So Leute, heute müssen wir mal ein bisschen eher zum Ende kommen. Denn, also jetzt haben wir eh keine Themen mehr.
Und dein Babysitter ist nur bis elf bezahlt.
Babysitter all.
Aber wir haben es doch, oder? Ich meine, alles gesagt. Wir haben keine Ahnung, wie das iPhone 5 wird. Wir haben keine Angst.
Was ist mit Emacs? Wir müssen schon mal eine halbe Stunde über Emacs reden.
Darüber machen wir noch mal eine eigene Sendung.
Und ich mach doch jetzt auch ein bisschen Erlang.
Darüber machen wir auch noch mal eine eigene Sendung. Wir können ja einfach mal jetzt...
Da komm ich dann einfach nicht mehr, dann kann Dennis da noch ein bisschen über ZFS erzählen.
Oder? Ich meine, ist da auch mal ganz gut, wenn man mal nicht ganz so müde ist.
Zuhause steht noch Kartoffelsuppe auf dem Herd, die muss ich auch noch essen.
Siehst du mal.
Die dürfte jetzt verkocht sein.
Nee, nee, die war gestern schon fertig und jetzt ist sie so richtig durchgezogen.
Ja, dann hoffe ich, dass es wieder amüsant war, hier mit uns.
Ja.
Vieren. Lieber so dahin zinieren und Rätsel raten und...
Zinilen.
Voll den Plan, wie die Teenager heutzutage so drauf sind. Naja, aber wir halten uns wacker. Dennis, willst du noch was dazu sagen?
Deinen Schluss, Pedro E.
Ich will jetzt noch das halbe Stunde erzählen. Ich darf nicht.
Ich will gar nichts sagen. E-Max, ne? Command, Meta, X, S und dann passieren ganz magische Dinge. Alles klar.
Danke, dass ihr hier seid und wir sehen uns bald!